Scholastic audio presents Wings of Fire
Book 7, Winter Turning, by 2ET Sutherland
read by Shannon McManus.
The Jade Mountain Prophecy.
Beware the darkness of dragons.
Beware the stalker of dreams.
Beware the talons of power and fire.
Beware one who is not what she seems.
Something is coming to shake the earth.
Something is coming to scorch the
ground.
Jade Mountain will fall beneath thunder
and ice.
Unless the lost city of night can be
found.
Prologue.
Two years ago.
It was one of those days so blue and
sunny that you had to be flying.
The sky reached in your window 1st thing
in the morning and dragged you out
flinging you up and up and up into the
beautiful wing catching wind.
You had to soar and spin and dive, because
a day this perfect might never come
again.
And sometimes you had to take your little
brother with you, and sometimes you had
to hurl his cautious tail into wonderful
danger, because the wind was roaring, and
the sky was glorious, and the sunlight
promised that nothing bad could possibly
happen.
Hailstorm did a flip in the air
laughing.
The currents are mine to command, he
shouted.
Can you catch me?
No, you cannot.
No one can.
I'm the commander of the sky.
I think the Sky Wings would disagree
Winter called.
He twisted to scan the cloudless blue
emptiness around them.
Stop worrying, Hailstorm said, spinning
into a dive.
There weren't any dragons within flight
site.
It was a perfect day for winter's 1st
expedition into Skywing territory
especially if he really wanted to find a
scavenger.
This doesn't feel safe, Winter observed
as they landed.
His talons sank into a pile of leaves, and
he jumped back, eyeing them with
suspicion.
Yikes!
What are all these flappy things on the
ground?
They come from the trees.
Hailstorm said, laughing.
No need to panic, little brother.
We're here for your weird little
obsession, so get excited.
He took a deep breath, inhaling the
smells of the forest, and sneezed
loudly.
Winter protested.
This is the Sky Kingdom.
There could be enemy soldiers
everywhere.
Lounging around in the woods near a
scavenger den?
Hellstorms said skeptically.
Doubtful.
He flicked his brother's wing with his
tail.
Winter was only three, but he was very
amusing, a lot more fun to tease than
their sister.
He also tried so hard, and still had so
much trouble with the rankings.
Poor dragon.
Hailstorm wished he could relax a little
bit.
Not everyone could be the best at
everything, although it most likely
didn't help that his big brother actually
was.
Despite his worry, Winter couldn't hide
the excitement spilling over his face.
Is there really a scavenger den here?
He blinked at the trees. as if hoping a
scavenger would suddenly fall out of one
of them.
That's what the patrol reported, Hellstorm
said with a shrug.
They said they saw at least 5 scavengers
and that many usually means a den
nearby.
Now that they were surrounded by trees
though, he had no idea how they were
going to find one of the little creatures
for winter.
Hailstorm had never actually seen one
himself.
There were 100s of furry smells in the
forest, but he couldn't even figure out
which ones were scavengers, and which
ones were squirrels.
The only thing he was sure of was that
none of them were polar bears.
What are you going to do if we do catch
one?
Hailstorm asked, turning over a fallen
log and checking underneath.
Nope, no scavengers there.
You know they can't survive in the ice
kingdom.
You won't be able to keep it.
I just want to look at it, Winter said.
Have you ever seen a scavenger up close?
I read that they wear other animals' skins
on top of their own skin.
Isn't that bizarre?
Why would they do that?
Same reason mother has that necklace of
sky wing teeth?
Hailstorm said authoritatively?
To make themselves seem more dangerous
and scare off any possible predators
obviously.
Winter glanced at the sky.
Speaking of sky wings.
We're fine, hailstorm insisted, tempted
to jab Winter's worrying snout with one
of his claws.
Where several mountains away from Queen
Scarlet's palace.
No one is going to find us here.
But won't father be furious?
Winter asked, twitching slightly.
Hailstorm ruffled his wings, as though he
was trying to shake the idea of their
parents right off his scales.
Who cares?
he said.
I'm going to be 2nd in command of the ice
wing army one day.
Queen Glacier already said so.
Mother and father can't do anything to
me.
They can do plenty to me, Winter said.
Not if you get high enough in their
rankings, Hellstorm said with a grin.
Which you do by being brave and strong
and bold.
I thought it was by being smart and
following orders, Winter said.
Hailstorm dismissed this with a wave of
his tail.
Dragons in the 3rd circle and below can
worry about following orders.
First circle dragons have to prepare to
be leaders one day.
Besides, I'm the best fighter in the ice
kingdom.
Even if we do get caught, I think I can
take a couple of sky wings.
Oh, really?
Said a mocking voice behind them.
How about 14 Sky Wings?
Hailstorm world around, red and orange
dragons were slithering between the trees
surrounding them.
Their eyes glittered in the golden light
and their enormous wings were tucked in
close to avoid the snarling branches
above.
His heart sank.
This couldn't be happening.
Bad luck wasn't a thing that ever
wandered into Hillstorm's life, and this
was the worst luck he could have
imagined.
14 Sky Wing warriors were more than he
could fight alone.
Definitely more than he could fight and
still keep his little brother safe.
Second in command, the ice wing army, said
the one who'd spoken.
A dark red female dragon with an
unusually long neck and tail.
Small rubies glittered from between the
scales around her eyes, larger ones
clicked together on spiky silver rings
around her claws.
Then you are a prize, aren't you?
Mother will be so interested to meet
you.
Let us go, Winter said fiercely.
Queen Glacier will have your heads on
spikes by morning if you dare touch us.
Oh?
Very attached to you, is she?
The dragon said, arching her brows.
That's absolutely our favorite kind of
prisoner.
Seize them, she ordered the other sky
wings.
Perhaps you can take us, Hillstorm said
drawing in a hissing breath.
But how many of you are going to die
first?
Do you know what happens when frost
breath touches your eyes?
Do you know what it feels like to watch
your legs snap like a broken icicle?
Or how long it takes frozen ears to turn
black and fall off?
His voice was cold.
His threats slicing the air between them
like a freezing wind.
Winter raised his tail and inhaled
working up a gust of frost breath of his
own.
So a few dragons die.
So the female sky wing with a shrug.
The other sky wings exchanged uneasy
looks.
You'll be our prisoners in the end either
way.
Here's another idea, said Hillstorm.
Take me and let winter go, and nobody has
to die.
What?
Winter cried.
You don't need him, Hellstorm said
ignoring his brother.
He's completely useless.
Queen Glacier won't trade any prisoners
for him.
Nobody back in the Ice Kingdom would care
whether they ever saw him again.
And you wouldn't even be interesting in
your queen's arena.
He can barely fight.
He'd be dead in 2 heartbeats.
Winter looked as though the world was
crumbling beneath his talons.
Is that true?
He whispered.
Hillstorm, is that really what you
think?
If he's so useless, the sky wing asked
why do you care if we let him go?
Hailstorm lifted, and settled his wings
again?
Call me sentimental.
He's my little brother, and I quite like
him.
Even if I wouldn't want him beside me in
a battle.
Besides, I know I'm worth trading.
Whereas he'll be bones in your arena
sands before the month is up.
Ouch, said the Sky Wing.
Giving winter an amused, pitying look.
I think I'd probably rather die in battle
than listen to my brother talk about me
that way.
I'm not useless.
Winter said furiously.
Bite me and you'll see.
Oh, go home, Hellstorm said, swatting
winter's wing.
You want to be useful?
Fine.
Get out of here.
Go tell our parents where I am.
I'm not leaving you, Winter protested, in
a half choked voice.
I'm not going to hand you over to them
without even trying to save you.
Yes, you are, Hailstorm said.
This is the real war, little brother.
Go away and let the true warriors fight
it.
Nobody wants to watch you pathetically
flail around and then die pointlessly.
Oh my, I can't even listen to this
anymore, said the Sky Wing.
I swing.
I'm going to be more merciful than your
heartless brother and let you go.
You can tell Queen Glacier that Queen
Scarlet will consider a trade.
If she'd like to send a messenger to open
negotiations.
Trade for who?
Hailstorm wondered.
The Ice Wings didn't have any political
prisoners of importance.
Where would they even keep them?
The ice palace was too cold for dragons
from any other tribe to survive it for
long.
He shoved winter away, trying to ignore
the anguished look in his brother's
eyes.
Fly away, he growled, right now.
He could see that the only way to make
winter leave was to be as cruel as
possible.
He lowered his voice and shoved in the
last blade.
Don't be a mewling rain wing in front of
our enemies.
Winter stepped back, tense, like a wolf
about to spring.
He stared into hailstorm's eyes for one
long final moment, and then he suddenly
pivoted and leaped into the air.
His pale blue scales glinted orange red
as they caught the sun, and then he
swooped into the wide sky, heading west.
He's safe.
Hillstorm thought with relief.
Even if he hates me now, at least he's
alive.
Winter wasn't useless.
But it was true that his current ranking
wouldn't make him worth rescuing, and it
was also true that Hailstorm didn't want
to see his brother die in Scarlet's
notorious arena.
The Skywing smiled as Hailstorm turned
back to her.
Aren't we civilized?
she said.
Somebody club this ice wing over the head
and let's drag him off to prison.
That's not ness.
Hellstorm started to protest.
But suddenly a sharp bolt of pain cleaved
through his head, and everything went
dark.
He woke up in a bright throne room, so
bright, he instantly got a headache.
Although the brightness of the sun on
eyes had never bothered him.
But here the sun reflected hotly in all
corners of the room, and every surface
seemed to be plastered with gold, loud
and gaudy and yellow, and way, way too
shiny.
Oh, finally. said an impatient voice
nearby.
You've been so horribly boring.
I hope you intend to be exceptionally
thrilling now to make up for it.
Hailstorm gathered his wings and stood up
slowly, rubbing his head.
Chains weighed down his talons, and
strange metal bands prevented his wings
from unfurling all the way, but there
were no guards around him.
Only one other dragon was in the room.
He lifted his eyes to the throne.
Orange scales. glittering rubies, a
circlet of gold and diamonds.
Yellow eyes peered down at him through
veils of smoke.
He'd only seen the sky wing queen from a
distance once, hearing a battle, but
there was no doubt this was her.
Greetings, your majesty, he said.
I'm sorry we have to meet this way.
She studied him for a moment, and then an
unexpected smile quirked the corners of
her mouth.
Instead of in combat.
She guessed.
He gave her a similarly small smile in
return.
Yes.
The battlefield is where I prefer to meet
all my enemies.
Although then the acquaintance doesn't
last very long.
Arrogant.
Queen Scarlet mused.
Like all eyes wings.
Take a note of that, she said over her
shoulder.
Hailstorm saw the shadows move behind the
queen, as if something were pushing
itself slowly out of the wall.
He blinked, feeling a strange shiver of
eerie fear.
But when he looked again, an ordinary sky
wing soldier was standing beside Queen
Scarlet, riding on a small scroll.
He hadn't seen her come in, but maybe all
the gold had dazzled his eyes, so he'd
just missed her before.
She was an orange color, very close to
the golden yellow of the room, with warm
amber eyes.
She looked young, and quiet.
Her voice when she finally spoke, was
soft.
Are you sure you want to do this?
Your majesty?
she asked.
Yes.
Queen Scarlet said with a hiss.
He's dangerous the way he is.
Anyone can see that.
I can't use him in my arena if I want to
trade him later.
And I don't want to deal with any messy
escape or rescue attempts.
You understand, I'm not sure what the
consequences will be, said the soldier.
If we stick to your unusual
specifications, I mean.
I told you I'd only use you for special
cases.
The queen lashed her tail.
This is one.
Very well.
Then he's gone, said the other Sky Wing.
No one will ever be able to find him.
Trust me.
Queen Scarlet snorted.
Not one of my favorite activities
trusting other dragons, she said.
But I'll give it a whirl, just this
once.
He's all yours.
The dragon smiled sideways at Hailstorm
and for the 1st time in his life, he felt
cold all the way through his bones and
claws.
She stepped toward him, reaching for
something around her neck, but he was too
hypnotized by her eyes to run, or fight
or even scream.
Her eyes were not normal sky wing eyes
anymore.
They were dark black.
Black is the darkest abyss in the ocean
and they were coming to swallow him
whole.
Part one.
A cold wind.
Chapter one.
The first time Winter disappointed his
family.
He was 2 years old.
Or at least the 1st time he knew he'd
disappointed them.
Perhaps it had been happening all along
and they'd hidden it behind the stern
demanding faces they showed all the royal
dragonettes.
He could remember the dawn that day.
The morning of his 11th hunt, the subzero
chill in the air, the paling purple of
the sky. 2 moons still high overhead
while the 3rd slid its thin crescent
slivered down below the horizon.
A snowy owl was perched on one of the
palace outcroppings, its talons digging
into the ice, it glowered beatily at
winter, as if it saw his disgrace
coming.
His sister icicle was in the hunting
party.
And his brother, Hailstorm too, along
with 2 of Glaciers' dragonettes, one of
Winter's royal uncles, 3 attendants, and
Winter's parents, Tundra, and Narwhal.
They gathered in the courtyard of the Ice
Palace, stamping their feet and beating
their wings as the glorious freezing air
filled their lungs.
The sharp crunch of snow beneath their
claws broke the stillness of the
morning.
Winter remembered looking up at his
mother as she hissed for attention.
This hunt is for the table of the queen
herself.
Tundra growled.
Whoever brings down the 1st polar bear
will be invited to sit at her side this
evening.
She shot a glittering look at icicle
coiled beside winter.
Icicle was only 2 years old as well, but
she already knew the future her parents
had planned for her.
So did winter.
Although he suspected he wasn't supposed
to.
He couldn't remember how he knew.
Had he overheard his parents whispering
when they thought he was too young to
understand.
Or had he figured it out from their
behavior over the years.
But he did know.
One day.
Icicle would challenge their aunt, Queen
Glacier, for the throne.
That was the reason she was hatched, and
the destiny she was trained for, to kill
Glacier, and become Queen herself.
The only question was when.
Glacier grew older and larger and
stronger each year.
And Icicle had to strike before one of
Glacier's own daughters seized the
queenship.
Daughters, sisters, or nieces could try
for the throne.
Cousins could not, neither could sisters
in law, or tundra surely would have
thrown down the challenge herself.
So Winter's parents couldn't wait
forever.
But they also needed to be sure Icicle
was ready.
She'd have only one chance.
Kill or die?
That was how it worked.
Isaacle lifted her snout and returned her
mother's arch calculating look.
It'll be me, she said, sounding almost
bored.
Signed a polar bear?
Easy.
I have a much better nose than these
two.
She flicked her tail dismissively at
Hellstorm and Winter.
We'll see about that.
Hellstorm said.
He grinned and hopped from foot to foot
full of energy the way he always was.
Winter often wished some of his brother's
confidence would spill over onto him.
The 5 dragonettes set out first, flying
away from the palace in 5 different
directions.
At their age, every hunt was still a test
a chance to prove your worth, and climb
higher in the rankings.
Not that Hailstorm needed to climb any
higher.
He'd been at the very top since he was
not quite 2 years old himself.
He made the top of the list the same day
icicle and winter hatched, in fact.
Winter knew it was risky.
But he decided to try flying out to sea
to hunt.
Sometimes polar bears could be found on
the islands off the coast, or drifting on
the icebergs, or swimming from one to
another.
He had yet to catch a polar bear after 10
hunts, and as a result, his place in the
rankings was lower than anyone in their
family had ever been.
Hailstorm killed a polar bear the 1st
time we took him out hunting.
His mother would observe coldly during
their tense family meals, sliding a bowl
of dripping meat down the table.
Icicle has killed 3 so far.
You obviously need to try harder.
He scanned the waves for a long time
hoping to see a bobbing white head.
Nothing moved, except the sea itself, and
the shifting reflections of the rising
sun.
Finally, he swerved down toward one of
the larger islands, not much bigger than
the ice palace, but studded with caves
where bears might hide.
And suddenly, there.
Standing at the edge of the water, staring
south, she was huge, with a yellowish
tinge to her dingy white fur.
The wind was blowing his scent away from
her, and he was gliding.
She hadn't heard him or smelled him yet.
In a few heartbeats, he could be down
there, sinking his claws into her
shoulders.
She'd put up a fight, but he would win.
He'd bring home a polar bear at last, and
if he hurried, it might even be him
sitting next to the queen at dinner
tonight, while Queen Glacier ate his
polar bear.
He wheeled upward, ready to dive.
And then a movement caught at the corner
of his eye, and he tilted his head toward
the caves.
A pair of tiny cubs was wobbling out onto
the snow.
One of them tripped and sprawled out, paws
flopping every which way, and the other
growled with delight and tackled him.
They rolled, wrestling playfully, and
their mother swung her head around to
grunt at them.
Winter hesitated.
Don't be a fool, he told himself.
Just kill them too.
That's the way to impress mother and
father.
But there was something else watching the
bears.
It was well hidden, higher up among the
rocks above the cave, but Winter's sharp
ice wing eyes spotted it when it moved.
A scavenger.
A scavenger here?
This far north?
The creature was wrapped in so many
furs.
At 1st winter almost thought it was
another polar bear cub.
But there was no mistaking those clever
thin brown paws for the great clumsy paws
of bears.
The scavenger was carrying a kind of
rough spear, and its eyes were fixed on
the polar bears, so it hadn't noticed the
dragon overhead yet either.
Winter scanned the island and spotted a
wooden canoe that had been hauled onto
the pebbly beach.
How far had this scavenger traveled
through the rough Arctic water?
Was it hunting the bears for prey, just
like winter was?
If so, why wasn't it moving?
Why had it lowered its spear as if it was
already giving up?
Winter stared intently, tracking the
scavengers gaze.
The way it was watching the cubs.
Was it hesitating the way he had?
Did it feel sorry for them too?
Surely that was ridiculous.
Scavengers couldn't feel pity.
A hungry scavenger wouldn't spare the
life of a bear just to protect her cubs.
Would it?
He wished he could scoop up the scavenger
and study it more closely.
What is wrong with you?
Tundra's voice suddenly shrieked across
the sky.
Winter nearly leaped out of his scales.
Are you hunting or sightseeing?
Are you an ice wing or a rain wing?
Kill that bear?
Winter twisted around and saw, to his
horror, that his mother, father, and
uncle, were all winging toward him with
disgusted expressions.
Right behind them was icicle, with a
polar bear carcass dangling from her
claws.
He dove frantically toward the bear, but
the noise had alerted her to the danger
and she was already charging up the slope
and bundling her cubs back into the
cave.
Winter beat his wings and lunged with his
talons outstretched, but they closed on
empty air.
As the 3 polar bears vanished into a
narrow, stony passageway where dragons
would never be able to follow.
Winter scrabbled at the cave entrance for
a moment, but there was nothing he could
do.
The bears were gone.
He carefully forced himself not to look
up at the scavenger.
If his parents knew it was there, they'd
make him kill it for the dinner feast, and
for some reason he didn't want to.
He couldn't imagine anyone eating those
little paws, or the scavenger's head with
its wide dark eyes.
A shiver went through his wings.
How could you let it get away?
Narwhal roared, landing beside him.
Winter's father slammed one talon into
the side of the cliff, and a small
avalanche of snow crashed over Winter's
head.
It was right there.
No kill could be easier.
Maybe he was worried about the little
baby bears.
Icicle offered, coming down with a thump
and a splattering of bare blood.
Maybe he didn't want to leave them all
alone with no mummy to take care of
them.
Poor wittle 4 balls.
Her voice was sneering and triumphant.
No, winter cried.
That wasn't it.
I was, I was just watching for a minute.
I would have gotten it if.
If you hadn't been wasting time mooning
around, narwhal hissed.
We have to report this, you know.
Your uncle saw the whole thing.
Winter stared miserably at his talents.
He knew his parents would have reported
it anyway, even with no other witnesses.
They believed in the strict ice wing
codes of behavior.
They agreed that the only way to make him
strong was to expose all his weaknesses.
Shame and fear were powerful weapons for
teaching young dragonettes.
If everyone was disappointed in him
surely he would fight harder to prove
himself.
I will, he thought fiercely.
I will be better.
I will claw my way up the rankings.
I won't make a mistake like this again.
But he still did not tell his parents
about the scavenger hiding nearby.
He glanced back only once, as they were
all swooping away, to make sure it was
all right.
That incident sent him down into the 5th
circle, above only one year old
dragonettes, in families that barely
counted as aristocrats.
For months, his mother had made him
memorize long sagas about dragons who'd
attempted the diamond trial to get back
into the 1st circle, including about 100
verses, speculating how gruesomely they
might have died.
The trial was a last resort, rarely used
but she made it clear that no dragnet of
hers would reach his 7th hatching day any
lower than 2nd circle, even if it meant
turning to an ancient mysterious, most
likely deadly ritual.
With that thread hanging over him, he had
struggled to claw his way back up to the
rankings, bit by bit, and he had tried as
hard as he could for so long.
And then, losing hailstorm, actually
weaving hailstorm, abandoning him to his
fate without a fight, had wiped out all
that work, and he'd had to start all over
from the 6th circle.
Which I deserved, he thought.
It was my fault we were on that
mountain.
My fault he got caught.
My stupid, cowardly decision to leave him
there.
But everything was different now.
Now he knew Hellstorm was alive, not dead
as they'd all thought.
Queen Scarlet still held him prisoner
hidden somewhere secret.
And Icicle had been bargaining for
hailstorm's life before winter had ruined
her plan.
She'd agreed to kill the dragonettes of
destiny in exchange for Hellstorm.
But winter had stopped her.
Which meant, if Scarlet killed Hailstorm
now, it would be even more winter's
fault.
He clenched his talons.
But maybe he could get to her before that
happened.
If he could find Scarlet, maybe there was
still a chance to save his brother.
He swiped raindrops off his face
inhaling.
The downpour was incessant and
repulsive.
He'd take a howling snowstorm over this
dripping, soggy horribleness any day.
The forest floor squashed between his
claws, and the wet tree branches lashed
his wings as they swayed in the storm.
Below him, his pet scavenger stood in the
open doorway of the cage winter had
built.
Bandit squinted up at the dragon, and the
thunderstorm.
I'm letting you go, Winter said
impatiently.
Don't just stand there.
I can't carry a pet with me while I'm
searching for hailstorm, especially not
one that flops around moping all the
time.
He rattled the cage, and the scavenger
flinched.
Winter had spent days and days on
planning and constructing this cage
making it beautiful for his very 1st pet
scavenger.
And then, Bandit hadn't appreciated it at
all.
He'd never used the swing or the running
wheel.
Mostly he'd cowered under the furs and
squeaked, or he tried to run away.
Isn't this what you wanted?
Winter demanded.
Bandit was the most disappointing pet of
all time.
But winter couldn't help it.
He still cared about him.
Otherwise, he could have abandoned Bandit
to be someone's dinner back at Jade
Mountain.
Winter still remembered the expression on
that 1st hunter scavenger's face all
these years later, the curiosity, and the
dragon like sympathy in its eyes.
He'd hoped to see something like that in
bandit one day.
But it didn't matter now.
Nothing mattered, except finding
Hillstorm.
Go on, get out of here, Winter grumbled.
He poked a bandit with one claw, but the
scavenger dodged, and retreated farther
into the cage, covering his head.
Winter felt a flash of pity for the
creature, and then felt furious with
himself for caring, when there were more
important things to worry about.
I know it's raining, but it's better than
the Ice Kingdom, trust me.
If I take him with me to the ice
kingdom.
He'll either freeze to death or be eaten
within the 1st day.
Queen Glacier had granted him permission
to have an exotic pet while at the
academy, but where he saw an exotic pet
his parents were likely to see a
delicious snack.
Winter, he heard a voice yell, somewhere
off in the trees.
A plume of fire lit up the faces of 4
dragons, hurrying toward him through the
forest.
To his astonishment, it was the rest of
his winglet from the Jade Mountain
Academy.
Kibley, Turtle, Kinkajoo, and Moon.
He pushed back against the little jump
that his heart made when he saw her.
Just what I need right now.
A bunch of glaciers slowing me down.
By all the snow monsters.
What are you doing here?
Winter demanded.
How had they even found him?
And why?
Looking for you?
Moon said simply.
Her eyes caught on his, shining in the
bits of moonlight that fought through the
storm clouds.
She always looked at him as if she could
see more of him than anyone else.
As if she saw dazzling mountain peaks
whereas parents saw nothing but a lump of
gray ice.
And we found you, Kinkachu added.
We're amazing.
She flapped her wings as Kibley sent out
another burst of flame, and Winter could
see that she had turned bright yellow
with purple spots.
Ridiculous.
That's what rain wings were, all of them
flamboyant and ridiculous, with their
feelings splattered all over their scales
like that.
It was embarrassing to be around.
Winter glanced down at Bandit.
He couldn't let these dragons distract
him.
I'm not going back to Jade Mountain, he
said firmly, no matter what they said
they wouldn't change his mind.
I'm going to look for my brother.
I thought so, Moon said.
Her voice quiet, but as determined as
his.
We want to help you.
We do?
Turtle said, stamping his feet.
Yes, Kinkachu said.
I didn't know we did, but now I totally
do.
No way.
Absolutely not.
I can't be around them.
Not even moon.
I mean, especially Moon.
He saw Kibley staring intently at him, as
though the sand wing was figuring out his
next move.
Ghibli had done that all the time in a
cave they shared on Jade Mountain, and it
had been very unsettling to live with.
Winter could just imagine what it would
be like to have the sand wings black eyes
inspecting everything he did on the path
to finding hailstorm.
You can't come with me, he said.
I'm going to Queen Glacier.
I need to explain it all to her and get
her to help me find Hellstorm.
Perhaps you would give him a wing of
soldiers of his own to command.
Or perhaps she would send out all her
warrior dragons to search for Hailstorm.
Regardless, he knew he needed the power
of the ice wing queen to save his
brother.
That was the smart thing to do, wasn't
it?
Wouldn't it make more sense to go to the
Sky Kingdom?
Kinkachu asked.
Your brother must be imprisoned there
somewhere, right?
We can all look for him in like all the
mountain caves or something.
Or you could go after icicle, Kibley
said.
Try to find out more about what Scarlett
told her.
This was exactly what he didn't want, more
options, more doubt.
Kibley was right.
Icicle was the only one who knew anything
about Hellstorm and Scarlet.
Following Icicle would make sense, except
I don't know where she's gone.
Winter said bitterly.
Back to the Ice Kingdom, he hoped.
Although she had to know Queen Glacier
would be furious about her breaking the
Jade Mountain truce.
I have a guess, Kibley said.
Of course he did.
You won't like it, though, he added
nodding at Kinkachoo.
I think she's gone to the rainforest.
She knows the one Scarlet hates the most
is glory.
Everyone knows that.
If they know the story of what glory did
to her face.
So I think Isaacle might think that if
she kills glory, Scarlet will forgive her
for failing to kill the others.
Nobody spoke for a long moment.
Thrice cursed moons, Winter thought.
He's right.
That's exactly what she would think.
Icicle is brilliant, dangerous, and
prefers to hunt alone.
She would find a way to solve this
problem instead of running for help.
Thunder rumbled overhead.
Then I'm going to the rainforest, Kinkachu
said fiercely.
I'm not letting her kill my awesome
queen.
Suddenly moon let out a yell of pain. and
crumpled forward, her wings collapsing
around her.
Winter stepped toward her, but Kinkachu
was faster, catching the night wing in
her wings.
Moon?
She cried, staggering sideways.
A flash of lightning lit up Moon's face
as the black dragon lifted her snout to
the sky.
Something blank and weird had taken over
her eyes, like frost on a lake.
And then she began to speak, in a voice
nothing like her own.
Beware the darkness of dragons.
Beware the stalker of dreams.
Beware the talons of power and fire.
Beware one who is not what she seems.
Something is coming to shake the earth.
Something is coming to scorch the
ground.
Jade Mountain will fall beneath thunder
and ice, unless, unless the lost city of
night can be found.
The voice lurched to a stop, and Moon
closed her eyes, releasing all the
tension out of her wings.
Everyone stared at her, Winter's heart
was hammering, like the pelting
raindrops.
Those words.
That couldn't be what it sounded like
could it?
By all the snakes.
Kibley said at last.
Winter met his eyes in the next flash of
lightning.
Kibley looked as terrified as he felt, as
shaken as he'd been the day of the
explosion in their history class.
What was that?
That's what you've been muttering in your
sleep, Kinkachu said to Moon.
It sounded like a prophecy.
Winter said slowly, but it couldn't be.
The Night Wings had sworn to everyone
that their powers were gone.
Tsunami, sunny, Starflight, clay, and
glory had confirmed it.
No more mind reading.
No more prophecies.
Ever again.
That was what they'd said.
Exactly.
So someone was lying.
But who?
Moon shook her head and pressed herself
upright, her wings unsteady.
Turtle, she said.
Please give him one of the rocks.
The sea wing fumbled with the arm band he
always wore.
Winter could see that a couple of the
black stones were missing from it, and as
he watched, Turtle pried out another one
and passed it to Winter.
The stone was small, about the size of a
dragon's tooth, and had a strange sheen
to it, although that might have been the
effect of the rain and the lightning, it
was jagged around the edges, but not
sharp.
It looked fairly ordinary.
What's this?
he asked.
What does this have to do with
prophecies?
I have a lot to explain, Moon said.
She sounded nervous, as though he might
stab her with his tail spikes any moment
which he'd refrained from doing to anyone
so far, so he thought that was rather
unfair.
Everything.
The whole truth.
I'm going to tell you everything.
That sounds ominous, Winter said.
No more ominous then, Jade Mountain will
fall beneath thunder and ice, Kibley
said.
I hope we're all planning to talk about
that, because I'm extremely unsettled
right now.
She said we have to find the lost city of
night, Kinkachu said.
That's all, and then everything will be
fine, right?
Isn't that what everyone else heard?
I'm pretty sure.
I heard that we're all going to die
Turtles said.
Death, death, monsters everywhere, death.
Is that it?
Kibli Ass Moon.
Is that what you saw?
Jade Mountain is going to fall on us
all?
I don't know, Moon said.
I've had visions, but none of them ever
came out in words like that before.
I don't know what it means.
Visions.
Winter didn't like the sound of that.
He closed his claws around the rock
frowning at her, but Moon had gone quiet
staring into the dark as though she were
hearing something else.
A few moments passed, and then she seemed
to snap back into herself.
Winter, she said.
There are a few things you need to know
about me.
I'm listening, he said.
Not that I have a choice, apparently.
It's true what you've heard about the
Night Wings, she said.
They really have lost their powers.
There hasn't been a night wing who could
read minds or see the future in, well, a
very long time.
She took a deep breath.
Until me.
Winter's tail twitched.
His heart felt like the rock in his
talons, small and hard.
Because I hatched in the rainforest, she
went on.
Under 2 full moons, I can do both.
Both what?
He forced out past the claws that seemed
to be closing around his throat.
See visions of the future.
She said, then hesitated.
And read minds.
Chapter 2.
No.
Thunder rumbled through the dark clouds
like boulders sliding down a mountain.
What had Moon seen in his mind?
What did she know?
Did she know that he felt?
That he'd been thinking about her?
Her eyes and the way she tilted her
head?
Her claws that could gently shield his
scavenger one moment, and rip apart a
goat the next?
The way she stood up to him the 1st time
they met?
But looked at him as though he was worth
listening to.
She must know that he thought about her
all the time.
Stop thinking about it.
Don't think it.
Don't let her see anymore.
But you're safe now, I promise, she said
quickly.
Reaching toward him as he leaped back.
The rock you're holding?
It's Skyfire.
It can shield your thoughts for me.
As long as you're holding it or wearing
it close to your scales, I can't hear
anything you're thinking.
Sounds like another nightwing lie, Winter
snarled.
What have you seen in my head?
He thought fiercely.
Moon wiped raindrops from her eyes and
took a deep breath.
I promise you, Winter.
I can't hear anything in your mind right
now.
And even before, it was very... confusing.
Behind her.
Kibli let out a snort that sounded a bit
too amused.
That's how I knew about Icicle and
Scarlet, Moon said.
I heard them talking in icicle's dream.
And I heard Icicle planning to kill
Starflight on her way to the library.
But I can only hear what dragons are
thinking right at that moment.
I can't reach in and rummage around in
anyone's brain or anything like that.
Winter found this image not very
reassuring at all.
You've been listening to us from the
moment you met us, he said. deceiving us
spying on us.
He hissed out a wisp of frost breath
turning the raindrops around him into
tiny chunks of ice that clattered to the
ground.
I should have expected as much from a
night wing.
But not from this night wing.
He thought moon was different.
He'd begun to think she might be the only
night wing in the world he could trust.
And the whole time, she'd been lying, and
snooping around in his thoughts, he must
be the most dim witted dragon who'd ever
lived.
I shouldn't have let my guard down.
I've always been taught that nightwings
are conniving underhanded backstabbers.
I know the history of what they did to
us.
This is just more proof of that.
Go back to Jade Mountain, all of you
Winter said.
Leave me alone.
He turned to the cage where his scavenger
was still standing, staring mournfully
out of the rain.
And you, get out of here.
He roared as loud as he could.
Bandit stumbled back with a cry of terror
then bolted out of the cage.
The little creature tripped and sprawled
on the wet leaves, scrambled upright
again, and went galloping off into the
dark forest.
Winter saw the look on Moon's face as she
watched Bandit go.
Sympathetic, pitying, curious.
No one else had ever been as interested
in scavengers as he was.
He curled his talons around the Skyfire
Rock.
I mean it, go away.
I'm going to the Ice Kingdom, and if you
follow me, you'll die.
He paused for a moment.
Not that I have any objection to your
debts just to be clear.
I just don't want to listen to you all
breathing and flapping and saying stupid
things all the way there.
That can't be your plan, Kibley said.
The sandwing was using his annoying, let's
be sensible about this voice.
Go home and beg for help.
By the time you get there.
Your brother might be dead.
Your best chance is to catch icicle.
Before she kills Queen Glory, Kinkachu
said fiercely.
The little rain wing was now a mango
orange color, with streaks of black along
her wings.
She looked ready to fly into battle.
But Icicle was a deadly warrior who could
kill a vegetarian rainforest dragon with
a snap of her tail.
I don't need help from any of you.
He growled, especially you.
He threw a glare at Moon, who folded her
wings closer around herself, but didn't
look away.
You do, actually. said Kibley.
You won't get 2 steps into the rainforest
without our help.
It's full of night wings now, and
everyone knows they don't like ice
wings.
And if you find Scarlet, Do you think
she'll just tell you where your brother
is?
Wouldn't it be useful and much more
efficient to have a mind reader with
you?
Oh, is that what you are now?
Winter asked Moon.
A clever tool that can be used by whoever
needs some quick answers.
I won't let anyone use me, she said with
a flash of anger.
But if I can do something good with this
this gift I didn't ask for.
Then yes, I'll do it.
Um, turtle interjected.
Winter shifted his glare to the sea wing
who had been quietly pacing in circles
splashing through the puddles with his
huge talons.
Excuse me, what about the creepy
prophecy?
Is Jade Mountain in danger?
Shouldn't we, you know, warn someone?
I'm not worried, Kinkachu said.
We know where the lost city of night is.
The Night Wings abandoned it when the
volcano erupted, but we can still get to
the island from the rainforest.
That's easy.
So we go to the Lost City, and then all
those awful things won't happen, and Jade
Mountain will be fine, right?
Nothing to panic about.
Kimley let out a plume of fire
illuminating Moon's doubtful expression.
I don't think it's that simple, she
said.
The things I saw when the words came.
The things I see in my nightmares.
I can't imagine that just visiting the
volcanic island could stop any of that
from happening.
Well, let's try it and see.
Kingaju said enthusiastically.
But if it doesn't work, Turtles said
fidgeting nervously with his claws, all
those dragons at Jade Mountain, my
sisters, Hey, I agree with you, Kibley
said.
I'm completely feeling the doom right
now.
But do you think anyone will believe
her?
He nodded at Moon.
When they've been told the Nightwings
have no powers now?
Sonny will, Kinkachu said.
Tsunami might not.
She doesn't like prophecies much.
And then what?
Shut down the whole school based on a
maybe prophecy?
Kibley went on.
I don't think they'll do that.
Besides, winter's problem is urgent.
We have to find his brother before
Scarlet kills him.
So I vote.
We do that now, and deal with the
impending apocalypse afterward.
Me too, Moon said.
What in the world made these dragons
think his problem was their problem?
Finding Hailstorm was urgent to winter
but it made no sense for any not ice
wings to get involved at all.
Winter narrowed his eyes at Turtle
dripping forlornly into the puddles
around his claws.
It was easy to forget that the sea wing
was a royal prince as well, the son of
Queen Coral.
He never acted like royalty.
Instead, Turtle behaved as though he
didn't want to be noticed at all, mumbly
sticking to the background, agreeing to
anything.
Was he afraid of something?
Or just boring.
If an ice wing acted the way turtle does
he'd be stuck in the 7th circle forever.
Which meant winter could get rid of him
by applying the right pressure.
You should go back, he said, making
turtle jump.
You don't want to tramp around Pyria
looking for my deadly sister.
Who will kill you on site?
Or my brother, who might do the same
because, by the way, killing Sea Wings
was a specialty of his?
Go keep an eye on Jade Mountain instead.
Turtles glow in the dark scales flickered
illuminating his anxious face with pale
greenish light.
But what if the mountain falls on me?
Is it dangerous?
Not as dangerous as following me, Winter
hissed.
It's not going to fall on you because
we're going to stop it.
Kinkachu said, but don't you want to stay
with us?
I can't decide what sounds worse, Turtle
admitted.
Chasing killer dragons across Pyria, or
sitting at school, waiting for some kind
of thunder and ice catastrophe to drop on
my head.
It's all right, Moon said.
Turtle, you can go back to Jade
Mountain.
You can tell them that we're safe and
where we've gone.
That's true he said, perking up.
That would be useful of me, wouldn't it?
Probably, Kibley agreed.
Although, you could be useful with us too
but it's your choice.
Turtles shuffled backward.
I'll tell tsunami and the others not to
worry about you.
And I did promise mother to watch out for
anemone, so I should, uh, I should really
do that, you know?
But you go catch the bad guys and stop
the prophecy.
And then I'll see you all when you get
back to school.
Okay?
A moment later, the sea wing had slipped
away into the trees, and soon they heard
muffled, wet wing beats as he flew away.
Hmm.
Kinkachu said with a frown.
That was disappointing.
How can we be the 2nd coming of the 5
dragonettes of destiny, if there's only 4
of us?
I highly doubt we're destined for
anything special, Winter said.
You're not getting rid of the rest of us
that easily.
Kibley said sharply to Winter as though
he knew exactly what Winter was trying to
do.
All right, Winter growled.
Fine.
Let's all go to the rainforest together
like a sloppy pile of mudwing siblings.
I can look for icicle, and you can go dig
around in the ashes of the night
kingdom.
And I can save Queen Glory, Kinkaju said
weeping into the air.
Besides, Kibley pointed out, flicking his
tail at winter.
That'll actually bring you closer to the
Ice Kingdom.
Since then, you can use the tunnel that
comes out north of Queen Thorn's
stronghold.
That was true.
Winter disliked it intensely when Kibley
made clever observations like that, and
it happened about 40 times a day.
I know, he said, looking down his nose at
the sand wing.
Obviously, I figured that out.
That's the only reason I'm agreeing to
this.
Oh, Kibley said, with a rakish grin.
I thought perhaps it was because I'm so
charming and convincing.
You are neither.
Winter said.
In fact, if you don't shut up at once, I
will change my mind.
Kibli pretended to wrap invisible chains
around his snout, and lifted his front
talons innocently.
Let's go, Moon said, spreading her wings
and lifting off, Kibli and Kinkajoo
leaped after her.
Winter hesitated for a moment, watching
the lightning flash in the sky beyond the
flying dragons.
Why was he agreeing to this?
An ice wing warrior didn't need help from
anyone else?
Least of all, a pack of misguided dragons
from other tribes.
Take it, Kibli.
Everyone knew Sandwings were nearly as
untrustworthy as Nightwings, except half
as smart, and twice as likely to betray
you for golden treasure.
And a rain wing?
They weren't even worth mentioning in the
great ice wing sagas that told the
history of this world.
Lazy, and insignificant, and weak.
There was no benefit to be gained from
knowing them or befriending them.
Worst of all, how could he ally himself
with a night wing, even temporarily, even
if he went into it knowing not to trust
her.
To travel with Moon, to spend a single
moment longer with her, knowing what he
knew now.
And yet, still feeling something that he
should not be feeling, I should stay as
far away from her as I can.
Mother and father would be more than
disappointed in me.
If they heard of this, any potential
position in the palace would be gone
forever.
I'd land at the bottom of the 7th circle
and have to choose between a diamond
trial, or being stationed on an Arctic
island outpost for the rest of my life.
He could see their faces so clearly.
That look they got whenever he did
something wrong, the look that said, if
only we'd lost you instead of hailstorm
if only you met any of our expectations
if only you were everything an ice wing
should be.
Winter.
Kibley called from above.
The others were hovering up there, waiting
for him.
Come on.
This was only temporary, he reminded
himself.
Get to the rainforest.
Look for icicle.
Then he could rescue Hailstorm by
himself.
That's what a true ice wing prince would
do.
He wasn't really working with Moon and
the others.
He didn't have to listen to them, and he
certainly wouldn't ask them for help.
Most of all, he would never, never trust
them. especially that lying night wing.
Shaking rain off his tail with a clatter
of spikes, he ascended into the storm
wheeled around in a circle, and took off
toward the rainforest without a glance at
the other dragons.
Chapter 3.
Winter was not surprised to discover that
the rainforest was horrifying and awful.
For starters, there was something
blocking Winter's view in every
direction.
Giant trees to the left, tangles of vines
to the right, a thick canopy of leaves
overhead.
He could barely see 5 feet in front of
him.
Never mind the horizon.
How could any dragon keep watch in a
place like this?
How could you ever know if you were being
attacked or buy how many dragons?
It was an indefensible quagmire.
Also, a literal quagmire.
Every time they landed, the mud was
nearly enough to make him want to claw
off his own scales.
Moreover, the whole place was
overwhelming.
Too many bright colors.
What self respecting bird would ever need
to have red, yellow, blue, and green
feathers?
Black and white.
Those were the only feather colors for a
dignified bird.
Too many strange noises.
What kind of animal howled like that?
Why could he hear a waterfall for what
seemed like hours, and yet never see it?
And what was that infernal nonstop
buzzing?
Also, far, far, far too many weird
smells.
Winter couldn't decide which was the
worst part.
The bugs or the heat.
It was painfully, oppressively hot, in a
sweltering.
We are being boiled alive in our scales
kind of way.
He thought he'd experienced heat
traveling through the kingdom of sand, but
this was also damp and sticky, and more
miserable than anything he'd ever felt
before.
Then, there were the insects, swarming
around them, finding every spot between
the dragons' scales to wriggle in and
suck their blood.
He'd already shaken 2 green striped
caterpillars, a walking twig thing, and
an alarmingly furry spider out of his
ears.
His wings kept catching on enormous
spider webs, and creatures with 1000000s
of legs had scurried over his talons at
least a dozen times.
He itched unbearably from his horns to
his forlornly muddy tail.
Was Icicle really here?
He couldn't imagine her putting up with
any of this.
He couldn't imagine her with even a speck
of mud on her.
She had always returned from battle as
pristine as when she'd left, apart from a
few bleeding blue scratches here and
there.
Perhaps she'd taken 2 steps into this
rainforest, and decided that murdering
the rain wing queen wasn't worth it.
You must hate this place.
Moon said, appearing beside him.
They'd stopped to rest near a river, and
winter was crouched on a large boulder
trying to dip his talons in the water
without stepping in the oozing black mud
that lined the banks.
He narrowed his eyes at her, reaching
unconsciously over the small wolfskin
pouch, he kept tied to one of his ankles
where he'd hidden the skyfire.
She sighed.
No, I didn't get that from your head.
I just figured an ice wing would probably
hate it here.
It must be the polar opposite of the ice
kingdom, the anti-polar opposite, she
added, then scrunched her snout, trying
not to laugh at her own joke.
Is this merely idle conversation?
What would be the point of that?
Or is she trying to trick some
information out of me?
It is, he said finally.
And I do.
This is where I grew up, she said, waiting
a few steps into the river.
The water eddied around her legs with
glints of reflected sunlight.
It's not so bad, actually.
Humph.
Winter snorted.
Not so bad?
Kinkachu said indignantly from the other
bank.
This is the most beautiful part of
Pyria.
Other dragons would be lucky to live
here.
The rain wing bounded into the water with
a splash, the drenched winter's nose and
tail.
A fat orange toad burst out of the river
and made a clumsy dash for the reeds
trying to get away from the dragons.
Moon tilted her head at it, then flared
her wings at Kibley as he sat up from the
middle of the river.
Don't eat it, she warned him.
Seriously, one of those gave me hiccups
for days.
Also, some really weird dreams.
I thought for a while I was having
visions of a possible future where newts
and ant eaters took over the world.
Kinkichu giggled.
Here, try these instead.
Moon offered.
She reached into one of the overhanging
trees and pulled a few strange fruits
from the branches.
They were a curious reddish pink on the
outside, with flaps like folded up flower
petals, but as she sliced them open with
her claws, winter saw that on the inside
they were white, with small black flex.
She handed one to Kibley, then glanced
sideways at winter.
Absolutely not.
He said, do not get that vile stickiness
anywhere near me.
Fruit.
Yuck.
His stomach growled, and he tried to hide
it by scraping his claws along the rock.
You are so, so weird.
Kinkaju said to him, how can you not love
it here?
Don't you come from a place with no
colors and no life?
He thought of the 1000 different
shimmering shades of blue in the ice
palace.
He remembered the distant splashes of
whales and seals, the way sound carried
across the cool, quiet ice.
He thought of how he could smell polar
bears or arctic foxes from miles away, and
how all of his senses could detect the
smallest changes in the frozen world.
Here, it was just too much.
White is a color.
He snapped at the rain wing.
Blue is a color.
That is an eyesore.
He pointed to a violently red flower as
big as one of his talons.
We also have these, Moon said.
She lifted a dark green leaf on one of
the trees and revealed a spiraling
tendril of delicate white blue flowers
glowing like snowflakes against the brown
trunk.
Oh, and look, there's a sloth.
She pointed to a furry gray shape that
was clambering slowly along a branch far
overhead.
Thank the moons, Winter said, leaping to
his feet.
I knew there had to be something worth
eating around here.
He shot into the air, his claws reaching
for the sloths exposed wide underbelly.
Wait, Moon cried.
There was a twin shriek of dismay from
Kinkaju.
The sloth peered over its shoulder, and
blinked enormous, confused eyes at him
and then, wham!
Something slammed into Winter's side and
smashed him against a tree.
He saw a flash of red scales and sharp
teeth and thought, Skywing.
Could it be Queen Scarlet, here, attacking
him?
He whirled and lashed out with his tail
but just missed the enemy dragon as a
dove under him.
Winter spun again and clawed at the air
where the dragon should have been, but
once again, it whisked out of his reach.
The red dragon swooped up to the branch
snatched the sloth in its talons, paused
to glare at winter, and then vanished.
Winter warred with surprise and fury.
Calm down!
Kibley shouted in his ear.
The sand wing ducked as winter swiped at
him.
Winter stop.
There was a sky wing.
Winter snarled.
It attacked me and stole my prey and then
disapp...
Oh, seal guts.
Not a sky wing.
Kibley pointed out, although Winter had
obviously figured that out already.
I know!
Winter warred, beating the air with his
wings.
Come out and face me, you cowardly lunch
stealing rain wing.
The dragon suddenly materialized on the
branch again, her scales shifting to a
furious red, with splatters of black and
orange.
Topher is nobody's lunch, she shouted.
Those nasty black dragons have already
eaten one of my sloths.
I'm not letting it happen again.
She flexed her claws and bared her fangs
at him.
Don't make her mad, Kibley said quickly
grabbing Winter's shoulder.
I mean, don't make her more mad.
The heat emanating from the sand wings
yellow scales was uncomfortable, and
winter shook him off.
As if a rain wing would ever dare fight
me.
Winter scoffed, as if I couldn't claw off
her face as easily as breathing.
What is with you and faces?
Kibley said.
You should try threatening someone's
elbows or ankles once in a while. just
for change of pace.
Kinkachu landed on the branch beside the
angry rain wing, angling herself between
the furious dragon in winter.
Exquisite.
It's me. she said.
I'm sorry about this.
I promise we were about to stop him.
Ha!
Winter barked.
Winter, do you have a part of your brain
that can handle empathy?
Kibley asked.
That sloth is her pet.
Just like bandit was your pet.
Can you by any chance remember about a
week ago when someone tried to eat your
pet?
Winter hesitated.
Of course he remembered that.
And he remembered how Moon had saved his
scavenger in her quiet, but resolute
way.
Kibley was right.
Again.
There was nothing more infuriating in the
entire world.
Bandit is much smarter than a flea ridden
sloth.
Winter snapped.
Landing on one of the fat branches of a
nearby tree.
He flinched as a centipede as long as his
foot, immediately scuttled over his
claws.
But fine.
I won't eat any stupid slaws.
Is there anything else that's off limits
that I should know about?
beloved armadillos, hairy giant spiders
that someone is terribly attached to.
I think the tamarind monkeys are really
cute.
Moon offered, swooping up beside them.
It'd be great if you could not eat
those.
Winter scowled at her.
As often happened with Moon, he couldn't
tell if she was joking.
Would you really eat a hairy spider
anyway?
Kibley asked, with genuine curiosity.
Exquisite clutched her sloth closer
hissed at Kinkajoo and Winter, and
vanished again.
This time Winter could see the ripple of
her scales changing, and the slight
weirdness of the air when she moved.
A moment later, the branch shook as she
took off, and he saw leaves thrashing
about as the camouflaged dragon flapped
away.
Moon landed next to winter. and suddenly
reached out to brush his wing with hers.
Unlike Kibley's, Moon's scales were cool
and smooth, like the icy walls of his
room back in the palace.
How dare she touch me?
Winter thought.
But then, he found himself keeping as
still as he could, so their wings would
stay connected.
What is wrong with me?
Moon's eyes were far away.
And he wondered if she even knew she was
touching him.
Someone's coming, she whispered.
Someone with dark thoughts.
Did she see darkness in my mind?
Winter wondered.
How did she feel about the way I hate
other dragons?
What's a dark thought?
Kibley asked, with something odd in his
voice, nervousness?
Was he also worried about what Moon had
found inside him?
What had she seen in his head?
It's obsidian.
He's thinking he hates being on guard
duty, Moon said thoughtfully, especially
with the rain wing he's been assigned as
a partner.
He hates being told what to do by rain
wings.
He wishes the night wings could overthrow
Queen Glory and rule the rainforest
themselves.
She paused.
All right, we're safe.
They've gone by.
She realized her wing was still touching
Winters, and pulled away with an
apologetic expression.
He tried to pretend he hadn't even
noticed.
So, we're all on board with avoiding
night wings, then?
Kibley said.
Excellent.
Present company accepted, of course.
Maybe not all night wings, but definitely
him, Moon said.
She sighed.
I should probably tell the queen what I
can do, so I can warn her about dragons
like this.
Her tail flicked the leaves below them.
But I worry.
I mean, should dragons be punished for
their thoughts?
Even if they never act on them?
But what if warning her means they'll
never do whatever terrible thing they're
thinking of?
I don't know.
I don't want anyone to use me as a way to
spy on the private thoughts of her
subjects.
Really?
Kibley said.
But it would be useful to know if a coup
or an assassination is coming.
If you could prevent that, wouldn't it be
worth spying on a few dragons?
No, Winter snapped.
Nothing justifies invading another
dragon's mind.
But that's how she stopped icicle from
killing Starflight.
Kibley pointed out.
Aren't you grateful she did that?
Winter glared down at Kingaju, who had
gone back to splashing in the river
below.
I still don't like it, he said.
In the wrong talons.
I mean, Moon could tell Queen Glory, she
heard someone planning a murder, and that
dragon could be punished, and who could
prove her wrong?
I wouldn't lie.
Moon said, looking outraged.
How do we know that?
Winter asked.
You hid your powers from us?
Why should we trust you?
And even if you wouldn't lie?
What about other night wings?
They've lied before, haven't they?
They lied about having powers for years
apparently.
The entire tribes full of liars, going
back 1000s of years, to the dark stalker
and his cursed mother, Beauslayer.
Moon jumped, overbalanced, and fell off
the branch with a lot of wild thrashing.
Startled, winter peered down at her as
she climbed back up.
Three moons.
What was that about?
Kibley asked when she was settled again.
Are you all right?
Moon was breathing in a funny, almost
panicked way.
Dark stalker?
she said to Winter.
How do you know about him?
Everyone knows about him, Winter said.
I don't.
Kibley offered.
Everyone, Winter said pointedly.
Who's anyone?
Ah, I see.
Kibley said.
You mean ice wings.
And Night Wings, Moon said, he's our
legend, Nightmare, Ghost Monster from the
Beyond, whatever.
Ours too.
Winter said grimly.
Trust me.
Why?
What did he ever do to the ice wings?
Moon asked.
Killed one of our princes, Winter said
stole our royal heritage, ruined
everything forever.
Oh my, forever?
Kidley asked.
He gave the sunlit rainforest a mock
serious, nodding inspection.
Well, that explains it.
I was wondering why everything was so
very ruined all the time.
Thank goodness there's one ancient dead
dragon we can blame for it all.
You wouldn't joke if you knew the whole
story.
Winter snapped.
Moon closed her eyes, then shook her head
with an expression that looked like
frustration.
I want to know the whole, she began, and
then her eyes popped open in alarm.
They're coming back.
Obsidian and the rain wing guard, we
should, hello?
Kankaju called, waving her wings.
Hi, over here.
Not do that.
Kibley finished for moon as she winced.
It was too late.
Winter hissed softly.
There was no chance of sneaking through
the rainforest now.
The guards were heading straight for
them.
Chapter 4.
A black dragon, the one with ugly
thoughts, slowly stalked along the banks
of the river, staring at Kingajou, his
forked black tongue flicked in and out
and his expression was calculating.
A few steps ahead of him was a rain
wing.
Dappled green like the forest, but not
completely camouflaged.
She splashed into the river and over to
Kinkaju, frowning.
Oh, it's you.
Kinkachu said.
Winter had never heard that tone of gloom
from the little rain wing before.
Hi, Bromeliad.
I thought you were orchid.
What are you doing back here?
Brumiliad demanded.
You were supposed to stay at that school
the queen sent you to.
I told her you were a terrible student
and would definitely fail or run off, but
would she listen?
Mysteriously not.
And now here you are.
So I suppose, I was right.
I'm doing something important.
Kinkachu snapped.
I'm here to save the queen, if you must
know.
Winter caught the shifty expression that
crossed Obsidian's face.
Maybe Moon was right.
Maybe this dragon's thoughts were as
dangerous as they sounded.
Then Obsidian looked up, and his gaze
landed on winter.
His tail began lashing furiously.
And I swing.
He hissed.
Now a rainforest.
Don't just look in the trees, friend.
Come down and say hello.
That sounded like just about the last
thing Winter wanted to do, but picking a
fight with a night wing would waste
time.
Time he needed to find his sister.
He reluctantly spread his wings.
Don't let him bully you.
Moon whispered, catching one of Winter's
talons before he could lift off.
He's afraid of you.
He's planning how to be as cruel and
commanding as possible, because he wants
to see you squirm.
I don't squirm for anyone.
Winter snarled under his breath.
I know, Moon said.
You shouldn't.
You're a much better dragon than he is.
You're.
You're a much better dragon than most
anyone.
She ducked her head to look down at her
claws.
Winter blinked at her.
Was that really what she thought?
Even after looking inside him?
Not me though, right?
Kibley said, nudging Moon with a grin.
He's not better than me.
I'm awesome, right?
Like, the most awesome.
The way she smiled back at the sand wing
like she couldn't help herself, made
Winters scales feel all crawly and too
warm.
He spent away from them and leaped down
to the ground.
The night wing guard sat back on his
haunches, inspecting the dragons
suspiciously, as Moon and Kibley landed
on the river bank as well.
Having a night wing's gaze on him
traveling over him as though he was a
half eaten seal carcass, made Winter want
to smash in some faces with his tail.
He scraped his serrated claws through the
damp layer of leaves on the forest
floor.
You're the peculiar dragonette, Obsidian
said finally, narrowing his eyes at
Moon.
Failed school already.
Did they realize you can't talk and send
you back?
What's with a multi-colored escort?
He squinted at the dragons around her.
Exactly who are you?
None of your business, Winter growled.
Obsidian's brows went up, and he eyed
Winter even more closely.
Winter wondered if it would be a bad
start if he slashed that superior
expression right off the black dragon's
face.
We're here to see Queen Glory, Kibley
said.
Winter was interested to hear a note of
hostility in Kibley's voice as well.
From what he'd seen so far, the Sandwing
usually got along with everyone, or tried
to, especially right at first.
And trust me, she'll want to see us.
So don't be a camel sniffer about it.
I have to take you to the night village
Obsidian said haughtily.
That's the protocol for new dragons in
the rainforest.
We'll send her a message, and if she
wants to see you.
She'll come find you there.
Um, no, Kinkachu said.
Hello, I am a rain wing, not a new
dragon.
I live here.
I'm practically the queen's best friend.
And I am taking my new friends to see her
right now.
The Nightwing shifted his wings slightly
and flicked his tongue through his sharp
teeth.
Kinkachoo, Moon said, touching her claw
mate's shoulder.
Actually, if we go to the village, I
could see my mother, and we could ask
whether anyone's seen icicle.
Oh, all right.
Kingichu agreed.
But I'm going because I want to, not
because anyone is telling me to.
She flared the rough behind her ears at
Obsidian, turning it orange as she did.
He smiled nastily.
Well, come along then.
I'll go tell Queen Glory you're here, said
Bromeliad, lifting off into the trees.
Winter followed Kibley and the others
staying a few steps behind so he could
keep an eye on Obsidian.
He had imagined visiting the home of the
night wings many times, but in those
fantasies.
He always arrived at the head of a
battalion of ice wings.
His visions, generally involved, swooping
down in vengeful glory, blasting frost
breath across the entire city, and wiping
out the whole tribe in one icy attack.
Nightwings had been the sworn enemies of
ice wings for 100s of years.
But there hadn't been any action between
them during winter's lifetime.
The ice wings had been too busy with the
war of sand wings succession, fighting
nearly every other tribe, to worry about
the secretive, impossible to find night
wings.
But then the news had arrived about the
massacre at the Sky Wing Palace.
When the tribe heard that Nightwings had
descended on Scarlet's arena, and
slaughtered all the ice wing prisoners
while they were still chained and bound.
Well, winter wasn't the only one who'd
sworn vengeance.
Finding the secret night wing home had
become the ambition of every young ice
wing.
And now here he was, about to walk right
into it.
This wasn't the secret home, of course.
This was their new home, the one they'd
been driven to after the volcano erupted
and wiped out their last home.
Everyone knew about this one.
Just like everyone knew the night wings
had no more powers, that they were
resettling in the rainforest, and that a
seven-year-old rain wing was their new
queen.
They heard the village before they saw
it.
Wing beats, branches being ripped off
trees, something that sounded like
hammering.
Winter could also smell meat cooking over
fire, and he wished he could order his
stomach not to growl and embarrass him.
Then he saw black scales ahead, and felt
his talons start tingling.
Two dragons were pacing across a path
that had been cleared through the trees
evidently guarding it.
Obsidian went on ahead to speak to them
in low murmurs.
The Night Wings glanced over, and
Winter's claws curled in.
If he had to die fighting night wings.
That would be a fine way to go out.
Will they kill me?
Like they killed Hillstorm?
He caught himself.
It was instinct to see a night wing and
think of his brother's death, but
according to Queen Scarlet, Hailstorm
wasn't dead. 12 other ice wing prisoners
definitely were, though, and somewhere in
this village were the dragons who killed
them.
Obsidian beckoned Winter and the others
forward with his tail, and the 2 guards
stepped aside to let them pass, smirking
in a horribly superior night wing sort of
way.
What do you think those smug expressions
are for?
Kibley said loudly to winter?
Doesn't seem like night wings have
anything left to be smug about, right?
I mean, they've gone from claiming to be
the most powerful tribe in Pyria, to
homeless and pathetic, and bowing to rain
wings.
All 3 guards bristled, flaring their
What's wrong with bowing to a rain wing?
Kinkaju demanded.
Kibli, quit making things worse.
Moon hissed.
I was just wondering, he said calmly, with
a wink at winter.
Winter knew what he was doing, and it had
worked.
Kibley's words had riled up the night
wings, and made Winter feel better at the
same time.
All of his senses were on high alert as
they walked into the village, and more
and more night wings appeared around
them.
His eyes darted around, assessing their
activity.
He expected plotting and scheming and
battle training.
But most of the night wings seemed to be
busily engaged in very ordinary things.
A group of 10 were grappling with vines
and bushes and stunted trees, trying to
expand the open space.
Three more were washing fruit in the
river, near a set of cooking fires dug
into the ground, where another 4 night
wings were roasting what looked like
small pigs.
Several others were working on shoring up
their ramshackle huts that dotted the
cleared area.
Winter saw a young dragon scramble onto a
roof to add more giant palm leaves, only
to have the entire structure cave in
underneath her.
She plummeted to the ground with a yell
and a crash, and a few other night wings
began shouting at her.
There were a few rain wings who might
have helped them build all this.
Kinkaju explained suddenly. glancing at
Winter and Kibley.
We could have showed them how to set up
their village in the treetops, like ours
but the night wings didn't want help.
Plus they thought it was too sunny up
there.
Like, what does that even mean?
How could it ever be too sunny?
It was cooler down on the rainforest
floor, but it was all so muddier.
Winter wasn't sure which option he'd
prefer, but he was glad he didn't have to
live here at all.
He wondered if the Night Wings really
founded an improvement over their last
home.
Mother, Moon cried suddenly.
Her whole face lit up, like the sun
sparkling off a glacier.
She flew across the clearing and threw
her wings around a tall, thin dragon, who
looked a lot like moon, without the
silver teardrop scales near her eyes.
Moon.
The night wing gasped.
Her expression went from quietly tired, to
startled to overjoyed, and she wrapped
the dragonette in close to her with
fierce affection.
Winter felt a strange twinge watching
them.
Ice wings don't hug like that.
He reminded himself.
At least royal ones don't.
It would be undignified.
He couldn't imagine his mother or father
wrapping their wings around him, or
looking that happy to see him, for that
matter.
Was this how all night wings were with
their dragonettes?
He glanced around the clearing, looking
for dragons younger than himself, and
realized they were almost none.
It took him a while to finally spot one
by the river, leaning against his
mother's side and helping to wash fruit.
She had one wing tented protectively over
him.
And there was another small dragonette
over by a fallen tree, practicing her
flying.
A dragon who might be her father stood
beside her, catching her when she fell
awkwardly.
There was something protective and proud
about the way he was standing too.
Winter pulled his gaze away and noticed
odd looks on the other dragonette's faces
Kibli and Kinkaju.
There was something faintly wistful in
their expressions as they watched Moon
and her mother.
He caught himself starting to wonder what
their family stories were.
They look like lonely cows, he thought
ferociously.
I refuse to moon about like that over
anything.
My parents are perfect the way they are.
They made me strong and dangerous, a true
dragon, stronger than anyone else here
that's for sure.
I may not be as fearsome as Hellstorm, but
still, I'm an ice wing, the greatest
tribe in Pyria.
I must act like one, especially here, with
so many night wing eyes on me, like
father says, be strong.
Be vigilant, strike 1st, and trust
nobody.
What are you doing here?
Moon's mother asked, holding Moon by her
shoulders.
Moon curled her wings in, her face
falling.
I didn't get thrown out.
She said in a soft voice, I didn't do
anything wrong, and nobody...
That didn't happen, mother.
Winter realized that Moon was responding
to something her mother was thinking.
He touched his Skyfire pouch again, and
wondered if the little rock could protect
him from all the night wings here, or if
there were other secret mind readers
invading his thoughts right now.
Shh, said the older dragon, pulling moon
close again, she eyed Winter and Kibli
warily.
But I did make friends, Moon said.
She wriggled out of her mother's grasp.
You should meet them.
She turned toward the others, and her
eyes went wide.
No, stop, she shouted.
He's not?
Suddenly, Claus encircled Winter's neck
and his body was thrown to the ground
with a jarring thud.
Someone bigger and heavier leaped on top
of him, pinning him down.
Don't ball the struggling ice wing, said
an unfamiliar voice.
You're under arrest.
Chapter 5.
Winter warred with fury, struggling to
fight back, but his attacker had him
expertly immobilized.
Stop it.
Get off him.
Moon yelled.
Winter couldn't see much, with his snout
pressed into the ground, but he felt the
weight of dragons pushing and grappling
on his wings.
He's on our side.
Kingachu cried, or he was, before you
randomly attacked him for no reason.
Now he'll never like us again.
I wasn't going to anyway.
Winter bellowed as best he could, seething
with rage and humiliation.
I didn't like you before either.
I don't like any of you.
And I'm going to murder this night wing.
I don't know.
It sounds kind of murder e, Kinkachu, said
the voice.
And we heard there's an extra dangerous
ice swing on the loose right now, so I'm
going to keep sitting on him until I get
further instructions.
I'm instructing you.
Kinkaju yelped.
He's not the dangerous one.
That's his sister.
It's true.
Kibli chimed in.
This one is honorable.
He's no sneak in the night assassin.
Hey.
Ouch. said the dragon on top of winter.
Nothing wrong with assassins.
Who said there was anything dishonorable
about assassins?
They're just not allowed to kill my... my
queen.
It's my job to stop them, and drop some
violence on their heads, but I'm not
judging them, Sheesh.
He's not here to kill glory, Moon said.
If he were, he would tell you, and he'd
challenge her in open combat.
Would I?
Winter wondered.
True.
I wouldn't hurt a nothing rain wing.
But if I'd had a chance to kill the night
wing queen.
Would I have done it the honorable way?
Or any way possible?
What would mother have wanted me to do?
Anyway possible, he guessed.
That was how Icicle and Hellstorm had
been trained.
Death Bringer.
Another new voice thundered, loud enough
to rattle the leaves overhead.
What are you doing?
Saving you?
Protecting the forest?
Defending our new home, sitting on a very
cold ice wing, said the night wing, from
his perch on Winters back.
You know, the usual.
A murmur eddied through the village as
footsteps approached.
Winter tried to wriggle around to see who
was coming, but Death Bringer reached out
and gently pinned his head to the ground
again.
A grotesque greenish brown beetle with
about 4000 legs came scuttling up and
began creeping curiously onto Winter's
nose.
Stop arresting my guests, said the
newcomer, pausing beside winter.
It's not romantic or heroic, it's
annoying.
I've told you this before.
I know, Deathbringer said. sounding
aggrieved.
But look, it's an ice wing.
Sonny specifically said an ice wing tried
to kill all the prophecy dragonettes.
This is definitely opinion before asking
questions kind of situation.
All right, off.
Glory said firmly.
The weight on top of winter suddenly
lifted. as if she'd hauled Death Bringer
off with her own talons.
I am going to replace you as my
bodyguard.
If you seriously can't tell the
difference between a male ice wing
traveling with my friends, Kinkaju and
Moon Watcher, and a lone female ice wing
out to kill me.
Pay a little more attention to detail
Deathbringer.
Also, by the way, you're one to talk
about killing prophecy dragonettes.
Winter scrambled upright, flinging the
beetle off his nose and baring his teeth
as he spun around.
His attacker was a night wing a few years
older than him, wiry and graceful, and
clearly trained to fight from the way he
stood, and the way he was assessing
winter.
Winter lunged toward him, and found his
way blocked by a dark green dragon with
flares of orange around her ears, and
along the underside of her wings.
She reached out and took one of Winter's
talons, pressing it between hers, and
lowering her head in a small bow.
We are so honored to have Queen Glacier's
nephew in our forest, she said.
I sincerely apologize for the outrageous
behavior of my brain dead bodyguard.
You should have been escorted at once to
my royal pavilion, not attacked in such a
disrespectful manner.
She glanced around the gawking night
wings.
Everyone back to work?
Right now.
To winter's surprise, they obeyed her.
Although there were a few muttered
grumbles and 2 or 3 dragons who moved
deliberately slowly.
He hesitated.
Every bone in his body wanted to fly into
a rage and rip Deathbringer's wings off.
He couldn't let a night wing treat him
that way, especially in front of all the
other night wings, and get away with it.
But he'd never been greeted as visiting
royalty before, and there was something
irresistibly compelling about the way
Queen Glory beckoned him to walk beside
her. as if they were equals.
Will he be punished?
Winter demanded.
Oh yes.
Glory said, frowning at Deathbringer
creatively and firmly.
Very well.
Winter said.
He shook as much dirt off his wings as he
could, and stepped up regally beside
Glory.
I don't have time to punish him myself
anyway.
We have urgent matters to discuss.
Indeed, said the queen, turning to lead
the way out of the village.
Behind him, Winter heard Moon saying
goodbye to her mother, and the others
hurrying to join him.
Sunny told me some of the details, but I
hope you can fill in the rest.
I can, Kinkaju offered, bouncing up on
Glory's other side.
Winter sister, icicle, who is like wicked
scary, by the way, was secretly
conspiring with Queen Scarlet, because it
turns out Winter's brother is like
actually alive, not dead like everyone
thought, and Scarlet's totally got him
locked up somewhere.
So icicle was going to kill Starflight to
get him back, except then Moon and Kibley
and Winter, completely heroically stopped
her, and it was apparently amazing, and I
missed the whole thing.
Can you believe it?
And so then Icicle flew off, and we
figure she's coming here to kill you.
So we're here to completely heroically
stop her, again, and also find out what
she knows, so we can rescue Winter's
brother ourselves.
Also, hello, school is awesome.
How are you?
You are in as much trouble as
Deathbringer.
Gloria said sternly, looking down at the
dragonette.
What were you thinking?
Leaving school without permission?
When everyone was already in such a
state?
Do you know how worried Sonny and Clay
have been?
Kinkachu stopped in her tracks with an
expression of deep dismay, and an
explosion of dark blue splotches across
her scales.
Oh no, she cried.
I'm sorry?
didn't turtle tell them where we went?
Yes, and that certainly helped, Glory
said with a snort.
Good news.
Four of your students have gone off to
find a dragon who just tried to kill you
in order to find another dragon who has
tried to kill you about 90 dozen times.
Oh, excellent.
Thanks, turtle.
Now I don't have to worry at all.
I mean, we were hoping somebody would
take care of the vengeful and deadly
Queen Scarlet Forest, probably a bunch of
5 year olds.
Very reassuring indeed.
Moon ducked her head.
Sorry, Your Majesty, she said, and this
felt urgent.
She glanced sideways at winter, and an
odd flicker of something like gratitude
went off in his chest.
Stupid, stupid, as if he cared that she
knew how important it was to find his
brother.
I didn't ask for help, and I don't need
it.
It is urgent.
Kinkachu said.
We think Icicle is coming here next to
kill you.
That's what I said.
Offered Deathbringer, who was trailing
behind them with an expression that
looked closer to amused than repentant.
Ahem.
Glory considered kinkaju thoughtfully.
Do you really think so?
Absolutely, Kibley interjected.
You're the only target she has left.
It's the smart choice for her.
I'd wager a month of lizards on it.
That would be irritating.
Glory said.
If Deathbringer turns out to be right, I
mean.
It makes him really insufferable.
I am here to search for my sister, Winter
said to Queen Glory.
I just need your assurance that no one
will interfere with me while I do that.
He cast a dark glands over his shoulder
at Deathbringer.
I think we can do better than that said
the queen.
She stopped and tilted her snout at one
of the branches overhead.
Banana?
Winter frowned.
No, thank you.
But as he spoke, he noticed a shimmering
in the air around the branch, and then
all at once, there was a dragon sitting
there, in a rather hideous shade of pink
that winter had never seen before.
Actually, it's heliconia, Your Majesty
said the rain wing, but good guess.
Glory flicked her tail.
Heliconia.
Please tell my scout captains to meet me
at the pavilion as soon as possible.
The pink dragon scales started fading
into shades of blue.
But I shouldn't leave you unguarded
majesty.
The rain wing queen waved her talons at
the surrounding trees.
I think 7 guards are quite sufficient.
One might call it overkill, in fact, one
might even infer that somebody doesn't
think he can do his job properly on his
own.
Also that he must think I'm either blind
and deaf or recently hit on the head, that
I wouldn't notice the addition of 5 more
dragons following me around.
The whole point of a top secret invisible
guard.
Deathbringer said severely, is for them
to be invisible and secret.
Therefore, it is extremely unhelpful for
certain queens to go pointing them out
and discussing them loudly with the
entire rainforest.
Go now, Glory said to Heliconia, ignoring
Deathbringer.
The rain wing guard bowed immediately and
vanish.
Winter could barely hear her wing beats
flapping away over the buzzing, dripping
sounds of the rainforest.
He curled his talons and stared up at the
trees.
There were 7 other dragons up there
watching them.
He couldn't see any sign of even one.
All right, he admitted to himself
grudgingly.
That's kind of an impressive skill.
Ice wings were good at hiding in the snow
of course, but here in the rainforest, he
stuck out like a broken wing, which means
icicle wheel 2 at least.
The pavilion is a short flight this way.
Glory explained to winter.
I had it built halfway between the night
wings and the rain wings for anything
official.
She took to the air and Winter and the
others followed her.
He strained his ears to listen for the
sound of 7 extra pairs of wings flying
alongside them, but it was impossible to
separate them out from the others.
Queen Glory's royal pavilion was a vast
platform in the air, built on the
branches of a circle of tall, overlapping
trees.
Winter guessed, that it was about midway
between the ground and the treetops
middle ground for the night wings and
rain wings.
It had a roof made of the same
translucent leaves he'd seen in the
library windows at Jade Mountain
constructed atop twisted wooden columns
instead of walls, so the pavilion was
open to the air, but sheltered from the
rain.
Purple and blue morning glory flowers
hung like bells from the vines that wound
around each column, and delicate white
orange pink orchids, grew from the mossy
crevices of the trees.
They landed one by one, shaking out their
wings and sinking their talons into the
claw marked wooden floor.
Winter's gay swept over the interior of
the pavilion, which was almost empty.
Two scroll racks stood on either side of
a simple raised days, only a few inches
higher than the rest of the platform.
Not much of a throne.
Winter reflected, as Glory climbed onto
it and settled herself with her tail
around her claws.
Now, she said, I know who you all are, but
let's officially meet anyway.
I'm glory, queen of the rain wings and
the night wings.
My overenthusiastic bodyguard there is
Death Bringer.
She lifted one talon into the air, and a
sleek, beautiful gray sloth clambered
down from the roof beams to curl up on
her shoulder.
And this is silver.
Royal Pet, not royal lunch.
Kibley said to Winter, nudging his wing.
So try not to eat it, if you can restrain
yourself.
I'm Kibli, your majesty, one of Queen
Thorn's advisors.
Welcome.
And then we have Moon Watcher, Kinkajoo
and of course, Prince Winter, said
Glory.
My friends will be very relieved that
you're all safe.
Jade Mountain is a bit of a mess right
now, and it didn't help to have one
entire winglet disappear.
Sorry, Kinkachu squeaked.
Sorry, Moon agreed, looking down at her
talons.
There was a pause.
The queen gazed sternly down her nose at
the other dragons.
All right.
I'm sorry for making them worry, Kibley
said, but winter can't go searching for
icicle and hailstorm all by himself.
Yes, I can, Winter said sharply.
That's the entire plan.
That's what I'm going to do.
It suddenly occurred to him to wonder
what would happen if someone else found
icicle before he did, when they tried to
hurt her.
They'd end up dead if they did.
She was bigger, more ferocious, and 10
times better trained than any of these
little dragons.
His insides gave a weird lurch as he
imagined what would happen if she found
moon unguarded.
Icicle would definitely kill her.
The night wing who'd foiled her plan to
kill Starflight.
The Nightwing, who was already too close
to her brother from Icicle's point of
view.
If she knew how I've been feeling about
Moon, she'd be even more likely to kill
her, he realized.
Not that he felt that way about Moon
anymore.
He couldn't.
Moon had lied to him and invaded his
mind.
He could put her safely back in the
category of despicable conniving night
wings.
I hate.
He glanced over at her as she lifted her
head and met his eyes.
Something in her expression said, I will
help you whether you let me or not.
Much like the 1st time they'd met, when
she'd protected his scavenger, no matter
how he threatened her.
It doesn't mean anything.
This twisting feeling in my chest.
I can hate her, and still not want Icicle
to kill her.
It doesn't mean that I care about her.
Well, let's see.
Glory said, sitting up alertly.
Here come my watchers.
Dragons began appearing out of the leaves
materializing like the sun coming out
from behind a cloud.
In alarmingly bright shades of yellow
blue, and pink, they swooped into the
pavilion and landed in a row in front of
Queen Glory, until there were 6 dragons
lined up.
Although a line was hardly the right
description for the slipshod way they
were standing.
Some of them with their wings akimbo, or
their tails flopping all over the place.
No discipline, Winter thought
disapprovingly.
Remembering the rigid, perfectly coiled
lines of guards that attended Queen
Glacier.
He also remembered practicing for hours
to get that stance just right, his wings
folded exactly so, his tail in the right
position, his snout up, and shoulders
back.
It was agony to hold that pose for too
long, but his mother had made him stand
like that before every meal, making him
wait until she approved before letting
him eat.
These rain wings need someone to whip
them into shape.
He thought, resettling his tail with a
small rattle of spikes.
I called you in to ask if any of you have
seen any sign of an ice wing today.
Queen Glory said.
For those of you who don't remember the
lessons, those are the white or blue
dragons with spiked tails and cold
scales.
One of the rain wings leaned toward her.
In a loud whisper that carried to the
other side of the pavilion, he hissed
Your majesty, I think there's one of
them.
Right behind me.
The dragon next to him looked around in
alarm, spotted winter, and leaped
backward, nearly knocking one of her
companions off the platform.
Oh my gosh, is that what they look like?
She cried.
Why is it pointy all over?
Look at its tail. yelped another.
It really is all spiky.
And can you feel how cold it is?
Whoa that's so weird.
Said a 4th, reaching for Winter's wing
Winter twitched back and growled at her.
Glory exhaled slowly through her nose.
This is our guest.
Prince Winter of the Ice Wings.
Have you seen any dragons today that look
like him?
No?
They all answered, almost in unison.
Would have noticed if I did.
One of them offered.
Look at how sparkly he is.
Like raindrops on a cobweb or something.
I'll say, agreed another.
Plus brr.
I think I had woken up if something that
cold went by me.
Me too, said a third.
The queen closed her eyes eloquently.
Death bringer cleared his throat.
Permission to check with the backup night
wing guards?
he asked.
Yes, yes, Glory said, waving him away.
But make sure you tell them if they do
see an ice wing, they are to follow her
not attack her, especially if they're on
their own.
Deathbringer bowed and spread his wings.
And that includes you, Glory yelled after
him as he flew away.
Keep your claws to yourself.
Can't hear you.
He called back cheerfully.
Winter glanced sideways at Moon, and
found her staring intently at one of the
rain wing watchers.
Um, Moon said.
Your Majesty?
Can I ask?
Yes, Glory said, waving her talons.
Speak up.
Just, even if they didn't see an ice
wing?
Moon blurted in a hurry, anything
suspicious, like something frozen or
colder than usual.
She trailed off.
She knows that Rain Wing saw something
Winter guest.
She saw it in his head.
But of course, she hadn't told Queen
Glory she could read minds yet.
Well?
There was this weird spot near the oldest
giant banyan tree.
The rain wing scout mused, almost to
himself.
I did notice something funny there.
What do you mean?
Gloria asked him.
There was a spot on the ground that was
all shriveled up, kind of.
The rain wing answered.
His scales were royal blue, dotted with
little swirls of dark pink.
It looked like something had killed all
the plants in a circle there.
And they were kind of crusty and whitish
and the berries were as hard as rocks.
Oh, and kind of cold too.
Do you think that's important?
Winter flared his wings.
Where was this?
he demanded.
How far away?
I know where the banyan tree is.
Glory said, already rising.
She untangled silver from her neck and
deposited the sloth on a nearby branch.
We can be there in a few minutes.
The rest of you, stay here.
Can't I come too?
Moon asked.
I can be useful.
I. She stopped, struggling for words.
Winter realized that she was hoping her
mind reading could help.
Me too, Kinkachu cried.
I want to come.
No, Queen Glory said firmly.
I am your queen, both of you, and I'm
ordering you to stay here.
Winter wished he could insist on going by
himself.
But he needed someone to show him the
way.
And if he was perfectly honest, someone
who could sense Icicle's mind nearby
would probably come in handy.
Moon can come, he said, with what he
hoped was an offhanded shrug.
That's fine.
Not her, though.
She's far too loud.
He jerked his chin at Kinkaju.
I am not.
Kinkaju protested.
That's so unfair.
Kinkaju?
You wanted me to be queen, and now you
have to listen to me, Glory said.
Stay here, because if you get killed by
an ice wing, I'm going to be extremely
mad at you.
She glanced from winter to moon, a
wrinkle of puzzlement on her forehead.
But all right, Moon, come along.
Soon the 3 of them were soaring through
the trees, well, trying to soar.
Winter kept getting his wings tangled in
unexpected vines, or spider webs, or
branches, or once, snagged on the nest of
a large beaked, indignant red bird.
After a few minutes of lying, Queen Glory
stopped abruptly and swung around.
That is a level of noisy that makes me
think you aren't even trying to be
stealthy, she said.
Come on out.
Kibli emerged sheepishly from behind a
tree with huge leaves.
I was trying to be stealthy.
He protested, but there's too many things
to crash into.
I'm a wide open desert kind of dragon.
Winter shook off a tangle of moss and
branches, disgruntled to realize he
agreed with a sandwing about something.
What did I say about staying put?
Glory asked.
You're a great queen, I hear, but with
all due respect, you're not my queen
Kibley said, setting his jaw.
I go where they go.
Besides, winter wants me along.
He just can't admit it.
I don't.
Winter said.
You can send him back to the kingdom of
Sand for all I care.
He adores me, Kibley said.
Glory willed her eyes.
Fine, enough arguing.
Let's go.
Kibli shot Winter a delighted grin, and
flapped over to fly beside Moon.
She was surprisingly dexterous at moving
between the trees and dodging stray
branches.
Even glory still ran into things
occasionally, but moon slipped easily
through the forest like a seal diving in
the waves.
Soon they were descending toward an
absolutely enormous fat tree, with
bulging branches and knobbly roots
sticking out of the undergrowth.
From the air, Winter spotted the circle
the rain wing had mentioned.
The frozen berries had melted into mushy
puddles of purple, while the leaves and
undergrowth were all black and damp.
But it wasn't a neat circle.
There were patches of green still left
within the circumference of it, which
meant something had been blocking icicles
frost breath in those spots, something, or
someone.
Glory and Moon circled the tree, while
Winter and Kibbledy landed and studied
the rainforest floor.
A sharp headache was starting to work its
way through Winter's brain.
He didn't want this to be true.
He wanted to find icicle, but he didn't
want to find out that she'd done
something else terrible.
The layers of leaves and bracken were
disturbed here, as if something had been
dragged away.
Kibling noticed it too.
His snout wrinkled with concern.
Winter followed the trail, trying to
guess what he would have done in this
situation.
Hidden the body.
To give myself more time before I was
caught.
But she couldn't have dragged it far.
Maybe I'm just imagining the worst.
Maybe she killed a rainforest boar.
A really big one?
And dragged it off to eat?
Maybe?
Winter paced over to a wall of bushes
where the ground began to slope up.
The banyan's roots extended this far, some
of them nearly as fat around as a
dragon.
Between one of the roots and the bushes
was a mound of leaves, dirt, moss, and
mulch that looked too big to be natural.
His heart sinking.
Winter started to clear away the debris.
Moon and Kibley joined him, helping
silently.
The corpse of a nightwing guard lay
beneath the dirt in a hastily dug hollow
his face contorted in frozen rage.
His throat slashed, and his scales
ravaged by frost breath.
Icicle was definitely here.
Chapter 6.
Moons, Glory muttered, staring over
Winter's shoulder at the corpse.
Clouds of dark red were gathering along
her wings and spine.
This is bad winter.
Bad for your sister, bad for the peace of
the rainforest.
The night wings are going to set their
heads on fire.
Kibli agreed.
No wait.
They're going to set the closest ice
wings head on fire.
Winter?
I hope your skull is as thick as it
looks.
Winter didn't want to ask.
He really believed that reading another
dragon's mind was wrong, but if it meant
stopping icicle before she did something
like this again, and finding her before a
vengeful troop of night wings did, he
gazed at Moon until she looked up and met
his eyes.
He tilted his chin questioningly, and she
shook her head.
She couldn't hear icicles mind nearby.
If icicle sees you for, she'll know
you're here to stop her.
Glory said.
She gave Moon a worried glance.
Let's get you somewhere safe.
And you, Moon pointed out.
The queen snorted, as though she was
pretty sure she could handle anything and
led the way back to the royal pavilion.
What happened?
Kinkachu yelped as soon as she saw them.
She leaped up, her scales shifting into
spirals of orange and lavender.
Did you find her?
Uh-oh, winter looks mad.
Well, actually, that's how he always
looks.
Is he mad?
What happened?
Deathbringer was there too.
Stamping around, making the platform
shake, and accidentally ripping flowers
off the vines.
By yourself.
He warred at glory, with 3 little
dragonettes to protect you.
Excuse me?
Winter objected.
Dragons my age are seasoned warriors
where I come from.
We guard the queen all the time in the
ice kingdom.
Don't get your tail in a knot.
Glory said to Death Bringer.
Her sloth was already clambering up her
tail onto her back again.
My top secret invisible guard was
following us too, and you know it.
But I wasn't, he protested.
She gave him an exasperated look.
You can't always be, she said, in a low
surprisingly affectionate voice, that
suddenly made Winter rethink everything
he had assumed about the queen and her
bodyguard.
So calm down and trust me to take care of
myself.
Says the dragon, who got herself chained
up in a lava prison.
Deathbringer muttered.
The important thing is that we know the
ice wing is here, Glory said.
She is?
Kinkachu squeaked.
Actually here?
In the rainforest?
Right this minute.
Winter thought.
She's close by.
His perfect overachieving sister was
somewhere in this damp mud hole, hiding
from rain wings and planning a murder.
How far would she be willing to go?
If Winter tried to stop her?
Would she kill one brother in order to
save the other?
Don't leave out the key adjectives in
there.
Kill one low ranked, disappointing
brother in order to save the long lost
hero with a bright future.
That makes the equation a bit easier.
Glory's tail lashed back and forth as she
began issuing orders.
We need to organize teams to search
starting here and spreading outward.
I also need you to come look at something
for me.
She brushed Deathbringer's tail lightly
with her own.
To identify the body.
Winter guest.
Before she tells the other night wings
what we found.
So she can tell them who's dead.
As for you all, Glory said, turning to
Winter and Moon and Kibli.
I think the safest place is the
Dragonette Wingery.
It's not far.
It's already well fortified, and I'll
double the guard to protect you.
What?
Winter cried. flaring his wings.
You can't lock us up with a bunch of new
hatched dragonettes.
I need to look for my sister.
Glory shook her head.
I'm sorry, Winter, but if anything
happens to you, the ice wings will
declare war on us, and I wouldn't blame
them.
Keeping you safe is the most important
thing.
She hesitated.
I promise to let you speak with her when
we find her.
Unless an overzealous nightwing kills her
first, Winter shouted.
He lashed his tail furiously.
You can't promise me you'll keep her
alive.
I know how night wings are.
They'll kill her the moment they see
her.
I am their queen, Glory said, with steely
ferocity, and I will not let them do
that.
She's my sister, Winter Ward.
Exactly, Glory snapped back.
So you're in danger from her and from the
entire tribe of Nightwings.
Once they find out what she did.
I'm not having any more dead dragons in
my rainforest today.
Warm claws step down hard on Winter's
back foot.
He whirled around, snarling.
Stop arguing with her.
Kibley whispered through his teeth.
She's not going to give in.
Kinkaju agreed.
Behind her, Moon nodded, adding the
weight of a mind reader to that opinion.
Glory was already turning back to
Deathbringer, and a pair of scout
captains.
Winter shoved Kibley away.
He was not done fighting about this.
There was no way he was going to sit
quietly with a bunch of baby dragons
while an enemy tribe chased down his
sister.
Listen, Kibley hissed, shoving him back.
If you keep arguing, she'll add even more
guards.
Just agree, and then we'll sneak off.
It's the only way.
Kinkachu's eyes went wide, and her scales
turned an odd shade of yellowish green
but Moon was nodding again.
We'll figure it out, she agreed in a
whisper.
We'll make sure you're the 1st one to
find your sister.
Winter ground his teeth together.
He'd spent a lifetime being told what to
do.
But that was by other ice wings.
No rain wing could order him around.
And you didn't have to listen to
whispered advice from a sandwing either.
Mother and father would want him to fight
right now.
He was sure of it.
They'd wreck this pavilion and fight the
entire tribe, both tribes.
If anyone tried to stop them from hunting
for icicle.
But if he fought everyone now.
Glory would see him as a threat, just
like Icicle.
Whereas, if he waited, and snuck off to
search for her as Kibley suggested.
It was horrible.
Winter could almost see his ranking
plummeting.
Everything he'd ever worked for, vanishing
as he bowed his head to obey a rainbow
bright dragonette, queen of the night
wings.
It'll be worth it if I come back with
hailstorm, he told himself fiercely.
Even if I'm the bottom ranked ice wing
for the rest of my life, saving Hillstorm
would make all of this worthwhile.
And so he agreed.
He nearly changed his mind when he saw
the rainforest wingery, though.
It was even worse than he'd feared
exactly the sort of soft, cuddly, lazy
stupid setup, he should have expected
from a bunch of rain wings.
They didn't care if their dragon heads
grew up to be feeble and non
threatening.
So of course they left them to roll
around like mammal cubs, instead of
launching their training the moment they
hatched.
The main play area was an enormous
trampoline made of springy vines and
leaves, strung between several trees high
above the ground.
It was surrounded on all sides by tall
soft, woven mats of branches that kept
the baby dragons from falling over the
edge.
Six full grown dragons guarded the
perimeter. 3 night wings and 3 rain wings
all of whom looked more alert and tense
than anyone else winter had seen so far.
One of the night wings inspected each of
them carefully before allowing them
inside.
She poked their small skyfire bags
sniffed the rocks, studied Winter's snout
with a worried expression, and spent a
full minute examining Kibley's deadly
tail barb.
It's very safe.
Kibley promised her.
Sandwing dragonettes learn early how to
avoid accidentally stabbing anyone.
He coiled his tail protectively inward
and the guard jumped back.
I don't like it.
She said to Heliconia, the rain wing
who'd escorted them to the wingery.
We're supposed to keep complete strangers
away from the dragonettes, and this one
looks the mildest word I can think of is
hostile.
She frowned at winter.
That's just his face, said Kibley, and
his personality.
He would never harm a dragonette.
Moon promised.
I can speak for myself.
Winter snapped.
Grumbling under her breath, the Nightwing
finally let them pass.
They flew up and over the woven wall
landing lightly on the platforms around
the trampoline inside.
Winter scanned the space, and saw that it
was full of peculiar toys that didn't
appear to teach anything or impart any
valuable skills whatsoever.
Inside the wingery were 9 dragonettes
less than a year old.
At first glance, Winter thought they were
all night wings, because they all had
black scales, and were wrestling in a
pile together.
But when the newcomers landed on the
platforms around them, 9 tiny heads
popped up, and 7 of them became suddenly
vibrantly pink and yellow.
Pretty new dragons!
one of them cheered, and 8 dragonettes
came rampaging over, staggering on the
bouncy surface and flapping their
unwieldy wings.
Winter backed up all the way until his
wings hit the wall, but that didn't stop
3 tiny rain wings from closing in on
him.
Glittery, yelped one.
I can do that, said another.
Look, look, look.
He crouched, concentrating, and a wave of
icy blue surged across his scales.
A moment later, he looked like a
miniature version of winter, without the
extra ice dragon spikes and horns.
He held out his claws and cooed
admiringly himself.
Nice work, Kinkaju said.
She squinted at winter as though he were
an ice sculpture that needed improving.
You could add a little more dark blue
shading around the spine and edges of the
wings.
Sure.
The dragonette clicked his teeth together
thoughtfully, and a moment later, a
subtle shift went through some of his
scales, making the jagged ridge along his
back look sharper and taller, a little
more like an ice wings.
Try this one, called a dragonette, who
was circling around Kibley.
The sand wing wrinkled his nose at her
and she wrinkled hers right back.
Her scales were already shifting to the
same pale yellow as his.
She spread her wings and studied the
underside of them, then reached out and
poked Kibley until he opened his wings
for her to examine.
Hmm, she said.
A shimmer of gold and bronze appeared on
her chest, and then slowly melted into a
color that almost exactly matched
Kibley's underscales.
Woo, she cried.
Let's see if I can do is snout.
Winter watched tiny brown freckles in a
small, dark zigzag that matched Kibley's
scar appear on her scales.
He tried to squash his amazement.
Dragonette, less than a year old, could
do that?
Winter glanced around the wingery.
Maybe they weren't completely wasting
their time in here after all.
Of course, camouflage scales weren't as
impressive or useful as hunting and
fighting and survival skills.
Hailstorm had battled a killer whale
before he was one year old.
Winter had been sent out to spend an
entire night in a blizzard alone.
Icicle was already combat training with
dragons 3 times her size by her 1st
birthday.
These dragonettes wouldn't last a minute
in ice wing training.
They wouldn't make a dent in their
rankings at all.
His gaze fell on the one dragonette who
was hanging back.
A small, nervous looking night wing with
a leaf bandage wrapped around one
foreleg.
The dragonette met his eyes, squeaked
nervously, and tucked his head under his
wings.
Don't mind him, said the dragonette, who
turned himself the color of winter.
He's so useless.
Said the other night wing dragonette.
She was sleek and glossy, like a seal, and
was studying the newcomers with more
reserve than the wild curiosity of the
rain wings.
He still having nightmares about the
volcano every night, even though that was
months ago.
Toughen up, lizard, she barked at him.
The bandaged night wing slowly drew his
head out and folded his wings back
shivering from horns to tail.
Winter could see him fighting back his
terror as he squared his shoulders and
faced the new dragons.
Some night wing he is.
The female dragonette snorted.
We keep telling him what an important
dangerous tribe we are, but frankly, I'm
not sure he'll ever measure up.
I guess some dragons are just.
Hatched in the wrong tribe, Moon finished
softly.
Winter tilted his head at her.
Did she wish she weren't a night wing?
Or had she heard other dragons wishing
they could be something different?
Not me.
He couldn't imagine not being a nice
wing.
His whole life was about trying to be a
true ice wing warrior.
All he'd ever wanted was to rise to the
top of the rankings and prove himself to
his parents and the rest of the tribe.
That was all he should want.
Until I met her.
And now I want, What?
To understand a night wing?
To have her care about me?
No wonder he hated himself.
All right, scoot.
Kibley said suddenly, flapping his wings
at the dragonettes.
Leave us alone and go play, quietly, over
there.
He herded the dragonettes to the other
side of the enclosure and came back
ducking his head toward moon.
Are you all right?
He whispered.
Winter realized Moon was rubbing her
temples.
He'd forgotten that she must be hearing
the thoughts of all the dragons around
them.
While the baby dragons were bombarding
the newcomers with words, they must also
be blasting the inside of Moon's head
with their thoughts.
I'm fine.
I just need to adjust.
Moon said, dropping her claws and shaking
out her wings.
We can't sneak away yet.
The guards are too focused on us.
She glanced at Winter.
I'll keep listening.
Her talons went back to her head, and she
closed her eyes.
Guess what?
Kinkaju said.
Lightly bouncing the vines below her.
Her claws had all turned dark green to
match the wingery, so it almost looked as
though she had no feet at all if you
didn't look closely.
I think I figured it out.
I was thinking about Moon's prophecy
while you were off chasing icicle.
The stalker of dreams.
That must be Scarlet, using the dream
visitor to bother people, right?
Maybe, Kibley said.
Although there's something a little
ominous about darkness and stalker so
close to each other in the prophecy.
What if there's a connection to that dark
stalker you mentioned, Winter?
Winter scoffed.
He's been dead for centuries.
If the prophecy is about him, it's a
little out of date.
Was it his imagination, or did Moon just
press her eyes closed even harder?
Everybody, shush, Kinkaju ordered.
I'm telling you something.
So I thought, if Scarlet is the stalker
of dreams, maybe the talons of power and
fire is that freaky sky wing everyone's
afraid of, what's her name again?
Peril.
Winter growled.
Of course it could be peril.
The dragon who could burn other dragons
to death just by touching them.
She'd stared at him with her creepy, fiery
blue eyes, standing there in the entrance
hall of Jade Mountain, as though she
could go wherever she pleased.
After everything she'd done, and everyone
she'd killed.
Free and unpunished.
It wasn't right.
I could believe it.
She's murder waiting to happen.
Kibley shook his head.
But she saved Clay's life.
I was there.
I saw it.
I don't think she's working with Scarlet
anymore.
Then you're an even bigger fool than you
look, Winter snapped.
Hey, hey, quit being mean, Kinkaju said.
Maybe that's what one who is not what she
themes is about.
Peril seems like she's changed, but
actually, she is totally going to betray
the dragonettes, and scorched the earth
and kill everyone and all the other bad
things at once.
She paused.
Suddenly, I am not enjoying this
conversation as much as I thought I
would.
Did you see anything?
In Peril's mind.
Kibley asked Moon, nudging her gently.
Was she planning anything terrible?
Peril's mind is almost impossible to
read.
Moon said, opening her eyes.
It's all fire in there, like she's
burning from the inside too.
I think, I think she's not a happy dragon
but I'm not sure she's evil.
I don't really know though.
I mean, no one is completely evil.
What are you talking about?
Winter demanded.
Plenty of dragons are completely evil.
Not when you see what's going on inside
them.
Moon shook her head fiercely.
Dragons are complicated.
Some are kinder than others.
She looked up at Kibley, then quickly
away.
Or braver than others.
Here she glanced mysteriously at winter
and he shivered.
And some of them do really cruel things
but everyone has both good thoughts and
bad thoughts, and reasons for what they
do, reasons they believe are important.
I don't have bad thoughts.
Do I?
Kinkaju asked Moon.
Moon laughed.
True, not that I ever heard, she
admitted.
I'd better have them all now, quick, while
I can, Kinkaju said, touching her Skyfire
pout with a grin.
Winter puzzled over Moon's words for a
moment.
He would have assumed that hearing other
dragons' thoughts would confirm that most
of them were evil, or at least halfway
there.
How could Moon be immersed in other mines
all day, and still believe in the
goodness of dragons?
She hasn't met very many other dragons.
He told himself.
Growing up in the rainforest, hidden
away.
But she'd met the whole night wing tribe
which surely was full of evil.
And Peril, and Sora, the dragon who'd
tried to kill Winter's sister, and Moon
had met Icicle.
Don't you think icicle is evil?
He blurted.
I mean, I don't, but no, Moon said.
That's what I mean.
She's doing what she thinks she has to do
to save her brother.
I wouldn't make the choices she's made.
And she needs to be stopped.
But I think I understand them.
It is very cold and intense inside her
head.
I guess, I think it would be hard, growing
up like she did. always knowing your
parents are expecting, Um, expecting big
um, things of you.
She trailed off, giving Winter a sideways
glance.
She knows what my parents want from
icicle.
Winter realized with a jolt.
She knows Icicle is supposed to grow up
to challenge Queen Glacier, but she's
keeping that secret.
Perhaps just to show me that she can keep
secrets.
Don't trust her.
He reminded himself.
Nightwings are manipulative.
She's probably just saying what I want to
hear.
Moon shifted her wings, turning to look
at the playing dragonettes, and a fan of
sunshine brushed across her scales.
They're not just black.
Winter thought.
They're more of a dark purple.
With shades of dark blue and green mixed
in.
Back to the prophecy, he said irritably
trying to focus.
So perhaps scarlet imperil are
conspiring.
Maybe they're planning to take down Jade
Mountain together.
What does the old night wing home have to
do with that?
We should go there and see, Kinkachu
said.
It's not far from here.
Maybe, there's something there we can use
to stop them.
Kibley suggested.
The 3rd dream visitor, Moon said
suddenly.
She sat up and flicked her tail over her
talons.
Starflight said it was lost when the
volcano exploded.
Maybe we can find it.
Then we would need to hunt for icicle.
Kibley said, turning to Winter.
You could contact Scarlet yourself and
ask about Hillstorm.
I can't, Winter said.
I've never seen Queen Scarlet.
Icicle was part of the delegation that
went to negotiate for Hellstorm's release
unsuccessfully, obviously.
So they met, and that's why Scarlet can
get into her dreams.
But I couldn't do it, even if I had a
dream visitor.
There was a pause.
Kimberly tapped his claws together softly
thoughtfully.
I might be able to, he said.
I saw her once, from far away, but I
think I could dream visit her.
So let's go.
Kinkaju whispered.
Moon, how about now?
Moon tipped her head sideways, then
nodded.
I think they're calming down, she said
but the little ones are still very
interested in us.
They'll put up a huge fuss if we try to
leave.
Oh, I have a plan for that.
Kinkaju said confidently.
Watch, it'll be hilarious.
She fluffed out her wings, turned herself
in iridescent blue like a dragonfly, and
sauntered over to where the baby dragons
were arguing in loud whispers about why
Winter and Kibley had such weird tales.
Hello?
Kinkachu said to them, once play a game?
Yes!
They all shrieked in chorus.
It's basically hide and seek.
Kinkaju said.
You know, where you try to find the
camouflaged dragons.
The 4 of us have a bet that we can each
hide better than the others, even though
I'm clearly going to win, because I'm the
only rain wing.
She lifted her talons and dramatically
changed them red.
Ooh. went all the dragonettes.
So you all close your eyes and we'll
hide.
And whoever finds one of us 1st wins, said
Kinkachu.
All right, make sure you count to a 1000
so we have enough time.
Okay. squealed one of the rain wings
covering her eyes.
One, two, three, six, 17.
The others all cover their eyes as well
and began shouting random numbers along
with her.
Whoops, Kingajoo said, galloping back to
Moon.
I forgot about how most rain wings can't
count.
We'd better move fast.
Which way?
Kibli asked Moon.
Where are the guards?
Moon closed her eyes, and pointed at 6
spots around the circumference of the
trampoline walls.
And 2 of them are also watching the sky
to make sure we don't fly out.
She added, opening her eyes again.
So we go down, Winter said.
Over here.
He crossed to a corner with more shadows
than the others, where a few curiously
shaped branches and large seed pods were
piled, as if were playing with.
He moved them aside, and touched the
place where the wall met the woven
vines.
If we make a hole here, they might not
notice for a few minutes, long enough for
us to get away.
I can burn a hole, Kibley offered, small
flames spurting from his nose.
Put those away, Kinkachu said, batting it
is snout.
No fire in my forest, thank you.
This will be safer, Winter said.
He crouched, clenched his jaw, and
summoned the cold from deep inside him.
It hissed into his throat, like a
building snowstorm.
Finally, he opened his mouth and shot a
shimmering blast of frost breath at the
web of leaves and branches.
He throws a spot just large enough for a
dragon to crawl through, a small, icy
circle of silver vegetation.
600 One of the dragonettes bellowed
suddenly, leaping ahead a few hundred.
The others gleefully joined in, 609, 642.
Quick, Moon whispered.
Winter leaned forward and wrapped sharply
on the ice with his front claws.
The circle cracked, and then shattered
into tiny frozen splinters, leaving a
jagged hole at the base of the wall.
What was that?
One of the night wing dragonettes asked
but he was drowned out by the others
shouting, 698, 895.
Go, go, go.
Kingaju whispered frantically.
Winter dove through the hole first
catching his wings on a few remaining
shards of ice.
Moon was right behind him as he shot
toward the ground and plunged into a
thicket of enormous leaves.
A moment later, Hibli and Kinkaju landed
beside them with soft thuds.
Kingachu's scales immediately shifted, and
she vanished like a snowball thrown back
into the snow.
Moon was still as an iceberg beside
winter, her wings folded to hide the
silver scales that sparkled underneath
her eyes closed and brow furrowed.
He leaned closer to whisper into her
ear.
Did anyone see us?
She shook her head.
But I can't imagine those dragonettes are
going to believe we're somehow hiding in
there for very long.
You'd be surprised.
Kinkaju said.
Hide and seek is our favorite game in
kind of an obsessive way.
They'll search every square inch of the
wingery before giving up.
I pulled a few things over to hide the
hole.
So with luck, we'll have a few minutes at
least.
This way, Moon said, slipping off into
the trees.
Winter tried to stay low and in the
shadows as he hurried after her.
He spotted the flicker of black wings
overhead, as one of the guards circled
around the wingery, but no one raised an
alarm yet.
How am I going to find icicle?
He whispered to her, before anyone else
does.
She hesitated, giving him a worried
sideways look.
I don't know how much you want to hear
about what I can do.
She whispered back.
I've never had anyone to talk to about it
before, except, well, no one really.
But I don't want to freak you out.
It is disturbing, he admitted.
But tell me anyway, if it's about
icicle.
I can't sense her anywhere.
Moon shook her head.
I've been listening as hard as I can
since we got to the rainforest, but
there's no sign of her.
Maybe she left already, Winter said.
Maybe, she figured out where Scarlet is
and went to confront her.
He checked behind him and saw only Kibley
battling the vines and mud.
If Kinkaju was there, it was impossible
to tell.
What he wouldn't give for camouflage
scales.
Then, he could slip through the trees
without glory or any guards spotting him
he could find icicle, and get her away
from here before anything terrible
happened.
Anything else terrible, that is.
Are you really wishing you were a rain
wing right now?
He scolded himself.
Wouldn't mother and father love to hear
about that?
Now was the time to ditch these dragons
before his thoughts got any more
entangled.
He could fall behind Kibley, wait until
no one was paying attention, and then
take off.
Now that he had the sky fire, Moon
wouldn't be able to find him by his
thoughts.
He'd hunt down icicle, and they'd go get
Hellstorm together.
Or if he couldn't find her, he'd go back
to the ice kingdom on his own, like he'd
originally planned.
He paused for half a step, letting Moon
slip ahead of him.
Another minute, and then, Moon suddenly
froze, digging her talons into the
ground.
Instinctively, Winter and Kibli froze
too.
Search party coming this way, she
whispered.
We have to hide.
She turned and pushed winter toward a
nearby fallen tree, covered with moss and
winding yellow flower vines.
Under there. you fit?
I'd rather fight them.
Winter objected.
They'll thank your icicle and lock you
up.
Kinkaju's voice said from the air.
Unless they kill you first, Kibley said
which I realize I should be more
enthusiastic about, but for some reason
I'm not.
Come on.
He tugged on one of winter's wings, then
dove under the tree himself, rolling into
a ball in the shadows.
Winter reluctantly followed, crouching
until his underbelly was sliding across
the wet leaves.
Dangling curls of damp moss caught on his
horns, and something scuttled down his
spine as he wedged himself in next to
Kibley's warm scales.
Oh, why are you so glittery?
Kinkaju fretted from outside the hiding
hole.
Nothing natural is that color.
It's all right, Moon whispered back.
Just try to cover us and stay as still as
you can.
I'll have you know, I was a hide and seek
champion.
Kinkaju started.
No one, shh, Moon said, and a moment
later, Winter was startled to feel her
sliding in beside him.
The silver scales by her eyes caught the
light for a moment as she turned her head
listening.
He could feel the whole length of her
body breathing softly, anxiously.
That's better, Kinkaju whispered.
I can't see him anymore.
Winter covered the Skyfire pouch with one
of his talons and tried to breathe.
Maybe this was what Moon had meant when
she said reading his mind was confusing.
He couldn't even tell what he was
feeling.
Furious, trapped, frustrated, grateful
safe, alone, protected, on fire.
Wanting the wrong things, hating himself
confused, confused, confused.
His mind flashed back to the 1st time
he'd done a ranking test out in a storm
with hailstorm and icicle.
They'd lost him as soon as they could
each striking out on their own.
It made sense, even to a one year old
dragonette struggling through a
blizzard.
Nobody wanted to risk letting someone
else drag down their ranking number.
So what were these dragons doing?
Why were they risking the wrath of their
queens by helping him?
Moon's scales rippled as she shifted
quietly.
Was that her heartbeat he could feel?
Thundering in the places where their
wings were pressed together?
Or was that his own?
He closed his eyes and tried to stop
thinking.
A few eternities passed, and then finally
moon whispered, They're gone.
Then get out of the way and let me out
Winter said, in a strangled voice that
came out more harshly than he'd meant it
to.
She rolled instantly away, and he
wriggled after her until he stood
blinking in the green rainforest light
again.
Kimley emerged, stretching out his wings
and shaking his tail.
Careful with that thing, Winter snapped
glaring in the poisonous barb as it swung
back and forth.
If you ever get stabbed by my tail, I
promise it won't be by accident.
Kibley said haughtily.
Moon, wait up.
She was already moving away, toward the
sound of a waterfall in the distance, and
the sand wing hurried after her.
I could leave now.
Winter thought, feeling as though his
talons were paralyzed with indecision.
I should leave now.
That would be the smart ice wing thing to
do.
The words you're looking for are, thank
you, Kinkachu said, materializing
suddenly beside him.
Winter jumped.
Thank you, Moon, for warning me and
hiding me and helping me, even though I
am an enormous super jerk sometimes.
She flounced off into the trees.
Her orange scales fading back into the
green of the leaves.
Winter hesitated, and then followed her.
They're still useful to me, he thought.
I have a better chance of finding icicle
if I stay with them.
But just for now.
Soon, he promised himself.
I'll leave soon.
Chapter 7.
When winter caught up to the others, they
were gathered at the base of a huge tree
beside a waterfall, staring up at a hole
in the trunk, there was something
immediately and indefinably uncomfortable
about this place.
It was like a spot of thin ice on a
frozen lake, where the cool safety of the
upper world came too close to the dark
depths below.
That's the tunnel to the night wing
island.
Kinkaju said softly.
Her voice was never that quiet or
wobbly.
Winter squinted at her.
Was she afraid of the place for some
reason?
You can wait here if you want.
Moon said, brushing Kinkaju's tail with
her own.
If it's too... to anything.
I'm all right, Kingaju said.
She flared the rough behind her ears, and
deliberately turned her scales dark
blue.
I just haven't been back since the whole
thing.
Whoa, Kibley said, making the connection
before winter did.
I didn't realize you were.
You're one of the rain wings they...
Imprisoned and experimented on.
Moon finished for him.
It wasn't quite as horrible as it sounds
Kinkachu said.
Only, mostly that horrible.
Winter had to take a deep breath, and
poke the feeling he was having to be sure
he was having it.
Respect for Kinkaju?
Surprised that a dragon as silly as her
could have survived what the night wings
did to the rain wings.
He'd heard only rumors, really. stories
that had spread after the war ended.
Tales of night wings abducting harmless
rain wings, dragging them back to the
volcanic island, chaining them up, and
forcing them to use their venom so the
night wings could study it.
It sounded unforgivable to him.
But Kinkachu did not act like a dragon
with a grudge.
She didn't seem to hate the night wings
at all, even though she clearly should.
Yet she treated Moon like a best friend.
Because moon is different, whispered his
treacherous mind, because she would never
do what the other night wings did.
But you don't hate them, Kibley said
echoing Winter's thoughts.
That's fascinating.
Well, they're not my favorite dragons
Kinkaju admitted, squirming, except Moon
of course, and Deathbringer is usually
pretty great.
But, you know, they're trying to change.
They have to.
And with glory as their queen, they won't
do any more awful things.
We'll see, Winter muttered.
Moon flew up to the hole and stepped
inside, then twisted to look back at
them.
Winter, come look at this.
Just inside the mouth of the tunnel was a
squashed wet leaf, shaped a bit like a
scavenger's paw.
When winter crouched to sniff it, it felt
colder than the tunnel around them.
Did she go this way?
He asked Moon.
I don't know.
She said.
I still can't hear her, but maybe that's
why.
If she's at the volcano.
Winter started down the tunnel, walking
straight into that unsettling, wrong
feeling air.
He heard the shuffling wings of the
others falling in behind him.
Heat crackled along his scales as he
glimpsed the end of the tunnel, and he
paused.
This was worse than the damp rainforest
heat.
This was the kind of heat, where he
wouldn't be able to use his frost
breath.
And there was something blurring his
sight.
Bits of ash, maybe, drifting through the
air.
He took a deep breath and stepped out
into a cave.
His talons sinking instantly into a layer
of ash that covered the floor.
It was dark, and nearly impossible to see
but a faint gray light scraped the walls
on either side of him.
Winter took a step forward as Moon
emerged behind him and breathed out a
small plume of fire.
Sharp claws seized winter's heart.
The shape of a huge dragon loomed
overhead, its wings outstretched, its
talons reaching toward him.
He's dead, Moon said quickly, whoever he
is, he's gone.
This is just the shape of him left
behind.
She edged forward and tapped one of the
grasping talons.
The dragon didn't move.
I wonder who it was.
Winter's breath slowly returned.
He carefully made his way around the
petrified dragon, trying not to touch the
statue of hardened ash.
There was a tunnel he could just squeeze
into, although it was clogged with ash
and the floor was a field of cooled lava
that was still too hot for winter's
liking.
It was a relief when he reached open air
and was able to spread his wings and
fly.
This, then, at last, was the secret home
of the night wings.
He circled, studying everything below him
and felt his triumph dimming.
The island was smaller than winter could
have imagined.
It made him feel instantly claustrophobic
even with, or perhaps because of, the
vast ocean lurking in all directions
dense black ripples of lava flows covered
everything he could see, still glowing
orange and yellow in places, where liquid
fire was spilling through the cracks.
A mountain cut jaggedly into the sky, the
volcano itself, but it looked as if the
top had been smashed in, leaving a
smoking hole.
Had the air been this impossible to
breathe before the volcano erupted?
Thick gray clouds, heavy with ash and
smoke, and sizzling with lightning
stretched across the sky.
Everything smelled of sulfur and fire, and
death.
Winter couldn't imagine anyone actually
living here.
What did the night wings eat in a place
so empty of life?
How could they sleep?
With a promise of fiery death smoking and
muttering over their heads all the time?
Who would raise their dragonettes in such
a hideous place?
It felt like a whale smacking him in the
face.
How suddenly and completely, he
understood Moon's mother, and her
decision to hide Moon in the rainforest.
The stranger question was why other night
wings hadn't done the same.
Afraid to disobey their queen, probably.
He guessed.
Ice Wings followed Queen Glacier's orders
with unquestioning obedience as they were
handed down through the levels of the
aristocracy.
It was like obeying your parents.
No one would ever think to do otherwise.
But Ice Wings had the entire Ice
Kingdom.
The safest and most purely beautiful
place to live in all of Pyria.
It was the polar opposite of this
nightmare.
Queen Glacier took care of them.
The night wing queen could not have cared
about her subjects at all if she kept
them rotting in a place like this.
Oh, Kinkachu gasped, soaring up beside
him with Moon and Kibley.
Look, they're fortress.
It's totally destroyed.
She pointed to the smoking volcano.
Winter hadn't even noticed the outline of
walls poking through the lava, but now
that he looked, he could see the clear
shape of the wrecked structure.
One of the towers looked eerily like his
own flight training tower in Glaciers
Palace.
I had no idea, Moon said.
I mean, I've seen the island in their
heads, but I never felt this.
Mother never said, It's so horrible.
Holy smoking vipers, Kibley said.
The sand wing swooped down toward a river
of molten lava, and then back up to
winter.
If I ever had nightmares, they'd be about
this place from now on.
I think this might take care of my
nightmares.
Kinkaju said.
Imagine having your home devastated like
this.
Poor night wings.
Poor night wings. winter exploded.
He would not.
Would not feel sorry for night wings.
Are you serious?
What is wrong with you?
Don't you remember what they were doing
to your tribe?
To you?
How they planned to steal the rainforest
and probably kill you all?
Kinkaju flinched away from him, covering
her eyes.
I know, she said in a small voice.
But isn't it still sad?
They deserve this.
Winter spat.
After everything they've done.
The night wings deserve to lose their
home like this.
How can you say that?
Moon asked.
How could any tribe deserve this?
Seriously, Kibley said.
What did they do to the ice wings to make
you hate them so much?
Winter twisted away from them, flying
toward the volcano.
His training had never covered this.
He'd grown up knowing the old stories
about night wings, and he'd always
assumed everybody else did too.
They were a part of his bones, and the
bones of every ice wing.
We hate night wings.
They stole from us.
They're all liars and backstabbers and
monsters.
Was it a secret?
The story what they'd done to the ice
wings so long ago?
Or did other tribes not know about it
because they didn't particularly care?
Or because the night wings had covered it
up over the years, layering their own
lies on top of the truth?
That was certainly something they were
particularly good at.
A blast of sulfurous smoke came from one
of the vents below, and he dodged around
it, coughing.
He'd always imagined the night wings
lounging around their secret home in
perfect security, feasting and laughing
and reveling in their superiority.
He'd imagine them living among marvels
perhaps deep underground somewhere, smugly
enjoying what they'd stolen from the ice
wings.
Not this.
Not anything like this Hellscape.
He banked to the left, searching the
ground for any sign of icicle.
Winter?
He turned and found Moon following him.
Please tell me, she said.
I really don't know what the Night Wings
did, and I think, I think I need to.
She flicked her tail anxiously.
Does it have something to do with dark
stalker?
It does.
Winter said.
Watching Kibley and Kinkaju flying over
to join them.
Well, if it was a secret, someone should
have told him to keep it that way.
The truth was, it was better for everyone
to know, so they'd understand never to
trust the night wings.
But it begins with his thrice cursed
mother, Foeslayer.
She approached the ice wings under the
guise of peace, to offer us an alliance
against the sky wings, and instead, she
abducted our prints.
What for?
Kibley asked.
You know, all the ice wing princes I've
met have been kind of grouchy.
Why would someone want one around enough
to steal him?
Winter glared at him.
Because Prince Arctic was our last
animus.
They all gazed back blankly, as though
they'd completely missed the thunderbolt
he'd just thrown at their feet.
Our last animus, he growled.
Don't you know anything?
Not every tribe has animus dragons.
Ice Wings haven't had any in centuries.
And you know why?
Because the Nightwing stole that power
from us.
That's crazy.
Kibli protested.
You can't steal a power like that.
You can if it's genetic, Winter said.
The Night Wings never had an animus
dragon until they took Prince Arctic.
Now they have them, and we don't.
He took off, flying in a wide circle
around the volcano as he eyed the lava
strewn slopes.
He kept hoping to see a flash of white
scales, but the only colors on this
island were black and red and gold and
gray.
Wait, Moon said, catching up to him.
What are you saying?
That faux slayer, and Prince Arctic.
They had eggs together?
A night wing and an ice wing?
Sounds twisted, doesn't it?
Winter hissed, ignoring the stab of guilt
he felt at the thought.
Especially when you realize that Arctic
would never have agreed to it, would
never have betrayed the royal family that
way, unless Foe Slayer threatened him
with something terrible.
But whatever she did, it worked.
Moon's wings missed a beat, and she
nearly fell out of the sky.
Winter, she cried.
Are you saying Dark Stalker's father was
an ice wing?
Not just any ice wing?
Winter snarled.
Prince Arctic, the very last animus ever
hatched in the ice wing tribe, father of
the dark stalker, the 1st night wing
animus.
They planned it that way.
That's complicated and devious.
Kibley said.
Congratulations.
You've just summed up Nightwings, Winter
said to him.
They couldn't Arctic go home after that?
Kinkaju asked.
I mean, once they had his eggs, couldn't
the Nightwings let him go?
Why didn't he go back to the ice wings
and have more eggs there?
Winter saw moon falter again, and
realized that somehow she knew the
answer.
Because Dark Stalker killed him, Winter
said.
His own son murdered him to make sure the
ice wings never got their stolen power
back.
That's not?
Moon cried, and then checked herself.
I mean, that's not the reason I heard.
Well, it's the truth, Winter said.
The volcano rumbled threateningly, and
spat a small shower of sparks into the
air.
They were flying over the far side of the
island now, and there was still no sign
of icicle.
But, Kibley said cautiously.
Is it that big a deal?
I mean, I hear animus dragons are more
trouble than they're worth.
Don't they go crazy after a while?
That's true, Moon said.
I read about a sea wing animus who
murdered almost his entire family.
But we knew how to handle them.
Winter scoffed.
We perfected the use of anima's power.
Ice Wings were the 1st tribe to figure
out that too much use can damage the
dragon's soul.
So we were very careful with our animus
dragons.
We bred them into the royal line, watched
each potential animus from hatching, and
trained them carefully so they would
understand their limits.
Each ice wing animus spent years planning
his or her one great enchantment.
They could use their power just once, to
create something that would benefit the
whole tribe.
Prince Arctic was only days away from his
gifting ceremony when the Nightwings
kidnapped him.
Wait, Kibley said.
What happened if an animist didn't do
what he was told?
What if he wanted to use his power for
something else?
Or what if he didn't want to marry
whatever princess was chosen for him?
I don't understand the question, Winter
said.
It is obviously an honor to marry into
the Royal Ice Wing lineage.
But if you take away all of a dragon's
choices, Kibley trailed off, stop being
obtuse.
Winter shouted.
You are missing the point entirely.
Prince Arctic was our animus heritage, and
everything would be different if the
night wings hadn't stolen and killed
him.
I'm just wondering if there's another
side of the story.
Kibley suggested, shrugging his wings.
No, Winter said, there isn't.
What I'm wondering is why you're still so
mad about it.
Kinkaju interjected.
It sounds like it happened 100s and 100s
of years ago.
Isn't it time to move on?
Who cares about all that ancient
history?
It's not ancient history to us.
Winter growled.
We still live with a consequences every
day.
But you can't blame the night wings who
are alive now.
It wasn't their idea, she argued.
And it's not like you can get your
vengeance on Foe Slayer or Dark Stalker.
Moon dropped suddenly down toward the
fortress, startled and irritated.
Winter had to wheel around in midair to
follow her.
When they caught up.
She was sitting in the mouth of a half
caved in tunnel, peering into the
darkness.
I don't think this is right, she said, as
they all landed next to her.
This isn't the lost city of night and the
prophecy.
It isn't?
Kingaju said.
Why not?
There was a city before this one, Moon
said.
The Nightwings used to live somewhere on
the continent, back in Darkstalker's time
but they fled their city after he was
once he was gone, and they came here, to
hide from him in case he ever came back.
She cast an odd, worried look at winter.
I think that's the city we need to find
the ancient one, the one that's really
lost.
Oh, Kinkaju said.
You couldn't have maybe mentioned that a
bit sooner?
Sorry, Moon said.
I was hoping this would work.
So we don't have to go look for a dream
visitor in there?
Kibley said, nodding toward the tunnel
because I am all in favor of not going
into the creepy smoking lava filled
tunnel.
Me too, Moon agreed.
Except that I thought I heard.
Maybe.
Icicle?
Winter demanded.
You think she's in there?
I'm not sure, Moon said.
But at almost the same time, they all
heard a strange scrape sound from deep
inside the volcano.
Oh, dear, Kingaju whispered.
Now I'm really wishing we had saved the
ancient evil dragon stories for somewhere
less spooky.
Scray.
Scrape.
Winter was sure, a moment before Moon
turned to him with wide eyes.
He saw the glint of silver pale scales
shimmering toward him, as a figure
crawled slowly out of the dark tunnel.
It was icicle.
They'd found her at last.
Chapter 8.
She's not all right, Moon whispered to
him.
Her mind is all scattered and foggy.
I don't know why.
A talon of ice trailed down winter's
spine as he watched his sister stagger
into the gray light.
Her arctic blue eyes were bloodshot
crackled with dark blue veins, and the
scratches she'd gotten in the fight at
Jade Mountain still hadn't healed.
She was streaked with mud and blood, not
just her own dark blue blood, but
splatters of dark red that must have come
from the night wing she'd killed.
Icicle scales had always been wider than
everyone else's, her claws sharper, her
teeth gleaming, and her spikes pristine
even after clubbing a walrus to death.
She plunged into the frigid ocean 6 times
a day, because she believed an ice wing
who glittered like diamonds was a more
menacing ice wing.
In icicles view of the world, grubby, dull
dragons deserve to be 7th circle.
Winter could never have imagined her
looking this wretched.
She clutched the edge of the tunnel with
her front talons, leaning against the
rocky wall and glaring at him.
Icicle?
he said.
Are you?
Why are you here?
she spat, to ruin yet another of my
plans?
You don't feel satisfied that you've
already guaranteed Hailstorm's death?
What's wrong with you?
Kinkachu blurted.
You look terrible.
Could be worse, Icicle snarled.
I could look like you.
I want to help you find Hillstorm, Winter
said.
If he's really still alive.
I don't need your help of all dragons.
Icicles said with a hiss, limping forward
a step.
You don't have the claws to do what needs
to be done.
She touched her head, wiping away a
trickle of blood from one of her horns.
And she's probably killed him by now
anyway.
What did Scarlet say?
Winter asked.
He spread his wings, blocking her path.
When she found out Starflight and the
others were still alive.
I haven't spoken to her.
Icicle swayed a little on her feet.
I can't, I don't want to see her.
To admit, I failed your fault.
But what if she kills him in front of
me?
Or what if he's already dead?
And she shows me his body.
She took another staggering step and
Winter reached out to catch her, but she
recoiled, snapping her teeth at him.
But how have you?
He started.
She hasn't slept.
Moon said wonderingly.
Not since Jade Mountain.
If I don't sleep, Icicle muttered
triumphantly, then she can't get to me.
She can't visit my dreams if I don't have
any.
Ha ha.
But it's been days.
Kingaju cried.
You haven't slept in days?
Don't you feel awful?
I don't need to sleep, Isaacle said.
Whenever I get tired, I lie down beside
the lava until the pain wakes me up.
She spread her wings, and winter saw with
a shudder, that she had blisters and
small burns bubbling in spots across her
scales.
This, he could imagine too easily.
His fearless, stubborn sister angrily
burning herself, slashing pain across the
body that betrayed her by daring to be
tired.
And he understood what she was going
through too.
He'd lived with the guilt of losing
hailstorm for the last 2 years.
Icicle.
We need to know if she's killed him.
He said.
I'd wager a few camels that she hasn't
said Kibley.
He's more used to her as a bargaining
chip than as a corpse.
Not very useful, corpses as a rule.
All right, shutting up now.
He added, catching the look moon was
shooting him.
Do you have any idea where she is?
Winter asked Icicle.
If we can get to her and find him.
If it were that easy, I'd have done it.
Icicle snapped.
I've considered all the options. trust
me.
There's only one way to save him, and
that's killing the rain wing queen.
I'm not going to let you kill Queen
Glory.
Kinkaju said stoutly.
Icicle barked a ragged laugh.
And how are you going to stop me?
You preposterous pink dragon.
Kinkachu lunged at icicle. flying past
winter in a red and orange blur before he
realized what was happening.
The little rain wing knocked icicle over
onto her back and wrapped her talons
around the ice wing's throat.
Nobody threatens my queen.
Kinkachu shouted.
Hey, Winter shouted.
Get off me!
Icicle raged.
She swung her tail at Kinkaju's wings, but
missed.
Her vicious claws went up.
The serrated edges glittering dangerously
ready for a killing blow at Kinkaju's
underbelly.
Kinkajou!
Moon cried, jumping toward them.
But before she could reach them, before
icicle could strike, before winter could
do anything, something small came
whistling through the air, and thunked
into icicle's neck.
Icicle let out a gasp and jerked back.
Kinkachu jumped off of her with a yelp
and looked up at the sky.
Winter followed her gaze to the clouds
and then watched as the gray melted and
shifted, like dragonettes bursting out of
the snow, into 9 dragons in shades of red
and gold and green.
Icicle of the ice wings, Queen Glory
announced, you are under arrest for
murder and attempted murder.
No!
Icicle roared, clawing at her neck.
She rolled over and shoved herself
upright, but her legs wobbled, and her
head was starting to droop.
What have you done to me?
What is happening?
It's only a tranquilizer dot, said
Deathbringer, winging down to land beside
them.
We find it makes transporting prisoners
much simpler.
You'll wake up just fine in a few hours.
No, Icicle shrieked.
I can't sleep.
Don't make me sleep.
She hurled herself at winter, dug her
claws into his shoulders, and shook him
with all of her fading strength.
Winter, stop them.
Help me.
Tell them I can't.
She'll find me.
She'll tell me he's dead, and then it'll
be over, and he'll be gone.
Winter.
Keep me awake.
It's too late, Deathbringer said. studying
her with a puzzled expression.
It's not that bad.
The dot sleep.
Isicle slowly collapsed forward onto
winter, her talons clenching open and
closed, as if she was trying to claw
herself back to waking.
She'll come for me, Icicle whispered.
So let her come, Winter said.
He crouched as his sister's weight
pressed him down, bringing his mouth
close to her ear.
Go ahead and sleep icicle.
You can stay awake forever anyway.
Talk to Scarlet, and tell her she can
still get what she wants.
But she can't.
Icicle's voice was barely a mumble now.
I'll be... prison.
Winter glanced up at the faces around
them.
Nobody could hear what he and Icicle were
whispering to each other, not unless they
could read minds.
Well, this was one way to find out if the
Skyfire really worked.
He leaned closer to icicle, close enough
for the Skyfire pouch to touch her scales
as well as his own.
And then, as his sister's eyes closed, he
whispered, Tell Scarlet, if she can prove
that Hellstorm is still alive.
I'll kill glory for her myself.
Chapter 9.
The healer's pavilion near the rain wing
village was large, quiet, and sunlit, with
curtains of green vines shielding the
interior from curious onlookers, and
there were plenty of curious dragons, ones
winter could see, and ones he could only
hear. murmuring and twittering, like a
council of invisible birds in the trees.
The rainforest was starting to give him
the suffocating, spine crawling feeling
that he was always being watched.
Only rain wings were allowed to carry the
unconscious prisoner.
Glory ordered all the night wings to stay
away and sent Deathbringer to make sure
none of them came looking for her.
She also didn't object when Winter pushed
his way into the pavilion and stood next
to his sister, glowering around
defiantly.
I'm staying right here, he said.
Understood, Glory said with a nod.
She turned to survey the others as they
edged through the curtain and stood back
against the wall, out of the way.
Your majesty?
How did you find us?
Moon asked hesitantly.
Glory glanced at Kinkaju, her scales
shifting to starbursts of royal purple
against deep blue.
I left her a trail to follow.
Kingaju admitted, looking guilty.
Sorry, Moon, but she's our queen.
I wanted her there in case we really did
find icicle.
Moon nodded thoughtfully, looking back at
the sleeping ice wing.
I guess it's lucky you did, she said.
Winter wanted to disagree, but he
remembered the desperate rage on icicle's
face.
She had been seconds away from killing
Kinkaju, and even though Kinkaju was just
a rain wing, he had to admit, only to
himself that he didn't want her dead.
Besides, whatever she has planned for my
sister now.
Queen Glory would have been much less
merciful if Icicle had killed her
friend.
So it was lucky for Icicle 2. that glory
had found them right then.
A pair of sky blue rain wings was moving
quietly around icicle, cleaning her
wounds, another one, pale pink, stood by
her head with a blowgun and darts at the
ready, in case she woke up.
Icicle's chest rose and fell in long
peaceful movements, and her face was as
still as winter had ever seen it.
The tortured expression was gone, for
now.
He hoped she would get a few hours of
real rest before Scarlet came hunting
through her dreams.
It's odd.
One of the rain wing healers murmured to
the other, look how much this scratch has
bled, Bullfrog.
She wasn't letting herself sleep, Kinkachu
told them.
She hasn't slept in 4 or 5 days.
The healers both made alarmed clicking
noises with their tongues and bent over
icicle again, inspecting her more
closely.
Why would any dragon do that to herself?
said the one named Bullfrog.
It's worse than refusing to eat.
Another day of it, and she'd probably be
dead.
At least she'll be able to heal now that
she has to sleep.
Going even 12 hours without sleep is one
of my nightmares, said the other.
Remember that rain wing a few years ago
who couldn't sleep?
That was the saddest case I ever saw.
Bullfrog shook his head, and his tail
turned a glum shade of gray.
A rain wing who can't sleep?
Glory echoed.
Isn't that kind of like a sea wing who
can't swim?
It was worse than that, said the pink
dragon.
He couldn't change his scales either.
Because he couldn't sleep, said Bullfrog
we figured out he had a snout deformity
that kept him from sleeping for more than
an hour at a time, but there was no way
to fix it.
It was awful.
He was awful, said the pink dragon.
Sometimes I would wake up for my suntime
nap, and he'd just be standing there
staring at me.
And he couldn't camouflage himself, and
you could never tell what he was feeling
by looking at scales. said the other
healer, shuddering from talons to tail.
It's like he wasn't even a rain wing at
all, said Bullfrog.
He was a lot grumpier than a real rain
wing too.
So, what color was he?
If he couldn't change?
Kibley asked curiously.
Kind of an ordinary lime green all over.
Bullfrog answered.
He held out one talon, and shifted the
scales along his arm to demonstrate, very
boring.
And unattractive, agreed the 2nd healer.
She gathered the damp leaves stained with
icicle's blood and bustled off.
That's our cautionary tale of what
happens when you don't sleep, said the
pink dragon.
Ahem your majesty.
I do sleep, Glory protested.
Maybe not as much as other rain wings, but
I've been doing suntime every day, no
matter how busy I am.
So quit your scolding jambu.
I'm just saying.
Jambu resettled his wings, looking
pleased with himself.
What are you planning to do with my
sister?
Winter asked glory.
I can take her back to the Ice Kingdom.
I promise, Queen Glacier will see that
she's punished.
Glory circled Isicle's bed, studying the
sleeping dragon.
She's too dangerous, said the queen with
a flick of her tail.
She killed one of my subjects.
On the way to killing you.
Kinkaju interrupted to point out.
Glory waved this away with one talon.
I can't let her just fly out of here.
She said to Winter.
I need to be a true queen to the night
wings, and that means letting them see
justice.
But I also don't want to start a war with
the ice wings, and I believe a queen
should have a say in what happens to her
subjects.
So I'll send for Queen Glacier, and
together, we can decide what happens to
Icicle.
That was more fair than winter could have
hoped for.
And yet, it made his stomach twist in a
painful, anxious way to think of his
queen coming here to judge him and his
sister.
The rankings.
He thought.
And what will mother and father think?
I need to find Hillstorm before she
arrives, he thought, if I can free him
Queen Glacier will understand why Icicle
did what she did.
In the meanwhile, Glory sighed.
We'll have to keep her tranquilized, so
she doesn't try to escape or hurt someone
else.
Wait, what?
Winter rose to his feet, and got his
wings caught in a woven leaf hammock that
was hanging from the ceiling.
He wrestled it off with a growl of
frustration.
I need to talk to her.
And I need a decent prison, Glory said
snapping her tail back and forth.
The rain wings don't have anything.
Where am I supposed to put misbehaving
dragons?
She turned to an older rain wing who was
sitting in the corner, watching with
stately composure.
Has no rain wing and history ever
required punishing?
We don't imprison.
We banish, said the older dragon with an
elegant shrug.
What could be worse than being thrown out
of the rainforest?
You see what I'm dealing with?
Glory said to Winter.
I have one prisoner right now. a night
wing, and we basically had to stick him
in a quicksand pit.
Every few hours, his guards haul him out
just enough so he doesn't die, and then
he starts sinking again.
Yuck, said Kinkachu.
But he deserves it, actually.
And there are 2 others I should deal
with.
But Queen Thorn has agreed to keep them
in her sand wing prison instead, until I
decide what to do with them.
Glory Sloth poked its head out from
behind the queen's shoulder and started
climbing slowly up her neck.
I'll figure out something else
eventually.
Glory said.
But I'm guessing Queen Glacier wouldn't
appreciate it.
If I stuck one of her dragons in
quicksand, so I'm afraid Icicle has to
stay asleep for now.
Your Majesty?
said a peach and plum colored dragon
poking her head through the curtain.
Deathbringer would like a word?
Excuse me, Glory said to Winter, with a
small bow.
The older dragon followed her out, leaving
Jambu on guard, and bullfrog still gently
cleaning icicles scales.
Winter inspected Icicles' face with
concern.
A small fro had appeared between her
eyes.
Was she speaking with Scarlet at that
very moment?
He watched her for a long minute, but she
didn't move, or speak, or give any other
sign of what her dreams were about.
Finally, he turned and stalked to the
wall where Moon and Kingaju were sitting
together, their tails entwined.
Kibli was pacing around the healer's
pavilion, poking his nose around curtains
to see the other patients, sniffing piles
of medicinal leaves, and scaring clouds
of small yellow butterflies out of the
rafters.
Now what am I supposed to do?
Winter hissed at him.
It was your bright idea to come here, but
I'm no closer to finding Hillstorm, and
it's my fault my sister's been caught by
a bunch of rain wings.
We are closer to finding hailstorm.
Kinkaju objected.
We've found the only dragon who's spoken
to Scarlet and knows the whole story.
And she's fast asleep, Winter said, which
does me any good how?
Kibbe stopped next to Moon, brushing her
wings with his.
Winter's claws twitched, and he clenched
his jaw.
The other rain wings weren't paying any
attention to them, but Kibley lowered his
voice anyway.
Didn't you say, you overheard icicle and
scarlet conspiring?
He asked Moon.
Does that mean you can get into dreams
too?
A shock like lightning ran through
Winter's veins.
Is that true?
he demanded.
Can you listen in when Scarlet finds
her?
I will try, Moon said, leaning a little
closer to Kinkaju.
I am trying.
It's all darkness in Icicle's mind right
now.
She's too deep in sleep for dreams.
Three moons.
Winter realized.
If Moon hears their conversation.
She'll know what I told icicle.
She'll probably have glory arrest me
too.
I'll have to be ready to fly the moment
she tells me what I need to know about
Scarlet.
So we wait.
Kinkachu said.
For Scarlet to come.
It seemed as if a long time passed.
As the shadows slowly lengthened, and
night came creeping into the pavilion
Winter arranged himself in the ice wing
guarding stance, but after a while, all
his training failed, and he fell asleep.
Moon jolted him awake by touching one of
her talons to his.
She's here, she whispered.
She's in icicles mind.
The pavilion was dimly lit by a few beams
of moonlight, and several jars hanging
from the ceiling that appeared to be full
of fireflies.
Kibli and Kinkachu slept peacefully
curled next to each other on the floor.
Winter blinked into the shadows, and saw
the bullfrog was still in the pavilion
asleep in a hammock next to a snoring
rain wing patient.
Jambu had been replaced by another rain
wing, who was watching icicle, her blow
gun at the ready.
He stepped quietly over to icicle's bed
and saw that his sister was sleeping very
differently now.
All her muscles were tensed, as if she
wanted to run, but couldn't, and her
claws were twitching violently.
Do you think she's about to wake up?
The rain wing guard asked Winter.
She just had another dart an hour ago, so
she shouldn't, but I've never seen anyone
fight sleep like that.
She looks like she's eaten some kind of
toxic burn.
I don't think she'll wake up, Winter
answered.
He meant it.
But he was still surprised when the rain
wing nodded and sat back.
Why would she trust the prisoner's
brother to tell her the truth?
Rain wings really had no sense at all.
Winter?
Moon whispered.
His name and her voice, like a spell that
ran warmth through his bones, he hurried
back over to her, I need paper, she said
grabbing one of his talons without
opening her eyes, and something to write
with, quickly.
Winter searched all the corners and boxes
and niches.
He even checked under all the beds.
He ransacked the entire pavilion and
didn't find a single scroll.
I'll be right back, he whispered to Moon
hurrying past her to the outer curtain.
She just nodded, her brow wrinkled with
pain.
He paused for a 2nd, watching her where
she crouched in the moonlight.
Did it hurt?
listening to other dragon's dreams?
Or was it particularly bad listening to
Scarlet and Icicle?
He pushed through the vine curtain and
stared out at a very dark rainforest.
In the ice kingdom, it was rare to find
this kind of darkness.
The gift of light had been passed along
to every inhabited part of the kingdom
and there were moon globes everywhere.
His home also had so much open space, and
the 3 moons always glittered on
everything.
The snow, the ice palace, the frozen
lakes, the glaciers.
He wished he had a moon globe.
He wasn't used to flying into pitch black
like this, especially when he couldn't
tell where any of their rain wings were.
He could hear some of them snoring amid
the nighttime rainforest cacophony, but
he couldn't actually see any other
dragons, even in the spots where
moonlight could reach.
He thought of hailstorm, trapped in some
kind of secret sky wing prison, probably
in complete darkness for the last 2
years.
Wait, a voice called softly behind him.
Kinkachu pushed through the curtain and
stood next to him.
You stay here, she said.
I'll get moons and paper.
I know where to go.
The new rain wing school is close by.
I should come with you, he said.
No thanks.
Kinkuchu nudged him out of her way.
You'd probably wake the whole village
thrashing and flailing around, stay and
make sure moon is all right.
She flashed away, vanishing quickly into
the dark, and he had to admit, more or
less soundlessly.
He wondered if rain wings had better
night vision than other tribes.
The tribes of fire would just use that
when they needed to light up the dark, he
guessed.
What about sea wings?
Could they see in the dark?
If he were still at school, he could
probably get someone to let him test that
theory by studying his fellow students.
But I'm not still at school.
And I'm not going back, and I shouldn't.
I mean, I don't care what other tribes
can do anyway.
He returned to Moon and found her in a
curtained off corner of the pavilion, next
to the only window with a view of the
starry night sky, a small blue frog with
darker blue speckles, was sitting on one
of her front talons, and they both seemed
to be listening to the chorus of frogs
and birds and insects, and whatever other
mysterious creatures were making all that
noise outside.
Winter paused beside his sister for a
moment.
Icicle looked as though she was slowly
relaxing back into real sleep.
Scarlet's gone, Moon said, as winter
approached.
Was it terrible?
Winter asked, is icicle all right?
What did Scarlet say about Hailstorm?
Moon gave him an odd, searching look.
Her teardrop scales caught the moonlight
on one side, and the firefly lamp on the
other, gleaming as though one was ice, and
the other was gold.
Winter realized.
This was the 1st time they'd been alone
together.
Apart from the sleeping dragons around
them, since he found out she could read
minds.
Or was it the 1st time they'd ever been
alone together?
He felt the weight of the skyfire rock
pouch around his ankle.
Scarlet says your brother is still
alive.
Moon turned her talon over, gently
sliding the frog onto the windowsill.
Icicle asked for proof, but Scarlet only
laughed at her.
I wish I could read Scarlet's mind, but
she's too far away, and it's not really
her in Icicle's dream, only a projection
of her.
So I can't tell what she's thinking, or
whether it's true about Hailstorm.
I'm sorry.
She gave him that quick confused look
again.
Icicle offered her a deal.
You don't have to, he started.
I'm not, she said, worried, I mean, I
know you won't kill Queen Glory.
Do you know that?
he asked.
How?
Because I think she's the kind of dragon
you respect, she said slowly.
And I think you wouldn't want to start a
war between the ice wings and both of her
tribes.
I think you can imagine what killing her
would do to Pyria, and you know it would
be bad.
Also, you're her guest.
She's welcomed and trusted you.
You aren't the kind of dragon who betrays
someone's trust.
Winter studied her profile as she wound a
vine between her claws.
That's a lot of thoughts, he said.
Weren't you paralyzingly shy at one
point?
What happened to that unobtrusive, quiet
dragon?
It turns out it's actually much easier to
talk to you when I can't hear what you're
thinking, Moon admitted, smiling.
He stared into her dark eyes for a long
moment.
But all of that about Queen Glory.
Are you sure you're not still reading my
mind?
He finally asked, quietly.
I don't have to, she said.
I've already been in there for one
thing.
I know you.
And I've watched you.
I saw you put out the fire in the history
cave.
I saw you save me and Starflight from
your own sister.
I think you can think bigger than just
one tribe against another.
You can think about what's best for all
the tribes.
I guess I just.
I trust you.
You seem very sure of certain things
about me, Winter said.
That I would never hurt a dragonette, that
I would never kill Queen Glory.
That I am somehow honorable and brave.
I am, said Moon.
I am sure of those things.
Even when everything else inside you is
confusion and mirrors and pain.
Those things are true.
He lifted the vine from her claws, and
wrapped it around his own talons, luring
his voice even more.
Sometimes, I'm only sure of one thing, he
said.
That I hope I never hurt you.
She gazed up at him in surprise.
Me?
But I thought you hated me.
Then you're not much of a mind reader, are
you?
He said with a half smile.
I mean, I should, but for some reason, I
can't.
He took another step closer.
Tilting his wings forward to brush hers.
Well, good, Moon said, looking at their
wings instead of his face.
I'm.
I'm glad you can't hate me.
Got it.
Kinkachu's voice said eagerly behind
them.
Moon, where are you?
Winter let out a breath he hadn't known
he was holding.
Here, Moon said.
She touched one talon lightly to Winter's
chest, then went past him and threw the
curtain.
Winter pressed his talons together, trying
to stop them from shaking, and then
followed her.
Kinkaju was in the center of the pavilion
under one of the firefly jars, spreading
a blank scroll on the floor.
She nudged an ink pot toward moon with
her tail.
What is this for?
Kinkachu asked.
I saw something, Moon said, crouching
beside her.
She took the long, thin reed that Kingaju
was holding and dipped it in the ink.
Behind Scarlet.
I got a glimpse of what was behind her
and I think it was a mountain.
It was kind of an unusual shape.
She started drawing.
Maybe we can find it.
Winter watched the lines appear under
Moon's claws, swooping and turning back
crisscrossing and diving like flights of
dragons in the sky.
This was a real clue, a clue that might
lead them to hailstorm.
It looked like a wall at first, tall and
sheer, with silvery waterfalls trailing
down it like dragon tails, along the top
of the wall was a ridge of sharp peaks
that looked like an ice wing spine
leading up to one peak that looped up and
back on itself, almost in the shape of an
eye.
Moon lifted the reed and studied the
picture.
That's close anyway.
She said.
Does it look familiar to either of you?
Winter shook his head.
I haven't spent much time in the Sky
Kingdom though, he said, assuming that is
the Sky Kingdom.
I've never been anywhere but the
rainforest, and Jade Mountain, Kinkachu
said with a helpless shrug, and the
Nightwing Island, of course.
Hey, Kibli, wake up and look at this.
The sand wing came instantly awake as
Kinkachu poked him, jumping to his feet
as if he was ready for a battle.
Moon held the sketch out to him and
explained where she'd seen it.
Kimble studied it for a while, then shook
his head.
Never seen it, he said, but someone must
have.
Great work, Moon.
Yeah, thanks.
Winter added hastily.
I didn't really do anything, she said
taking the drawing back.
It's only, I mean, I'm just...
Lucky.
Kingachu finished.
I wish I had a cool power like that.
Lucky?
Moon said wonderingly.
Above her head, 3 fireflies escaped their
jar and darted off in a flicker of
surprised sparks.
Well, it's no use asking any rain wings
where this is, Kinkachu said, flicking
her tail at the sketch.
None of us leave the rainforest if we can
help it, because it is awesome and
perfect here, she added, with a stern
look at winter.
Let's try Death Bringer, Moon suggested.
He's been all over the continent.
Kibli shot a sideways look at winter.
Is that all right?
He asked.
He's not exactly your favorite dragon.
Oh, survive, Winter said.
If you can help me find Hailstorm, that's
what matters.
It was hard to focus on hating the night
wings now that there was real hope in
front of him, a chance of finding
hailstorm before Scarlett killed him, if
he'd bought enough time with his lie
about killing glory for her, if he moved
fast.
If Moon had truly seen where Scarlet was
and if Hailstorm was there too.
If, if, if.
If I can make this happen, I might really
see my brother again after all.
Part two.
In the claws of the clouds.
Chapter 10.
Deathbringer didn't recognize the
mountains moon had drawn, but he knew who
might.
The talons of peace, he said.
He breathed out another small flame to
study the drawing.
Find them, or what's left of them, and
ask one of their sky wings to help you.
They'd found him on guard outside the
royal tree house where glory slept.
The darkness was not as thick up here
close to the treetops, where more
moonlight could filter through the
leaves.
The small glowing lights of
phosphorescent insects trailed up and
down the branches, and winter spotted a
few eerie glow in the dark moths, nestled
in the pale night orchids.
All right, then, said Kibley.
We'll go ahead and track down a shadowy
underground group who move every few
weeks and weren't caught for the entire
war.
Easy.
Deathbringer swatted at him. and Kibley
jumped out of the way with a grin.
They're not all that shadowy now
Deathbringer said.
And nobody said you were coming, Winter
said to Kibley.
I don't know what this we business is all
about.
Ignore him, Kibley said to Deathbringer.
We're growing on him.
I'm pretty sure.
Why did the talons of peace even still
exist?
Now that the war is over.
Many of them aren't welcome back in their
tribes, so they have nowhere else to go.
Deathbringer said.
Their goals are shifting though.
I know the dragon has taken over the
group.
I can help you find them.
If glory doesn't mind you leaving.
Oh, how nice of you to check.
Glory said, materializing suddenly out of
the darkness.
Winter jumped, wondering how long the
rain wing queen had been there, and why
she was camouflaged, because she was
following him, or because she was spying
on Deathbringer.
As it happens, Queen Glory went on, I
don't mind what Kibli and Prince Winter
choose to do.
I'm not their queen.
But I do have a few reservations about
allowing 2 of my favorite subjects to
gallivant around the continent, chasing
Paria's most dangerous dragon.
Did you hear that?
Kinkachu said, nudging Moon so vigorously
she nearly knocked her over.
Favorite.
The part you are supposed to hear is
dangerous, Glory said.
With blister and burn both dead.
Scarlet is probably the scariest dragon
left alive.
And she certainly hates us the most.
Explain to me how it is a good idea to
send a quartet of young dragonettes after
her.
No quartet necessary, Winter said.
Just the one, that's me.
Ice wing prints over here. going to save
my brother without the entourage.
Please order them to stay here.
It would make my life a lot simpler.
We are not going after Scarlet, Moon said
to Glory.
We're going to find Winter's brother.
We are doing no such thing, Winter said
firmly.
I am going to find him just me.
That's right, Kibley said, just him and
the 3 of us.
His best friends in the world.
I can't even dignify that with a snort
Winter said, looking down his nose at the
sand wing.
If we can figure out where she's got him
locked up.
Maybe we can set hailstorm free without
Scarlet even seeing us, Moon said.
Besides, Kinkaju said.
We're not that much younger than you and
your friends were, when you set out to
save Paria from all the bad dragons.
We'll be careful, Moon said.
We promise.
Don't listen to them, Winter said.
I don't want them to come with me.
In fact, if you could stick this sandwing
in some quicksand while I get away from
him, I will personally bring you a walrus
to express my gratitude.
Ew, said Kinkaju.
His very best friends.
Kibley said sincerely.
In the moonlight, it was hard to tell
what the colors were that were shifting
across glory's scales.
She curled her tail around the branch
underneath her and sighed deeply.
Death bringer.
I think you should let them go
Deathbringer said.
I went on my 1st mission when I was 4 and
I turned out fine.
Well, that's debatable, Glory said, and
if I wanted to go, you'd have an absolute
heart attack.
Yes, because you're the most important
queen Empira, said Deathbringer, and also
because I couldn't live without you.
Not that you care, torturing me with your
recklessness all the time.
That's true, Glory said.
You'd be an absolute mess.
The way you were before you met me.
I was only half a dragon before I met you
he declared, and I would be even less if
I lost you now.
All right.
Settle down, she said affectionately.
She turned to Kinkaju and Moon.
You may go, but here are my orders.
Do not interact with Scarlet.
Stay as far out of her way as you can.
Don't let her know you're there.
Don't fight with anyone.
Don't make any queens mad, and most
importantly, don't you dare die.
Understood?
The 2 dragons nodded, and Kinkachu
clapped her front talons together with
excitement.
Am I speaking a language only Ice Wings
understand?
Winter demanded?
Listen, Glory said, fixing her green eyed
gaze on winter.
I used to think I could do everything by
myself too.
I didn't want help from anyone.
But I wouldn't be here now if it weren't
for my friends.
And I have a feeling, you'll be saying
the same thing a year from now.
That might apply if these dragons were, my
friends, Winter objected.
But there are actually strangers who
happen to get thrown into a group with
me.
They're not even ice wings.
Why should they care what happens to
Hailstorm?
They care what happens to you, Glory
said.
For some reason, added Death Bringer.
Entertainment value, offered Kibley.
So, Glory said, shooting a quelling look
at the sand wing.
I strongly suggest you stop fighting and
take them along.
You might be surprised to find how useful
dragons from other tribes can be.
Winter growled softly.
He didn't want to give in.
He wanted to prove to his family that he
could save Hailstorm alone.
And he really didn't want to admit how
much he would rather have these dragons
with him when he faced Scarlet.
Moon's mind reading.
Kinkaju's camouflage, and Kibli's
aggravating intelligence, Yes, he could
imagine how they'd all be useful.
What was wrong with him?
Where was his ice wing pride?
But it would waste time if he tried to
keep arguing.
And saying yes meant a few more days with
Moon.
Which should have been a reason to say
no.
Very well, he said finally.
Tell me how to find the talons of peace.
The Winding Tail River began high in the
claws of the Clouds Mountains, and ran
down past Jade Mountain to the sea.
Near a bend in the river, north of the
rainforest, and west of Queen Morin's
Lake, there was a scavenger den that was
believed to be the biggest empirea.
Unlike most scavenger dens, this one was
not hidden away.
Instead, it was well fortified, with
stone walls, and defended fiercely by the
little creatures who lived in it.
I know some dragons who hunted there.
Deathbringer had said, but most of them
say it's not worth it.
You'll just end up getting jabbed with
sharp things, and pelt it with heavy
things.
There's much easier prey in the river and
mountains.
This was the new spot the talons of peace
had chosen for their signals.
Apparently, now that Jade Mountain was
being watched by too many dragon eyes.
This scavenger den was fairly high up
built on a cliff overlooking the forest
and any dragon flying over it would be
visible for miles in every direction.
Which wasn't Winter's favorite feeling, to
be honest, but that was how it worked.
The talent of peace were out there
somewhere, with someone watching the
skies in case of a signal like this, and
he needed to find them.
The 4 dragonettes reached the area
shortly after midday, landing on one of
the cliff tops below the scavenger den, a
brisk wind buffeted their wings, and
tossed hawks around far overhead with
piercing hunting cries.
The sun was brilliant yellow, white, in a
perfectly clear sky, much like the day
Hillstorm had been captured.
We could wait until night, Moon
suggested.
Then Kibley and I can fly up and signal
with fire, trails of flames in the night
sky.
Death Bringer said that would work.
They're not just watching for fire
breathing dragons, though.
Winter said.
I can take care of this part.
Don't worry.
He flung himself into the air before
anyone could argue with him.
The wind caught his wings, and lifted him
in a wheeling spiral, up and up and up
toward the blue dome overhead.
It was such a relief to be out of the
rainforest, and away from all the
clinging damp vines and weird, ripe fruit
smells.
Winter felt as though his wings were 6
times larger out here, with room to
stretch and soar.
He flew as high as he could, circled over
the other dragonettes, and then plummeted
swiftly down like a meteor slicing
through the sky.
He zoomed over their heads, banked upward
and caught a wind where he could float
like a leaf.
Now for the signal.
Winter angled his wings to catch the
sun.
He'd swum in the river and polished his
scales this morning, so they glittered
even more than usual, wintry blue and
white.
The sunlight reflected off him as he
tilted his wings, flashing like a mirror
to any watching dragons below.
He twisted slowly, making sure he could
be seen from any direction, although he
guessed the talent of peace were
somewhere in the long range of mountains
that split the land like jagged claws
pushing out of the ground.
He could see the twin peaks of Jade
Mountain far away to the south.
To the west, the pale rolling dunes of
the desert filled the horizon beyond the
mountain range, and below him, to the
east and north, where the swamps of the
mud kingdom.
Was hailstorm out there somewhere?
Did he know the war was over?
Did he know how Scarlet was using him
now?
Was he crouched in darkness, wishing
someone would come save him?
Winter shook those thoughts away.
Turning his attention to the scavenger
den.
It was cleverly chosen.
The scavengers had found a spot where a
huge overhanging ledge sheltered much of
their home from the sky, shielding them
in one direction from flying predators.
Cave entrances dotted the cliffside, and
odd little structures were carved out of
the rock, each probably large enough for
9 or 10 scavengers to curl up inside.
A wall of thick stones ran around the den
ending at the cliff on each side
barricading them in.
He could also see several patches of
greenery that looked almost like
gardens.
Could scavengers think far enough ahead
to plant gardens?
Next to the ledge, a waterfall cascaded
cheerfully down the cliff, right past the
den.
Some kind of wooden contraption was built
out into the spray, catching buckets full
of water, and spinning them back toward
the safety of the walls.
Winter hovered watching the scavengers.
Several of them were darting about
calling to each other in their squeaky
chirps.
They seemed very active, much more so
than bandit, almost like a pot of
dolphins, flurrying about after you
accidentally drop the remains of your
well carcass on them.
A few were peering over the wall at the
nearby cliffs.
He saw one point to the ledge where Moon
Kibley, and Kinkaju were sitting in the
sun together, resting their wings, black
and pale yellow, and iridescent blue
purple, green, side by side.
Are they worried about dragons so close
to their home?
Winter wondered.
That was cute.
Of course, this particular group of
dragons was possibly the least likely to
eat a scavenger of any dragons in Pyria.
But if they had wanted to, what would the
scavengers do about it?
The scavengers were rolling something up
to the wall now.
Something made of pieces of wood fitted
together, with ropes and metal bits as
well.
The sharp pointed end of it slid into a
slot in the wall and poked out the other
side.
Winters swooped lower, trying to figure
out what they were doing.
It didn't seem as if they'd noticed him
yet, in the sky above them.
A scavenger with long fur swooping off
its head like a tail climbed nimbly onto
the wall and leaned over, holding a torch
that flickered with fire at the end.
It lowered the torch to touch the end of
the contraption that was sticking through
the wall.
The flames caught and licked around the
point, and immediately the scavengers on
the other side of the wall started
bustling around, twisting the ropes and
pulling things and pointing the device.
At the dragons below.
It was a weapon.
These scavengers had some kind of fiery
projectile weapon, and they were about to
shoot it at Moon and the others.
Winter folded his wings and plummeted
toward the den as fast as gravity could
take him, there was a shout from one of
the scavengers.
Suddenly the weapon fired, and a spear as
long as a dragon came hurtling out of the
wall, dancing with flames and wickedly
sharp.
It plunged down, straight toward Kibley's
heart.
Look out!
Winter warred.
He wasn't close enough to reach it, but
he called up the cold from inside him, and
blasted a spray of frost breath at the
spear.
The fire went out instantly, as ice
crystals appeared all along the weapon.
The extra weight, and the force of his
breath, knocked the spear off course.
It crashed into the cliff underneath
Kibley's talons, and then dropped to the
earth far below instead.
Kinkaju shrieked, and Kibley leaped aside
spreading his wings to Shield Moon.
Winter wheeled over their heads and
landed beside them.
Time to move.
He barked.
The scavengers are shooting at us.
Kinkachu cried.
That's so mean.
We didn't even try to eat them or
anything.
But other dragons have.
Kibli pointed out.
The 4 of them swiftly arrowed into the
sky.
Far out of range of the scavengers
weapons.
Winter glanced back and saw the small
furry faces peering out to watch them fly
away.
Is it weird that I'm kind of impressed?
Moon asked.
I had no idea they could come up with
something like that.
I'm sticking with outraged, Kinkaju
said.
Hello, I'm a vegetarian.
There is so no need to shoot me of all
dragons.
I should go down there and roar at them.
Her scales were vibrantly alarmingly
orange.
Much brighter than any Sky Wings scales
could be.
Winter guessed that if the talons had
somehow missed his mirror signal, a
dragon this weirdly colored might still
catch their eye.
What in the world was it?
Kibley asked.
He soared in a tight circle, trying to
see down into the den.
How did it work?
How do they make it?
Could we make one?
I mean, not us, not right now, but maybe
one day for Thorn's palace.
I've never seen anything quite like it
Winter admitted.
Can you draw it for me?
Kibley asked.
Um, sure.
They found a place to wait for the talons
above the scavengers, out of their sight
this time, near the river that led to the
waterfall, Kingachoo and Moon went off to
find food, while Winter tried to sketch
the weapon in the sandy banks beside the
river.
But did this pull it back?
Kibli kept asking.
He poked the drawing, scattering sand
over winter's claws.
Did this part fit into here?
Wouldn't they need a piece like this?
I have no idea.
Winter finally erupted.
I was a little busy saving your scales.
That's true.
Kibley said, sitting back and giving him
a delighted smile.
You totally saved my scales.
I knew we were best friends.
Did I say thank you yet?
No, Winter grumbled.
Thank you.
Kibley said, entirely too sincerely for
winter.
Well, Winter said, I would have done the
same thing for anyone, you know.
I know, Kibley said.
I like that about you.
Winter saw, with surprise, that he meant
it.
Ghibli was as bad as a rain wing, flapping
his feelings all over the place all the
time.
You would get eaten alive in the Ice
Kingdom, Winter pointed out.
Kibli shrugged.
Maybe not.
I survived the Scorpion den, he said.
And my family.
They would not have saved me in this
situation, if you're curious.
More likely they'd have grabbed the spear
and stabbed me themselves.
Mine would have waited to see if I could
save myself, and then stood there shaking
their heads in grave disappointment when
I didn't.
Winter said.
Taking notes on all the things I did
wrong stood in the wrong place, allowed
Spear to penetrate scales, bleeding too
much, and so forth.
Kibling laughed.
They sound great.
They are, Winter said quickly.
That's how I swing parents are supposed
to be.
I'm very lucky.
Kibli gave him a strange look.
I guess they did something right.
He said after a moment.
I mean, for you to be so determined to
rescue your brother.
If I were in a sky wing prison, my
brother would definitely not come to
rescue me.
To be fair, I wouldn't go rescue him
either.
Pyrea would be much better off with him
locked up, where he can't hurt anyone.
A breeze sent ripples across the surface
of the river.
Winter stepped over his sketch and waded
into the water, rinsing the sand off his
claws.
Tiny golden and silver fish darted around
his talons.
The water was bracingly cold, like a
fleeting reminder of home.
I have a sinister older sister too, Kibli
offered.
Icicle's not older than me, Winter said.
We were in the same hatching.
And sinister is a bit of an
exaggeration.
Mm-hmm, Kibley said skeptically.
Winter sighed.
My parents will probably be so proud of
her.
Up until the part where she failed, which
they'll see is my fault, and then got
caught by rain wings, also my fault.
Going home is going to be excellent in
all the ways.
I can't wait.
It'll be all right, because you'll be
bringing hailstorm with you, Kibley said
confidently, so they'll have to forgive
you.
Will they?
Winter wondered.
Would they be proud of him if he
succeeded?
Or would they be too horrified by his
methods and his company?
His sharp ears caught a quiet splash
nearby.
Alertly, he spun in a circle and scanned
the river.
Suddenly, he spotted a dark shape
swarming through the water toward him
moving faster than a shark.
Before he could cry out, a dragon lunged
out of the water and straight for his
throat.
Chapter 11.
Winter let out a roar and swung his claws
in a ferocious arc.
The attacking dragon stopped himself at
the last moment, just out of range of
winter's talons, he yelped in surprise
and fell back with a splash.
Hey, the new dragon said indignantly
rude?
You could have taken my nose off.
And you'd deserve it for jumping at me
like that.
Winter snarled.
I was practicing my stealth approach, the
dragon grumbled, standing up and shaking
off his wet green wings.
He was a sea wing, a bit older than
winter, but much scrawnier.
I wouldn't have actually hurt you.
That's true, because I would have ripped
off your tail and beaten you with it
first, Winter said.
Nice, Kibley said from the shore.
Not the face this time.
Very creative.
Squid!
someone shouted above them.
Didn't you hear my orders?
A sky blue sea wing with dark blue horns
came soaring down from the clouds and
landed next to the 1st with a splash.
This dragon was bigger and frowning.
What?
Squid whined.
I very clearly said, nobody approached
the strangers, until I've had a chance to
speak to them, said the new Sea Wing.
What you're doing, the opposite of that.
I was being stealthy, Squid said, smacking
the water with his wings.
Dad said I should practice.
He thinks I'm really good at it.
He said maybe I'll be an amazing spy one
day.
The other sea wing looked as though he
had reached the farthest horizon of his
patience.
Squid.
Take your lurking and snooping and her
harassment somewhere else, right now.
Fine, fine, fine.
Squid floundered out of the water
flapping his wings and grumbling.
You know, my dad used to be the leader of
the talents of peace.
I don't know why he lets you boss him
around.
When he wanted to step aside, he could
have let me take over.
I mean, what was wrong with that plan?
He took off into the sky.
They could hear him muttering and whining
for a while as he flew away.
Winter and Kibley exchanged an amused
glance.
The blue sea wing took a deep breath and
exhaled slowly.
I apologize.
He said, let's pretend that never
happened.
My name is riptide.
I saw your signal.
Are you looking for the talons of peace?
Yes, Winter said.
Climbing out of the river onto the
grass.
Deathbringer said we should come to you.
We need a sky wing to help us with
something.
We don't have a lot of sky wings.
Riptide admitted.
Ruby pardoned almost everyone who'd had a
disagreement with her mother, so all the
fugitives who'd been hiding from Scarlet
went home, but we still have a couple who
don't feel safe going back.
I can ask one of them.
He let out an odd, high pitched whistle
and 2 more dragons emerged from the
trees.
One was a mud wing with a crooked tail
the other, Winter realized with a shock
was an ice wing.
Glittering silvery white, with pale
purple underscales.
But it was an ice wing he'd never seen
before.
And how was that possible?
Winter had an excellent memory for faces
and he thought he'd met every dragon in
the tribe at least once.
Please ask the sky wings to come here
Riptide said to the mud wing, who nodded
and flew away.
Who are you?
Winter asked the ice wing, who was
regarding him with cold, snake-like
eyes.
Siri, of the ice wings.
The strange dragon hissed, and you.
That was even stranger.
Every ice wing knew the royal family
surely.
I'm Prince Winter, he said slowly.
He realized he didn't know what his
current ranking was, which was a very
unsettling feeling now that he was facing
another ice wing.
Could he still say, 2nd circle, and hope
it was true?
But then, Cyrus hadn't offered his circle
number either.
Because he wouldn't have one.
Winter had to remind himself.
He'd have been thrown off the list when
he abandoned his post and joined the
talents.
Why don't I know you?
Sirius flicked his dark blue tongue
between his teeth.
It's a big tribe, he said.
Not really.
Winter eyed him from horns to tail.
Even without ranking circles.
Sirius still should have known to bow to
a prince, but it didn't seem like a good
fight to start.
Cyrus was quite a bit bigger than winter
and fiercely thin, with claws that looked
even sharper than normal ice wing claws.
Sirius has been with the talons of peace
for a long time, Riptide said, much
longer than I have.
He probably left the Ice Kingdom before
you were hatched.
That somewhat explained it.
Although Winter was still surprised he'd
never heard of Sirius.
He hadn't realized there were any ice
wings in the talons of peace.
What kind of ice wing would choose
banishment from the kingdom, to never
return to the snow and the ice palaces, to
give up your place and their rankings
forever?
Winter couldn't imagine it.
Did you know my parents?
he asked Cyrus.
Tundra and Narwhal?
Cyrus glanced up, tracking a rose colored
butterfly with a malevolent gaze, as
though he was considering eating it.
Perhaps, he said.
Long ago.
He had to know that Narwhal was the
queen's brother.
How could anyone have grown up as an ice
wing without learning the royal lineage?
Before winter could ask any more
questions, he heard snapping branches, and
turned to see Moon and Kinkaju
returning.
Kinkachu was carrying a small pile of
peaches and plums between her talons, and
a pair of rabbits dangled from moon's
jaws.
There with us.
Kibley said quickly, as riptide and
Sirius both bristled.
Really?
Riptide said.
Never thought I'd see a night wing and an
ice wing traveling together.
Or a rain wing outside the rainforest, for
that matter.
How did you all come together?
Winter glanced over at Sirius again, and
found him glaring at moon and Kikachu
with an expression of searing hatred, so
intense that Winter wanted to run across
the clearing and fling up his wings to
shield moon from it.
Siris had left the ice wings, but his
loathing of night wings, clearly still
ran deep.
We're from the Jade Mountain Academy.
Kibley said to Riptide, I'm Kibley, and
that's Moon and Kingaju.
Guys, this is ribtide and Sirius.
Sirius.
The Ice Wing snarled.
That's what I said.
Kibley smiled disarmingly, but winter
could tell by now when the sand wing was
deliberately trying to annoy someone.
Jade Mountain?
Ribtide echoed, his whole face lighting
up.
You must know tsunami.
How is she?
Did she send you?
Was there a message for me?
No, Winter said.
I mean, Deathbringer sent us.
Tsunami doesn't know we're here.
Oh.
Riptides wings drooped.
Moon took a nervous step toward him
opened her mouth, closed it, and then
blurted, but she thinks about you all the
time.
She made a face, as though she wasn't
sure she should have said that.
Really?
The sea wings, phosphorescent scales
flashed as he turned to look at her.
Yes, she, she wants to hear from you.
I'm not so sure about that, Ribtide
said.
I should probably wait until she contacts
me.
Oh, here's pyrite and avalanche.
There was a wrestling in the trees, and
then the mud wing was back, this time
with 2 sky wings following behind her.
The bigger Skywing had red scales.
Smoke rising from her ears, and a bad
tempered expression.
There was something about the way she
glared at them that made Winter's spine
prickle.
He followed her gaze and realized that
her hostility was directed at Kibley.
She almost looked as though she wanted to
rip the bar right off his tail.
Does she know him?
Or does she have a problem with sand
wings in general?
Well, if she does know him, that would
explain why she wants to kill him, ha
ha.
Winter let himself be amused for a second
but he also found himself hoping she
wouldn't be the one who helped them.
The 2nd sky wing was smaller, and her
wings twitched constantly, as if she
might take off at any moment.
Her scales were an interesting orange
color that was close to yellow, like the
inside of a peach, and her eyes were a
darker shade of orange, like the amber
earring Kibley wore.
Around her neck was a small brown pouch
on a gold chain, tight as a choker, and
she also had a gold nose ring on one side
of her snout, which was a jewelry
decision winter I'd never seen before.
Hi, she said. and then launched abruptly
into a speech.
Listen, whatever it is you need, I don't
think I can help you.
It's not that I wouldn't like to, I would
like to, really, I wish I could do all
kinds of things, but the truth is, I'm
not very good at anything, and I'm sure
I'm not the dragon you're looking for.
So, She trailed off.
Staring at them and twitching.
We're not asking much, Winter said.
We just want you to look at a sketch, and
see if one of you recognizes it.
And if you do, maybe you could give us
directions on how to get there.
Why should I help you?
The Red Sky Wing demanded.
Because word peace now, Riptide said
sharply, and dragons at peace help each
other.
That is kind of the entire premise of the
talons of peace.
She growled deep in her throat, sending
more smoke out her nostrils.
The other Skywing touched the little bag
on her necklace, rolling it anxiously
between her claws.
I don't know.
I mean, I have a terrible memory, she
said, and an awful sense of direction.
Just give it a try, please, pyrite.
Riptide said.
There was something in his voice that
gave Winter the impression, he'd spent a
lot of time managing this particular
dragon.
Moon took the mini scroll with her sketch
out of the satchel around her neck and
spread it out on a flat boulder, revealing
the odd mountain shapes she'd drawn.
Avalanche stomped over and glowered at
the drawing for a moment.
Doesn't look familiar.
She muttered.
All right, Moon said with a sigh.
Thank you anyway.
Can I go now?
Avalanche demanded, squinting at
riptide.
He nodded, and she leaped into the sky
flapping away with noisy, powerful wing
beats.
Pyrite, ribtide said, indicating the
scroll.
The thin sky wing edged up to moon
glanced quickly at the paper, then shook
her head, saying, sorry, sorry, sorry.
All trees look the same to me.
It's not a tree, Moon said firmly, pinning
pyrite with her gaze before the sky wing
could retreat.
It's a mountain, and you do recognize
it.
Tell us where it is.
Pyrite gave her a surprised, guilty
look.
Winter wondered whether he should warn
Moon to hide her mind reading a bit
better.
Oh, I suppose it's a bit familiar, Pyrite
said, squinting at the sketch again.
I'm sorry, I don't usually, um, do
anything useful, so.
Winter already wanted to smack this
dithering dragon.
Hailstorm was out there somewhere, alone
and trapped.
If Fidgety Pyrite thought she was going
to be the one thing standing in Winter's
way, He had a tail full of spikes ready
to convince her otherwise.
It's all right.
Don't be nervous, Kinkachu said.
Her scale's shifting to a warm golden
color similar to pyrites.
Anything you can tell us would be
helpful.
Well, I suppose it's not too far away
Pyrite admitted.
If I remember right, it's southwest of
the Sky Palace, ish.
Hmm, Kibli said, can you be any more
specific?
Maybe you can help us find it, Kinkaju
suggested.
Oh, dear no, Pyrite said, stammering and
shuffling backward.
I couldn't I'm sure.
Why are you looking for this place?
Sirius suddenly demanded.
Winter had almost forgotten he was there
but he'd somehow crept around until he
could see the sketch over Pyrite's
shoulder.
What do you really want?
It's a fair question, Riptide pointed
out.
If you want pyrite to go with you, we
should all know what she's flying into.
Winter liked the way Kibli looked to him
waiting for Winter to decide whether to
reveal the truth.
We think this is where Queen Scarlet is
hiding, Winter said cautiously.
Riptide sucked in a startled breath, Cyrus
sank lower to the ground and hissed, his
tail lashing furiously.
But Pyrite turned shining eyes to
Winter.
Queen Scarlet?
She's all right?
She picked up the drawing and held it
close to her chest.
And you think she's here?
I'll take you there if she's there.
I'm not sure that's wise.
Sirius growled.
Why would you get a vote?
Winter demanded.
She can help us if she wants to.
He had to admit to himself that he did
not love the idea of a fervent scarlet
loyalist leading them to the queen.
What if she betrayed them along the way?
But perhaps if they kept their true
mission a secret, they could still use
her.
I can try, Pyrite said.
I mean, I might get us lost, but...
I'll do my best.
For Queen Scarlet.
I always do my best for her.
Did, I mean.
She let out a little sigh, settling her
wings.
Thank you Winter said.
I don't like this.
Sirius interjected.
What good could come of finding Queen
Scarlet?
What are you planning to do if she is
there?
He suddenly gave Winters sharp look.
Did you say Prince Winter?
Mind your own business.
Winter snapped.
It's all right, Cyrus, Pyrite said.
Twisting her claws together, she gave
Winter an apologetic smile.
He kind of takes care of me.
He's just being protective.
Add that to the pile of weird mysteries
about this ice wing.
Winter thought.
Why would he be so concerned about this
rather annoying Skywing?
He can't be in love with her, can he?
Cyrus didn't have anything loving about
his demeanor.
He didn't even seem to particularly like
pyrite.
He barely glanced at her when she spoke.
He certainly didn't look at her the way.
The way I look at Moon.
Winter glanced across the clearing, and
finally admitted something to himself.
Or the way Kibley looks at Moon.
Did Moon look at either of them that
way?
He couldn't tell.
It didn't matter.
Neither of them could be with her
anyway.
Not if they wanted to remain loyal to
their queens and tribes.
Stop thinking about this, and focus on
getting Hellstorm back.
He stepped over to Pyrite, and reached
for the drawing in her claws.
As she held it out, their talons briefly
touched, and Winter felt a sudden weird
shifting of the world.
Like something tugging apart his muscles
from inside him.
He froze, staring into the sky wing's
innocent amber eyes.
He felt something strange like this once
before. at the tunnels in the rainforest
where magic had made the world not quite
right.
And if he felt the same twisting of magic
when he touched her talents, that could
only mean one thing.
Pyrite must be an animus.
Chapter 12.
Winter didn't have a chance to tell the
others his theory about pyrite that day
as it turned out, she was not only a very
nervous dragon, but she was also
extremely clingy.
As soon as Cyrus and Riptide were out of
sight, she attached herself to Winter's
tail and followed him around as though he
were made of delicious bear meat.
Why he'd been chosen for this particular
honor, Winter had no idea.
Kinkatoo and Kibli were much nicer to
Pyrite than he was, and yet she got all
flappy and anxious whenever they talked
to her.
Maybe she was simply used to having an
ice wing watch out for her.
And maybe, Sirius knows exactly what she
is, Winter guessed.
Maybe that's why he's so interested in
her whereabouts.
Maybe he's planning to use her power for
something.
But what?
What sort of sinister plans could alone
ice wing be hatching?
Brooding among the dwindling numbers of
the talons of peace.
Was he planning to deliver her to the ice
wings?
An animus to replace their long lost
Prince Arctic?
In exchange for letting him back into the
tribe?
Cyrus didn't seem to be in any hurry to
get back to the ice kingdom, though.
There must be a reason he left.
What was he up to?
It was also strange that Pyrite could
possess such enormous magic, and not be
more sure of herself.
Didn't she know she was ananimous?
Had she ever used her power?
How often?
And what had she done with it?
He glanced over his shoulder at where she
was flying, barely a wing beat behind him
casting fearful looks at the mountains
below them.
The 1st animus he'd ever met.
She was not at all what he would have
expected.
So, Pyrite, Kibley said in a friendly
voice, swooping up on her other side.
Pyrite jerked away from him, and nearly
bowled winter out of the sky.
Her wings thwacked around his snout for a
moment, and once again he got that twisty
ill feeling.
He shoved her off him and righted
himself.
Watch it, he snapped.
Sorry, sorry, sorry.
She mumbled.
She flicked her tail at Kibley.
You startled me.
Kibli made a, what is wrong with this
dragon?
Face in winter?
I was just wondering how you ended up
with the talons of peace, he said.
You don't exactly seem like the type to
desert your wing and strike out into the
wilderness on your own, looking for a
band of rebels to join.
Oh no, Pyrite said.
No, I'm not like that at all.
I'm completely loyal.
I would have kept fighting for Queen
Scarlet as long as she needed me.
She stretched her long neck and scanned
the ground below them again, then
twitched her wings to steer them a little
more westward.
But when Ruby took the throne, she made
everyone swear an oath to her, and I
couldn't do that, you know?
I'm completely loyal to Queen Scarlet
always and always and always.
Winter noticed that Moon was frowning at
pyrite, as if she were a book written in
the language of narwhals.
Had she also figured out that Pyrite was
an animus, could she see it in Pyrite's
mind?
But if Scarlet had a completely loyal
animus under her claws, why didn't she
use her to win the war?
So I left the Sky Palace and joined the
talents of peace.
Pyrite side.
Sometimes I have dreams about Queen
Scarlet telling me to come to her, but
Sirius always says to ignore them.
He says it isn't safe for me to go
flapping around the continent looking for
a dragon in exile, and the dreams don't
mean anything.
She smiled hopefully in winter.
But this isn't a wild scavenger, Chase.
You really think she'll be there.
Right?
I do, Winter said.
Suddenly wondering if this was a terrible
idea, bringing Queen Scarlet a pet
animas?
How many ways could that go horribly
wrong?
Would pyrite get in the way if they tried
to save Hailstorm?
What would she do if she knew that was
their goal?
They stopped to rest for the night in a
valley dappled with clumps of small white
flowers.
It made it look as though someone had
been tossing down snowballs from the
peaks around them.
Kibley started a fire, and cooked the
squirrels moon caught, while Winter got
himself a fish from the stream and ate it
raw.
He couldn't quite understand why anyone
would want to scorch up their food before
eating it, although it still sounded more
appetizing than the wild cherries and
plums Kinkaju had for dinner.
Pyrite picked halfheartedly at her
squirrel.
Her scales glowing in the firelight.
Every time winter looked over at her, he
was sure she'd edged a little closer to
him.
She didn't say much, and barely seemed to
be listening to Kibley as he told the
story of the dragonettes, defeating Byrne
and blister, and giving the sand wing
throne to Queen Thorn.
He'd been there and seen the whole thing
and he was a compelling storyteller, too.
Moon and Kinkachu were rapped, although
they must have heard it all before.
Finally, everyone curled up to sleep
including pyrite.
Winter volunteered to keep the 1st watch
which was a concept that seemed to
endlessly puzzle Kinkaju.
Why did anyone have to stand guard?
She'd asked the 1st night, Who would
attack sleeping dragons?
What do they have to fear now that the
war was over?
And other such inane, typically rain wing
type questions?
Darkness lay quietly over the valley.
One of the moons was a sharp crescent
just over the peaks, while the other 2
were a little more full and higher in the
sky.
Winter waited until Pyrite's breathing
was slow and steady, and then he
carefully eased himself around the others
to gently nudge Moon.
She stretched her front talons and made a
soft noise in her sleep, curling farther
into her wings.
He felt an almost unbearable longing to
press himself against her scales and fall
asleep with her star speckled wings over
his.
Moon, Winter whispered.
Shaking her shoulder again.
At last she opened her eyes and sat up
yawning.
What's wrong?
She whispered.
Is pyrite truly asleep?
He asked, as softly as he could.
She listened for a moment, then nodded.
Winter beckoned for her to follow him out
of earshot of the others, to be safe.
They stopped below a tree wrapped in
blooming vines of moonflowers.
Pale ghost petals shivering in the
breeze.
I think pyrite is an animus, Winter
said.
Coming straight to the point, because he
was afraid of what else he might say to
moon alone in the dark.
Oh.
That's interesting, Moon said.
If she is, she doesn't know it, or she
never thinks about it.
Wouldn't that be strange?
To know you have the most powerful magic
in Pyrea, and not think about it once all
day.
I'd imagine an animus would constantly be
thinking, I could just enchant this one
thing, and it would make my life easier.
And, but what if I go too far and lose my
soul?
Is this one thing worth it?
All day.
I would think, it would go back and
forth.
Maybe that's just what my brain would do
though.
In any case, I didn't hear anything like
that in Pyrite's head.
What do you think of her?
Winter asked.
Well?
I feel sorry for her, Moon said.
She ran one claw lightly down the vine
wrapped trunk of the tree.
Her brain is very odd.
It's like her thoughts are stuck in a
circle.
I don't know if she's been hit on the
head really hard or something, but they
just go round and around.
I'm completely loyal to Queen Scarlet.
I'm not very good at anything.
I'm glad I'm a Skywing.
I'm clumsy and not very bright and
generally useless.
And then back to I'm completely loyal to
Queen Scarlet.
Maybe she isn't very bright.
Winter suggested.
Or she's worried about the same things so
much for so long that her thoughts have
worn grooves in her mind, where they keep
spinning and spinning, Moon said.
I don't know I haven't read anyone like
her before.
It's very.
Okay, this sounds weird, but it's very
shallow in there.
Really, Winter said.
You've been surrounded by rain wings, but
never met anyone shallow before.
Moon poked him with her tail.
That is a really narrow-minded view of
rain wings, she said.
You must have noticed that Kinkaju and
Glory are anything but shallow.
She paused, then added with a small laugh
Well, all right, there's coconut.
I suppose he isn't much deeper than
pyrite, but it still feels unusually
weird in her head.
Maybe because she's inanimous, Winters
said.
Maybe she's using some kind of magic to
hide her power from other dragons.
A flurry of snowy petals swirl down from
the tree and over their wings, Moon
shivered.
That makes her sound very ominous, she
said.
That's exactly what I'm worried about.
Winter reached out and brushed a pedal
off Moon's shoulder.
What if she's a lot more dangerous than
she seems?
What if she can hide even from you?
How can we trust her?
They both turn to look back at the
slumbering shapes beside the fading
embers of the campfire.
Beware one who is not what she seems, Moon
whispered. sending a trail of ice along
winter's wings.
Could that be pyrite?
We need her help, though.
Winter said gruffly.
It's not like we can just fly off and
ditch her.
He was starting to wish they could
though.
I guess we just have to be careful, Moon
said softly.
She tilted her head to the side.
We should tell Kibley and see what he
thinks.
I'll tell him.
Winter said, hoping he didn't sound as
ungracious as he felt.
It was true it would be smart to get the
observant sandwing on the case, keeping
an eye on pyrite, but he found himself
picturing Kibley standing here, under
this tree with moon, and it made him feel
hollowed out, like an ice cave.
When I wake him for the next watch, you
can go back to sleep.
All right, Moon said.
She hesitated, then took a step closer to
winter, so that their wings were nearly
touching.
He felt his breath catch in his throat.
She was made for moonlight, all silver
and ebony, or moonlight was made for
her.
He could imagine her in the ice kingdom
silhouetted against the vast whiteness
dark as the ocean, and glittering like
the moonlit snow.
Except, if she said one talent in the ice
kingdom, someone would probably kill her
or at the very least, throw her into
glaciers, dungeon, where the cold would
take care of her just as thoroughly.
And his family would do the same, no
matter where she was, if they had any
idea how winter felt about her.
He would never let that happen.
Go on.
Sleep, he said, his voice coming out
rougher than he meant it to.
We might need you to find Scarlet
tomorrow.
She dropped her gaze.
Thank you for telling me about pyrite, she
said.
Good night.
And then she was gone.
Winter took this 2nd watch as well
knowing sleep would be a long time coming
for him tonight.
Chapter 13.
Kibley was the 1st to spot the eye shaped
spire in the distance. early in the
afternoon the next day.
Gray clouds had rolled in, covering the
sky in soggy blankets, and threatening to
rain at any moment.
Winter's wings felt like giant seal
flippers hanging off his back, heavy and
ponderous.
He had barely slept, and his eyelids
wanted nothing more than to slam shut and
drag him into slumber.
But when Kibley called, over there.
I think I see it.
A burst of energy jittered through
winter's muscles.
He soared over to Kibley's side, and
squinted in the direction the sand wing
was pointing.
I don't see anything, Kinkichu said.
That's because you're a rain wing, said
Pyrite.
I see it.
Skywings can see much better and farther
than you do.
So can ice wings.
Winter wanted to add, but he didn't want
to sound anything like pyrite.
I don't see it yet either.
Moon said to Kinkachu.
But if it's over there, let's go.
She put on a burst of speed and shot
ahead of the others.
Race you to that peak!
Kinkaju yelled, zipping pastor.
The 2 of them swooped away, their
laughter echoing back off the mountains.
Kinkachu's scales were dappled gold and
silver today, like some metallic treasure
version of a dragon.
She'd chatted happily with pyrite over
breakfast, and winter had felt a pang of
guilt that he hadn't woken her up to hear
his theory too.
Were rain wings even capable of regarding
other dragons with suspicion?
Terribly undignified.
Kibley said in a haughty voice, tipping
his snout at the racing dragons, we would
never allow such higgledy piggledy
shenanigans in the ice kingdom.
Was that supposed to be me?
Winter asked him.
Terribly unimpressive if so.
I haven't once said higgledy piggledy in
my entire life.
We would never allow such linguistic
imprecision in the ice kingdom.
Kibli barked a delighted laugh, and did a
loop in the air.
And their shadowy conversation last night
Kibli hadn't quite believed that pyrite
could be an animus.
He'd pointed out that Sky Wings hadn't
had one in centuries, possibly as long as
the ice wings, which was something Winter
should have remembered for himself.
But he had agreed that there was
something not quite right about the
skittish sky wing.
Winter found himself oddly comforted by
the idea that Kibley was watching her.
If anyone could figure out pyrites
secrets, and strangeness, it was probably
Kibley.
I wonder if this is how mudwings feel
working in teams all the time.
He'd read about the mudwing sibling bond
and how they lived and fought and died
together.
Father said it made them weak, because a
mudwing warrior would listen to his
brothers and sisters instead of his
commander.
Mother said they'd always be worrying
about what might happen to the soldier
next to them, instead of focusing on the
battle.
That's why it should be easy to defeat
the mud wings, they said.
But it hadn't been that easy.
As many, many battles had taught them
over the years of the Great War.
Maybe I'd rather have allies like Kibley
and Moon, making their own decisions, and
trusting each other than a commander
telling me what to do.
Winter thought.
Was that treasonous?
Did it make him less of an ice wing?
If he kept having thoughts like these
Would he be completely ruined by the time
he got home?
They reached the spire not long after
that, and found the jagged mountain wall
that matched Moon's drawing.
It overlooked a hidden valley, where the
3 waterfalls turned into rivers, that led
into a crystal blue lake.
The lake bent and squiggled around the
edges, like a new hatched dragonette's
drawing of a circle.
Winter and the others landed on the
northern shore, staring up at the eye
shaped rock formation far overhead.
I don't like it here.
Kinkaju said it once.
She shivered, flicking her tail and
turning a sort of pale jade green.
It feels like we're being watched.
I mean, as if the mountains themselves
are watching us.
And their rivers are whispering about us
Kibley said.
Kinkachu thwacked him with one of her
wings, and he jumped back, looking
injured.
I was agreeing with you, he yelped.
Oh, well, try to sound less sarcastic
next time, Kingachu scolded.
My point is, it's creepy here.
Moon glanced around to make sure Pyrite
wasn't listening.
The Sky Wing had waded into the lake and
was scanning the sky and trees
hopefully.
Sounds like the perfect place for Scarlet
to hide, she whispered.
A sudden flutter of wings made them all
spin around, but it was only a group of
crows taking flight from a nearby tree, a
murder of crows.
Winter thought with a shiver.
There's something over there.
Pyrite said, waving her tail toward the
far side of the lake.
They hopped over the water, following her
and found what appeared to be the
wreckage of a rough structure.
Long branches stripped of their leaves
were scattered across the ground, and
vines still tied in knots, lay in crust
piles, as if they had been trampled by
angry talons.
The entire mess was covered in ripped up
flower petals, rose and violet, and
daffodil yellow shredded scraps
everywhere.
The only remaining intact piece was a
canopy, woven from vines, that tilted
lopsidedly in the tree overhead.
Yikes!
Kinkachu said.
Someone was not pleased about something.
Winter glanced over at Moon, for the
9000th time that day, and found her
frowning up at the ridge that loomed over
them.
What is it?
he asked her.
Just a feeling, she said. letting a
shiver run out to her wingtips.
I don't know exactly.
I do know, said Kinkachu.
Creepy being watched feeling, as I have
already mentioned.
Pyrite let out a gasp and pounced on a
stack of broken twigs.
Caught on the point of one of them was a
dark orange scale.
It's Scarlet's, she cried.
I know it is.
I'd recognize her color anywhere.
She looked around desperately.
But where is she?
What happened here?
Did something terrible happen to her?
There's no sign of violence.
Kibley said, moving one of the branches
aside to look underneath.
No blood, no claw marks on the
surrounding trees.
It looks more like she destroyed her
shelter in a temper and left.
Perhaps she somehow found out we were
coming.
Winter said.
Dread crept slowly under his claws and up
along his spine.
What?
How would she know that?
Kingachu said in alarm.
Winter, Kibli, and Moon all looked at
pyrite.
The orangey yellow sky wing, was
overturning bits of foliage, and scraping
through the moss, as though she expected
to find Scarlet buried in it somewhere.
Preoccupied with muttering and hissing
and grumbling.
She didn't notice their attention on
her.
Pyrite, Kibley said.
Did you happen to see Queen Scarlet in
your dream last night?
She glanced at him and shook her head
doubtfully.
I don't think so.
I don't really remember.
I think I had a weird dream about snow
maybe, but that happens whenever I sleep
near Sirius, too.
It's still possible.
Moon said, even if she doesn't remember
it.
Scarlett could have interrogated her in
her dream and found out what she was
doing and where she was going.
It doesn't matter.
Winter said, what matters is that
Scarlet's gone and so is Hailstorm.
He ripped a large branch off the nearest
tree, and hurled it into the forest.
Gone.
Their one chance of finding his brother.
Scarlett could have taken him anywhere in
Pyria by now.
Or she could have killed him.
If she figured out that winter was not, in
fact, in the rainforest trying to
assassinate glory for her.
It was strange to Winter that Hailstorm's
death could still hurt so much every time
it happened.
He would have thought the 1st time would
be the worst.
The night a spy had burst into the royal
dining room, shouting that all of
Scarlet's ice wing prisoners were dead.
The Nightwings killed them all, he
shrieked.
It made no sense.
Why would Nightwings enter Skywing
territory to kill prisoners?
But it felt true nonetheless, like
something Nightwings would do.
If they could have attacked the night
kingdom that very moment, if they'd known
where it was, they would have.
All the ice wings in Queen Glacier's
domain would have risen up to avenge
their murdered comrades.
Winter's parents hadn't spoken to him for
a month after that report, and he didn't
blame them.
He didn't want to speak to himself
either.
He couldn't bear to see his own pathetic
face, and the icy reflections
everywhere.
Until then, there'd been hope that they
could still negotiate Hellstorm's release
or carry out a rescue plan.
But there was no hope.
He was gone, as dead as all the other
lost ice wings.
And now winter had the same crumbling
feeling inside, except instead of a snow
drift caving in.
This was a whole avalanche, cascading
heavily down into his bones.
This time it was even more his fault.
He had failed his brother, and then
failed him again, and again and again.
Stop.
Stop it, Kibley said, suddenly in front
of Winter, taking his shoulders and
shaking him.
I see you going to the giving up place in
your head.
Get yourself out of there right now.
We do not know he's dead any more than we
did an hour ago.
What we have to do is keep searching
because he's only definitely dead.
If we give up and sit here like moping
camels.
You are not allowed to mourn until you
see a dead body.
Do you understand me?
What else am I supposed to do?
Winter snarled.
What's your next brilliant idea?
How can he still be alive?
Who are we talking about?
Pyrite asked, wrinkling her snout.
What he?
I'm confused.
We split up and searched the whole valley
Kibley said, ignoring her.
I'll go with Kinkaju, and you go with
Moon.
Look for clues about how long Scarlet was
here. and where she might have gone.
Look for a cave or something else that
could have been used as a prison.
Figure out where and how she actually
kept him, and see if we can guess how
she's transporting him.
Were there other Skywings helping her?
Or how else was he guarded?
Is she traveling in a group?
With a chained ice wing behind her?
Because that's going to be a little
obvious, don't you think?
Look for messages she might have left
behind.
Look for anything that will actually tell
us something.
Winter stared at him, breathing so hard
his tail spikes were rattling.
Kibley stared back, deadly serious.
What kind of moon's dazzled dragon would
do all this for a stranger from a
different tribe?
Why hasn't he given up?
Why isn't he letting me give up?
When it means he could go back to Jade
Mountain and carry on with his life.
Come on, Kinkaju, Kibley said, flicking
his tail ladder.
We'll take the valley south of the lake.
The rest of you go north.
You bet, Kingachu said, with ridiculous
enthusiasm.
He's letting me go with Moon.
Winter realized, on purpose, even though
he wants to be with her as badly as I
do.
But he knows.
Or he hopes that searching with her will
keep me going.
Am I that obvious?
I'll go with Winter, Pyrite declared.
Not that anyone asked, but I figure
that's okay, right?
Although, what are we looking for?
Signs of Scarlet being here, Winter told
her.
Anything that looks like the detritus of
dragons.
She accepted this with a puzzled shrug.
He led the way back over the lake, and
they started into the woods, methodically
covering every square of ground all the
way back to the mountain cliff ahead.
Winter's eyes raked the dirt and trees
and shrubs and streams, and all the small
corners around them.
Can you hear anyone?
He whispered to Moon, when Pyrite was out
of earshot.
She shook her head.
Only pyrite.
Sorry, Winter.
Kibble had a point though.
Where had Scarlett been keeping Hailstorm
for the last 2 years?
Was he guarded?
Chained up?
Had he been moved here from somewhere
else?
Who had fed him and kept him alive while
she was trapped in Burns stronghold?
How did she keep him from trying to
escape?
Their brother Winter knew?
Would have fought tooth and claw to be
free.
If he'd been imprisoned anywhere near
here?
There should be clues.
Claw marks scored along the walls of a
cave, or a tree with indentations of
chains crushed into its trunk.
Or most likely of all.
Something hailstorm had used his frost
breath on.
They should look for signs of something
that had been frozen.
But there was nothing.
They spent their rest of the daylight
searching, with no success.
The only sign of life in the whole valley
was scarlet's scale in the destroyed
structure.
Otherwise, the grass waved peacefully, and
the trees quietly filled with fruit, and
it seemed as though no talons had ever
disturbed the stillness.
Winter couldn't imagine a prison here
anywhere.
There were no suitable caves for keeping
prisoners in, at least not close to the
valley floor.
Perhaps hailstorm's prison is higher up
in the mountains.
Winter speculated around their campfire
that night.
He was keeping his distance from the
flames.
The heat made his scales feel all melty
and sticky.
We'll search up there tomorrow, Moon
said.
We'll find something.
She shivered.
It's so quiet out here.
Winter actually found it distractingly
noisy compared to the ice kingdom.
For one thing, it sounded like 2 rival
cricket symphonies were competing at top
volume.
The owls were hooting so much.
It was a wonder they had time to fit prey
in their mouths as well.
Things flapped overhead, and small
splashes came from the lake.
The night felt extremely populated.
Then it occurred to him that Moon might
be talking about the noise inside her
head.
With all of them wearing Skyfire, the
only voice she could hear and there was
pyrites, presumably still treading in its
odd, boring circle.
That must be strange for her.
He realized, to give that all up and
trust us with her secret.
Would any other night wing do that?
Would any other dragon empire do that?
He wanted to believe that he would.
That if he had the power to read minds
he'd tell other dragons right away
instead of invading their minds in
secret.
But would he really?
With a rare weapon like that, wouldn't he
be tempted to use it?
That night, he let Moon take the 1st
watch.
All he wanted to do was turn off the
world and his brain for a while.
He gazed up at the shadowy, hulking forms
of the mountains, as sleep drifted
through him, slowly leading him into odd
half dreams about his brother in a cave
up there, watching the valley below for 2
lonely years.
He wasn't sure how much time had passed
wandering through a half seen labyrinth
of stone passages, when he turned a
corner, and suddenly the dream sharpened
around the edges.
An orange dragon stood before him, wearing
veils of dark smoke that poured from her
snout, and from the fire beside her.
Blood and ice dripped across her face and
wings until she shifted, and he realized
it was only rubies and diamonds embedded
in her scales, catching the firelight.
She pinned him with her yellow gaze, sharp
as talons.
Tell me who you are.
She ordered.
Don't you know?
he asked.
I know who you are.
Very flattering.
She said, in a slithering voice.
So perhaps, then you can also gather why
I am not pleased to see you.
She took a step toward him, and the dream
cave trembled around them.
Something wavered across her face, like a
mask, slipping to reveal a glimpse of
another disfigured face underneath.
You're a long way from the rainforest
prince of ice.
There's no one who needs killing around
where you are now.
He was silent for a beat too long, and
she began to laugh.
Oh, you mean me?
She said.
Is that your clever plan?
Find the most deadly queen Empirea?
Kill her and take back your brother?
She leaned toward winter.
Every muscle taut with glee.
Even if you could kill me.
You would never find your lost ice
swing.
Never.
The prison I've got him in is far too
clever for that.
Where is he?
Winter demanded.
Is he all right?
He was, all right, she said.
Her face twisted in a strange smirk of
triumph and fury.
But he won't be after this conversation.
I gave your sister one last chance.
She swore to me that you would kill
glory.
And yet, here you are.
And I know that backstabbing face melting
queen still lives.
Queen Scarlet side hugely, and shook her
head with a mockingly disappointed
expression.
I suppose if I won more dragon's dead.
I'll just have to kill someone myself.
And let's see.
Who do I have?
Right in my clutches.
Don't kill him, Winter cried.
What else do you want?
Queen Glacier's treasury is vast.
She would pay you his weight in diamonds
for his safe return.
Scarlett snorted.
What use?
Are diamonds to me.
If I want something, I don't pay for it.
I take it.
And right now, groveling prince.
I only want 2 things.
My throne back.
And vengeance.
Her eyes narrowed to slits, and her tail
lashed dangerously.
Here's some interesting information for
you.
Your queen doesn't want her nephew bag as
badly as you think.
I visited her dreams with a proposal.
Help me drag my conniving daughter off my
throne, and she could have him.
Would you believe she turned me down?
She said he'd been mourned already, and
her duty was to the yet unlost lives of
her subjects.
Doesn't that make you furious?
Ice dragon?
Winter stared down at his claws.
Was Scarlet lying?
Had she really tried to negotiate with
Queen Glacier?
And had his queen decided to leave
Hailstorm to die?
He realized, he could believe it.
The ice wings had just survived 20 years
of war over another tribe's throne, and
with nothing to show for it, except too
many dead warriors.
Queen Glacier would not be eager to
plunge them back into another conflict
especially on behalf of a dragon she
couldn't trust, and wouldn't want to see
in charge of the sky kingdom again
anyway.
So, you're his only hope.
Scarlett taunted him, or at least you
were.
It's all over now, though.
I can see that you're far too useless to
kill anyone for me.
My only remaining pleasure is watching
your face, as I tell you, your brother
will be dead by morning. winter's head
jerked up.
Wait.
He backed away from Scarlet, blinking
rapidly.
I have to wake up.
He dug his claws ferociously into one
shoulder, but felt nothing.
The dream cave still held him, and
Scarlet's yellow eyes watched with
menacing amusement.
Perhaps you'd like to hear how I plan to
kill him, she mused.
I could slowly burn him to death.
That would be lengthy and painful.
Winter turned and stumbled out of the
cave.
Was there a way out through the
passages?
He tried to visualize, snapping awake
opening his eyes, sitting up and finding
himself in the valley.
It wasn't working.
Scarlet's mocking laugh followed him
through the narrow maze, echoing off
smooth stone walls that all looked the
same.
Maybe, I'll gouge out his eyes 1st.
She called.
Maybe all stuff live goats into his
throat until he suffocates.
Winter stopped running and fumbled for
his ankle.
He felt the weight of the Skyfire pouch
there, solid and heavy.
Don't you want to beg?
Scarlet shrieked.
Don't you want to offer to do anything
for me?
What have I told you to kill the rain
wing who's with you?
What else could you throw at my feet?
Desperate prince.
With trembling claws, he ripped to the
cord, binding the pouch to his scales.
Finally, he yanked it free and dropped it
on the ground.
Moon, he yelled in his mind.
Wake me up.
Wake me up right now.
Barely a moment later, he felt talons on
his shoulders, shaking and shaking him
until finally, the dream world tore away
like wet paper, and he was sitting up on
the grass, eyes popping open, wide
awake.
Moon let go of him and took a shaky
breath.
Are you all right?
She whispered.
Behind her was Kibley, rubbing his eyes
sleepily.
They all look down at the Skyfire pouch.
Winter had really managed to tear it off
in his sleep, and now it lay between them
leaving Winter's mind exposed.
Moon immediately picked it up and handed
it to him.
Tell me what happened, she said.
Queen Scarlet was in my dream, Winter
said, tying the pouch back on.
Well, no wonder, Kibley said.
You've been thinking about her all day.
No, Winter said.
I mean, it was really her.
Dream visiting me.
They both got it at the same moment.
That means she's seen you, Kibley said.
Completely awake now, his tail curled up
into attack position.
In order to visit your dream, she must
have seen you, today, or she would have
done it sooner.
Scarlet saw you today.
Moon echoed.
She jumped to her feet, turning in a
circle, in this valley, where we are
right now.
Exactly, Winter said, which means Scarlet
is somewhere close by.
Chapter 14.
A breeze whipped through the trees
hurtling wet droplets over their wings
below embers of the fire made a hissing
sound, and pyrite shifted in her sleep
with a grunt.
Scarlet is close enough to watch this
valley.
Moon said again.
Kingachu was right.
We were being spied on.
She said, my brother will die in the
morning, Winter said.
He took a deep breath, trying to shut up
his hammering heart.
She said, now that she's seen me.
She knows I'm not going to kill anyone
for her.
How could she tell?
just by looking at me.
That's a good thing that you're not that
kind of dragon.
Moon reminded him, nudging his side.
Did you see any clues?
Kibley asked, about where she is now.
Winter shook his head.
We were in a cave in my dream.
It looked like any other cave.
Underground or in a mountain somewhere
except at one point, her face seemed to
change in front of me.
And the face I saw underneath, apart from
being horrible, It looked like it was lit
by moonlight.
Kimley looked up at the sky, his black
eyes darting from the moons to the
peaks.
Half the mountain range is in shadow
right now.
He said.
We fly to the other side and search.
Everywhere in view of this valley.
We go now.
Moon took a step toward Kinkachu and
Winter reached out to stop her.
The rain wing slept peacefully, a half
smile on her face, her scales dappled in
silver splotches, like the moonlight, that
fell through the leaves and across her
wings.
This is what your queen said not to do.
Winter reminded Moon in a low whisper.
We're going to confront Scarlet.
She could rip Kinkaju apart in a
heartbeat.
Glory would want her to stay out of it.
And you too.
I'm not staying out of it, Moon said
fiercely.
You need me if you're going to find her.
I'm not going to hide.
I don't do that anymore.
Then keep at least half your promise to
your queen.
Winter said.
Leave Kinkachu asleep and safe.
He's right, Kibley said.
Glory would definitely not want you both
marching off to find Scarlet.
Moon blew out a breath that ruffled the
tree branches around them.
She's going to kill me, she whispered
glancing back at her sleeping friend.
Better that, then Scarlet killing her.
Winter pointed out.
All right, Moon said.
She shook her head.
All right.
Let's go.
Winter was in the sky by the end of her
sentence, winging toward the eye shaped
rock formation.
From there, they could sweep south and
around the circumference of the valley
checking the mountain crags and
crannies.
It was a lot of distance to cover, and
perhaps Scarlet had flown off as soon as
she saw him, ending up 100s of miles away
by now.
But now that he'd seen her thirst for
vengeance firsthand, he had a strong
suspicion she was still nearby.
She'd want to watch Winter's despair the
next morning, and whatever panicked
action he took next.
So if she was close, and if Moon could
catch Scarlet's mind, maybe they had a
chance to stop her while Hailstorm was
still alive.
If he even is still alive, and she isn't
just torturing us.
Let moon go first, Kibley said, soaring
up beside him.
No offense, but you're glowing like a 4th
moon up here.
And I'm not exactly the most shadowy
dragon myself.
She's practically invisible in the night
sky.
That's kind of the point of our whole
tribe after all.
Winter twisted around, and had to admit
to himself that Kibley was right.
It took him a minute to even see Moon
behind him.
She faded perfectly into the dark, and
her silver scales, looked exactly like
distant stars.
But he wanted to lead the way.
He wanted to find Scarlet 1st and sink
his claws into her neck.
He wanted to be the one who rescued
Hailstorm.
The hero who brought him back, the dragon
who surpassed all his parents
expectations.
His wings wavered in the air.
His luminous, treacherous wings, which
reflected the moonlight to anyone below
who might chance to look up.
This is not about your place in the
rankings.
It's not about what mother and father and
the queen think of you.
It's about saving Hillstorm.
He fell back, lifting up into the cloud
cover.
The dense, rain soaked clouds around him
made it hard to see the land below, but
they would also hide his gleaming blue
white scales from anyone watching.
Moon shot out ahead, sweeping low over
the mountain ridge.
Her head tilted from side to side
listening, and she flew in long glides
keeping her wing beats quiet and spaced
apart.
Kibley and Winter followed, imitating
her.
The folded, crooked peaks whooshed
silently past below them.
Winter felt the minutes ticking by with
awful urgency.
What a scarlet guest they were coming and
left.
What if she killed Hailstorm now instead
of waiting until morning?
How soon was morning?
Was the sky getting lighter in the east?
He remembered her awful yellow eyes fixed
on his.
He tried to remember his brother's eyes
instead. bluer than winters or icicles
cringled around the edges when he grinned
which was all the time, because Hailstorm
was the only ice wing winter I'd ever met
who could laugh about what other dragons
thought of him.
Of course, it must be a lot easier to
laugh from the top of the rankings.
He'd never forgotten Hailstorm's last
words to him.
Had he truly meant them.
Had he always been disappointed in his
little brother?
Would he feel differently if winter came
flying in to rescue him?
Moon suddenly checked herself, flaring
her wings to come to a stop in midair.
Winter and Kibley did the same, farther
up in the clouds.
Winter's heart was thudding so loud, he
thought they must be able to hear it in
Glacier's palace.
He scanned the area.
A stretch of rocky slope leading up to a
peak, where several flat ledges and
outcroppings directly overlooked the
valley.
From here, he could see the dim flicker
of the fire they'd left behind, although
kinkajus and pyrites sleeping shapes were
obscured by the tree cover.
But if Scarlet had watched from up here
all day, she would have clearly seen
winter traversing the open spaces below
clearly enough to guess who he was, and
then walk straight into his dreams.
Moon beckoned them down to her, and they
all dove under a narrow shelf of rock
that hid them from the ridge above.
She's up there, Moon whispered.
Her and someone else.
Hailstorm?
Winter clenched his talons. holding in
the wild prickles of energy that were
stabbing through his scales.
I don't think so, Moon said.
It doesn't have the bright glare of an
ice wing mind, although it feels a little
familiar.
I can't actually read it.
Like, there's a wall of humming between
me and it.
Someone with Skyfire?
Kibley asked.
She shook her head.
A bit like that, but not exactly the
same.
It might just be the distance.
They're near the top of this mountain.
She put one talent over winter suddenly
making a sh gesture.
Winter forced himself to sit in silence
as she listened.
They're arguing.
Moon said.
Scarlet's mind is loud and angry and all
over the place.
I think we can get closer without her
noticing.
Lead the way, Kibley said.
She flowed silently over the ledge above
them, and began creeping up the hill
vanishing almost instantly into the night
shrouded undergrowth, Winter hurried
after her, trying to be as quiet as she
was.
It was almost impossible.
His talons were shaking with impatience
and tension.
Halfway up the slope.
He began to hear voices.
I absolutely hate these narrow nosed ice
wings.
Spat a voice.
That was unmistakably Scarlet's.
This one was worse than his sister.
He barely groveled at all.
I don't think he ever had any intention
of murdering anyone from me.
The nerve.
You couldn't convince him otherwise.
Said a 2nd voice.
Usually, you are very convincing.
He was obviously a lost cause, Scarlett
said with a snarl.
Kept making this hero face at me, like
I'm the bad guy, and he's coming to write
all the wrongs.
Excuse me.
Who got attacked by her own artwork, and
then kidnapped by her ally, and then
blackmailed by her champion, mid rescue
while meanwhile, her own daughter was
stealing her throne.
Who's the one with the hideous face
maiming?
whose throne is currently occupied by a
pretender, who could never have beaten me
in a challenge before, who had her whole
life ruined and emolished and shattered
by the stupid, horrible dragonettes.
There was a pause.
But before the other dragon could answer
Scarlet shouted, Me.
That's who?
I'm the victim here.
Someone should be all heroically trying
to help me write all the wrongs.
Where's my rotten cavalry of loyal
idiots?
Well, you have me, said the voice, with a
notable lack of enthusiasm.
You, barely count, said Scarlet.
You're weird.
And unreliable.
Ahem, the voice bristled.
I believe my talents have proven to be
very useful to you.
Not as useful, as if you were a proper
animus, Scarlett grumbled.
One limited power is not going to get me
back my throne.
An animus?
Winter thought, like pyrite?
Does Scarlet have 2 animus dragons loyal
to her?
By now they had crept close enough that
Winter could see small spurts of flame
coming from Scarlet's snout.
She was pacing on a moonlit ledge, while
her companion stood in the shadow of the
mountain, hidden from view.
Moon tugged him behind a tangle of
boulders and shrubs.
He crouched beside her, and Kibley crept
up on her other side.
Moon carefully spread her black wings
over them, hiding as much of their pale
scales as she could.
Her wing across Winter's back was warm.
Like a polar bear fur wrapped around your
shoulders, after a swim in the Arctic
Ocean.
You are welcome to dismiss me from your
service, said the stranger in a cold
voice.
Once you have paid me everything I am
owed, of course.
Scarlet growled low in her throat.
What do I do now?
She demanded.
I have this ice wing pawn, who should be
thrillingly useful, and it turns out
nobody will do what it takes to get him
back.
All I am asking for is a little
vengeance.
Is that so much to expect?
Perhaps a new strategy is in order.
Said the stranger dryly.
Scarlet let out a huffy sigh.
I suppose I do have to kill him.
She said.
Now that I've promised to about 8 times.
It will serve all of them right.
Or maybe it won't.
Since nobody even seems to care enough to
commit just a little murder for me. 3
moons.
She fumed in silence for a few minutes.
Smoke curled from her nostrils up to the
sky.
So, the stranger said after a while.
Are you prepared to kill the prisoner?
Scarlet flung a rock off the edge and
watched it bounce and clatter down the
hill.
Winter held his breath, pressing closer
to Moonside.
She hooked her front claws in the bush in
front of them and leaned forward, eyes
closed, head tilted toward the arguing
dragons.
Yes, Scarlet said.
Very well.
Bring me pyrite.
Chapter 15.
Moon's eyes flew open, and her bewildered
gaze met Winters.
Pyrite?
What does she have to do with hailstorm?
Did she do something to him?
Does she know where he is?
If she does, we have to get to her
first.
Winter started to scramble to his feet
but Moon pushed him back down with her
wing, pointing up at the ledge.
A moment later, a dragon leaped off it
and spiraled up into the sky, banking
toward the valley.
Winter only caught a glimpse of his
scales, as the firelight flickered over
them, but he was sure of what he saw.
Scarlet's ally was a night wing.
Who is that?
he demanded.
I have no idea.
Moon whispered back, but if he's a
Nightwing, Maybe that's why I can't hear
him think.
Maybe he's been trained to shield from
mind readers or something.
We have to get to pyrite before he does.
Kibli whispered from Moon's other side.
He was right.
They didn't have time for the mystery of
a Nightwing who worked for a deposed
Skywing Queen.
Winter slid out from under Moon's wing
and started crawling back down the
mountainside as fast as he could, looking
for a spot where he could take off
without Scarlet seeing him.
Pebbles bounced past him as Kibley and
Moon followed.
Now, Moon breathed suddenly.
She launched herself off the mountain and
winter hurtled after her.
He arrowed down toward their camp, his
eyes fixed on that small flicker of
firelight.
The night wing won't go straight there.
Kibley panted behind him.
He'll want to sneak up and take pyrite
while the rest of us are sleeping.
He'll land and approach the camp
quietly.
We'll get there first.
Only if you shut up and fly, Winter
growled.
Kibli didn't say another word as they
shot down the cliffs and over the trees.
Winter plunged through the leaves and
landed with a skidding crash beside
Kinkaju.
Yikes!
The rain wing yelped, leaping to her
feet.
For a wild, breathless moment.
Winter thought pyrite was gone.
But then she sat up on the other side of
the fire, rubbing her face.
What's all the noise?
She mumbled.
Yeah, really?
Kingaju said, flaring the rough behind
her ears.
Is someone on fire?
Why are you smashing around waking up
perfectly happy sleeping dragons?
Beep!
she cried, as Moon and Kibli came
thudding down behind winter, trailing
broken branches, with leaves and twigs
caught in their wings and tails.
You!
Winter leaped over the fire and bold
pyrite to the ground.
She screamed, flapped her wings at him
and tried to wriggle away, but he leaned
all his weight on her back, and pinned
her down with his deadly ice wing claws.
Even though she was bigger than him, she
stopped resisting quickly.
Her talons twitched in the grass, and she
twisted her neck to look back at him.
This is mean, she protested.
What do you know about my brother?
he demanded.
Nothing at all, she said.
Now, can I get up?
You know something, he said, in a low
dangerous voice.
He's an ice wing named Hailstorm, a
couple of years older than me.
The bravest dragon Empirea, Scarlet's
prisoner for the last 2 years.
He shook her roughly.
You know where he is.
All right, all right, she whined.
But you don't have to attack me.
I would have told you if you just asked.
Queen Scarlet's prisoners are kept in an
arena in the Sky Palace.
I can draw you a map of the place if you
want.
I don't think there are any ice wings
there anymore, though, and Ruby traded
back almost all the prisoners of war.
Frustration surged through winter, and he
dug his claws in just a little, making
pyrite wince across the fire.
Kinkachu was watching them with wide
bewildered eyes.
Don't toy with me, Skywing.
Winter hissed.
Scarlet needs you in order to kill
Hellstorm.
So why is that?
Where is he?
Did you use your magic on him?
What?
Magic?
Pyrite protested.
I don't have any magic.
I never did anything special for Queen
Scarlet.
Winter.
I think she's telling the truth, Moon
said.
She had her front talons pressed to her
head, and an expression of pain scrawled
across her face.
She has no idea what you're talking
about.
What she said?
Pyrite yelped.
No idea.
She's blocking you somehow, Winter said
furiously.
She is magic.
I can feel it.
With the sky wing pinioned below him, the
muscle wringing sensation of powerful
animus magic was beating through him
stronger than ever.
He glared down at the dragon and spotted
the necklace tangled around her neck.
Maybe with her necklace.
Maybe she enchanted it to hide her mind
from you.
He reached for the chain.
Don't touch that, roared Pyrite, surging
to her feet, and throwing him off with
sudden powerful violence.
Winter was flung straight into the fire.
The burning embers sizzled against his
scales and back talons, and he leaped
away with a howl of pain.
It took a moment for his head to clear
but when it did, he saw 2 shapes
grappling through the smoke of the
scattered fire.
Kibley's tail was poised like a scorpions
as he wrestled pyrite.
Her arms were longer than his, and her
claws slashed at his underbelly, while
her wings beat him away from her.
The sky wing's teeth were bared, and her
face was a grimace of fury and
determination.
Winter's burns were sending fiery bolts
of pain along all the nerves in his body
but he staggered forward to help Kibley.
And then, Kingachu shrieked, and a black
dragon was suddenly there, appearing from
the shadows.
He pounced on Kinkaju, striking her 3
times with swift brutality, and then
slamming her out of the way with a
powerful blow from his tail.
The little rain wing was thrown into a
tree trunk with a sickening crack.
She crumbled to the ground, her scales
fading to white.
Kinkajoo?
Moon cried.
The black dragon turned on her, and she
roared a jet of blazing fire straight at
his face.
He reared back, covering his eyes, and
she leaped at him, slashing furiously at
his wings and neck.
A bright gash of red appeared along his
throat, and he roared, seizing moon's
talons.
Blisters were starting to bubble along
the edges of his mouth and nose, and he
kept shaking his head, as though it was
hard to see, but he was strong and huge
and he flung moon to the ground with
ease.
Winter didn't remember choosing.
Although there must have been a moment
when his head said, go after pyrite.
She's the key to finding Hillstorm, while
his heart shouted, no, help moon.
But as far as he could tell, there was no
conscious thought involved.
He was just there.
Barreling into the night wing before the
monster could stamp his sharp talons down
on Moon's neck.
The 2 of them rolled across the clearing
black and white scales clashing, both of
them roaring at full blast.
Winter felt metal tangle and clatter
around his claws.
The night wing was wearing a mess of dark
jewelry, and things that felt like
compact iron boxes on chains, as they
smacked into winter's jaws and knuckles.
He ducked his head, as the Nightwing shot
a burst of flames past his ear.
The ice was rising in his throat.
He twisted to bring his mouth up to the
night wing's face, and hissed frost
breath straight into the dragon's eyes.
The night wing slammed his eyes shut at
the last second, but ice immediately
began spreading across his snout, sealing
his eyelids in place, and melting into
the burns moon had given him.
The black dragon's bellow of agony was
like nothing winter had ever heard
before.
He threw winter often, and bolted into
the sky.
For a moment, winter could see him
weaving and dipping from side to side as
he tried to fly without sight.
And then the night wing's black scales
vanished into the dark and the heavy
storm clouds.
At some point, it had started to rain.
Scattered fat droplets that plopped into
the dying fire with dragon like hisses.
The raindrops were soothing on winter's
burns as he dragged himself back to
moon.
She was crouched beside Kinkaju, shaking
the little rain wing gently.
Please be all right, Moon whispered.
Kinkachu, please wake up.
Her voice snagged into a sob.
I can't hear her.
I can't hear anything from her mind at
all.
She's just unconscious, Winters said, but
he wasn't sure.
The dragonette looked as if she'd been
dropped from a great height, crumpled, and
still.
He went for her first, Moon said.
Did you see that?
He could have attacked any of us, but he
started with Kinkachu on purpose.
Why would anyone do that?
Why target a tiny rain wing, the smallest
of us?
She straightened one of Kinkaju's crooked
wings and smoothed it back into place.
Maybe he was worried about her venom
Winter said.
Scarlet has probably talked about rain
wing venom quite a lot, given her
experience.
Moon lifted and dropped her wings with a
doubtful expression.
Her eyes never left Kinkachu's pale
face.
Winter turned and saw.
Finally, what should have been his 1st
thought?
Kimley had subdued pyrite, and was
standing over her on the other side of
the clearing, his venomous tail suspended
over the midpoint of her spine.
Winter limped over, and looked down at
the traitorous sky wing.
That night wing could come back with
Scarlet any minute, Kibble warned him.
We should get out of here as fast as we
can.
Winter nodded.
He reached for Pyrite's necklace.
No, Pyrite said, with a hysterical edge
to her voice.
Please, I'm not supposed to take it off
ever.
It's lie or death.
I need to wear it.
Please leave it alone.
Don't take it.
Don't.
He ripped it off her neck, yanking 3
times before the chain finally snapped.
The sky wing let out a cry of despair.
Winter felt the pouch crinkle between his
claws.
Whatever was inside was very light, and
crunched, like a talon full of snow.
He was about to open the pouch, when
pyrite scales began to slide off.
At least, that was Winter's 1st
impression.
It looked almost as though she was
melting and growing, and snapping into
place at the same time.
Her snout narrowed and lengthened.
The orange color bled swiftly out of each
scale.
Sharp spikes shoved up through the skin
all along her back, and at the tip of her
tail.
Kibley leaped off her with a shout of
surprise.
It was over in a matter of seconds.
The dragon, who was no longer pyrite
arched his back, unfolded his long white
wings, and opened eyes as blue as the
Arctic sky.
He coughed, and stared around him in
utter bewilderment.
His gaze landed on winter and Kibley.
Winter, he said, in a shaky, hoarse
voice.
Winter stared up at him, his talons
rooted to the earth, his wings prickling
with fear.
He was too shocked to speak Holy snakes
said Kibley.
Is that, are you?
Pyrite was gone.
Standing in her place.
Was hailstorm.
Chapter 16.
Hailstorm?
Winter whispered.
But how?
You were just, you were a Sky Wing.
I saw you.
How did you?
What happened to the throne room?
Hailstorm asked, his voice getting
stronger.
And what have you been eating to get so
big?
He stopped, swaying in place and rubbing
his eyes.
Wait.
I have to find the queen.
Why are my scales the wrong color?
He held out his talons and then recoiled
from them with an expression of terror.
What have you done to me?
Why am I so cold?
He seized Winter's front claws in a grip
that sent shockwaves of desperation along
Winter's arms?
Who am I?
Hellstorm demanded.
You're my brother, Winter said.
That was clear.
That was true.
They could deal with spells and lingering
side effects later.
He leaned into Hailstorm's grasp, locking
their eyes together.
And we have to get you out of here before
Scarlett finds you.
Queen Scarlet.
Hailstorm corrected automatically.
She wouldn't hurt me.
I am completely lo- His face twisted.
Horror warring with despair and
confusion.
What am I saying?
Winter.
We'll fix it, but right now, we have to
fly, Winter said.
Kibley darted across the clearing and
said something to Moon.
She immediately slid her talons under
Kinkaju and tried to hoist the rain wing
onto Kibley's back, struggling as
Kinkaju's tail flopped sideways and
overbalanced her.
The unconscious dragon's wings wapped
moon in the face, and her head lulled
awkwardly on her long neck.
Winter took a step toward them, but
Hailstorm wouldn't let go of him.
Are you real?
The tall Ice Wing asked.
Is any of this real?
Hillstorm, snap into it.
Winter barked.
We need to help my friends and get out of
here.
Friends?
Hellstorm echoed.
He squinted over at the tangle of dragons
on the edge of the dying firelight.
But winter.
I think there's a night wing over there.
Winter's guilt came slamming back through
him, along with a 2nd wave of guilt that
came from remembering how much moon had
done to help him.
She's on our side.
She's helping me rescue you.
Hillstorm, move.
He finally got his claws free and ran
over to the others.
He reached Moon's side in time to catch
Kinkaju as she slid sideways off the sand
wing.
Kibley had his teeth gritted and his eyes
closed, his legs bowed under her weight.
Kinkachu was small, but not that much
smaller than Kibley, who was wiry and
narrow shouldered.
Winter couldn't imagine how the sand wing
could even take off with her on top of
him, let alone keep up a breakneck escape
pace.
And winter couldn't do it either.
He was broader than Kibley, but not any
bigger.
But what's the alternative?
Leave her here?
He was astonished to find that he
couldn't even consider that possibility.
He wouldn't abandon her, not even to save
hailstorm.
He could feel his brother watching him
the needles of centuries of ice wing
judgment pricking along his spine.
We need someone as big as clay, Moon said
ruefully, resting Kinkajoo's head in the
crook of her shoulder and wing.
Hillstorm might be big enough.
But he's too confused, and he has no love
for rainwings, either as pyrite or as
himself.
I don't know what he might do with her
mid-flight.
If only Kibley and I could carry her
together.
Winter darted over to the trees, leaped
up, and wrenched the canopy loose from
the trunk it was bound to.
The weave of branches and vines was thick
enough to keep out rain.
If they were lucky, it would be strong
enough to hold Kinkajou.
He spread it out beside Moon, who
understood without words what he was
doing.
Awkwardly, they shifted Kinkaju onto the
makeshift stretcher, curling her tail
close around her body and tucking in her
wings.
There was no sign of life from her as
they did this, although Winter thought he
could feel a pulse in the palm of her
talons.
The pouch was still crushed in his
claws.
He needed to look at it more closely, but
not right now, and he wasn't about to
risk wearing it, after seeing what it did
to Hailstorm.
Carefully, he tucked it beside Kinkachu
snagging the chain securely around
several branches.
Kibley took one side of the canopy in his
front talons.
Winter reached for the other, but Moon
interceded.
I'll do it, she said.
You take care of your brother.
She hooked her claws in the web of
branches and nodded at Kibley.
Beating their wings together.
They lifted up into the air, wobbling and
lopsided for a moment.
Winter jumped to catch Kinkaju in case
they dropped her, but they righted
themselves and flew higher, their wings
finding the same rhythm.
They shot up into the clouds as the rain
began cascading down harder and harder.
Winter ran back over to Hailstorm.
Fly, he shouted. follow me.
Maybe I should wait here for Queen
Scarlet.
Hailstorm said uncertainly.
She could probably explain what's
happening to my head.
No, Winter shouted.
He shook his wings furiously, which did
not help dry him off at all.
She is the enemy.
Come on.
He couldn't believe Scarlet wasn't here
already.
How long could it take the nightwing to
fly back to get her?
Even with his face burned and frostbitten
maybe he'd gotten lost, unable to see.
But Scarlet still should have heard the
noise of the battle.
She could be flying down to investigate
right now.
He launched himself into the air, and to
his relief, Hailstorm only hesitated a
moment before following.
The rain smashed down on them, harder and
harder.
Winter wished it were snow instead.
He tried imagining the drops, as light
fluffy flakes of comforting snow, but it
didn't help.
Lightning flashed overhead, and he caught
a glimpse of the odd flapping shape that
was Kibley and Moon and the sagging
canopy.
They were flying west, hopefully out of
the mountains and toward the kingdom of
sand.
And beyond that, the ice kingdom.
Winter thought.
He glanced sideways at Hailstorm, now
keeping up with long, powerful strokes of
his wings.
I did it.
I found him.
I can take him home.
He looked forward again, at the dragons
winging their way over the mountain range
and felt a strange, stabbing feeling in
his chest.
Home.
Where none of my friends can go.
Where I must be.
I mean, where I can be a true ice wing
once again.
They flew without stopping for the rest
of the night.
Winter and hailstorm soon caught up to
the others, and then slowed to match
their speed.
Although hailstorm gave winter a puzzled
look as he did.
After a while, Winter moved in to take
the canopy from Moon, and she let him, a
short time after that, she took it from
Kibley, and the 3 of them traded off
turns silently for hours, saving their
breath for flying.
Hailstorm did not offer to help, but he
stayed with them, to winter's relief.
Finally, they flew out of the edge of the
storm, straight into a cool gray morning
somewhere in the borderlands between the
sky kingdom and the kingdom of sand.
The mountains were behind them, and the
sun had not yet climbed high enough to
make it past the peaks, but everything
was lit in that barely dawn, colorless
way that makes your eyes tired.
A small herd of spring box turned
graceful, antlered heads to the sky
spotted the dragons, and bounded
instantly away, their white tails
flickering as they fled south.
We can rest at the river, Kibley called.
Almost there.
Winter hefted his side of the sling
trying to adjust his aching talons.
The entire front half of his body felt
numb.
As though he had turned to stone and
someone had decided to hang a rain wing
off his petrified arms.
His head was fuzzy with exhaustion.
Soon he saw the great 5 tail river ahead
of them.
A vast green, brown, blue vein, stretching
from the desert to the delta.
According to the history schools.
This was the most disputed piece of
territory in all of Pyria, as the sky
wings and sand wings had fought over
ownership of the river for centuries.
Winter wondered if Byrne had promised it
to the Sky Wings in exchange for their
alliance in the War of Sand Wings
succession.
He wondered if it was only a matter of
time before Queen Ruby and Queen Thorn
resumed the battle that had raged for so
long.
But for now, the banks of the river were
peaceful.
Near the delta, the sand wing settlement
on the west side, had slowly merged with
the sky wing village on the east over the
last 20 years, so that now, red and
orange and sandy yellow wings dotted the
sky and the streets side by side.
A wide white stone bridge had been built
across the river. lined with shops where
dragons traded and bartered all day.
Winter knew this from reports he'd heard
in the throne room.
Icewing reconnaissance had kept a close
eye on the tentative piece that was
forged between Byrne and Scarlet, would
it last be on the war?
Where would that lead the ice wings?
The next border where the sand wings
might look for new territory.
But he had only ever flown over the great
river.
He'd only seen the growing town from a
distance.
Now, seeing it take shape ahead of them
he realized that was Kibley's
destination.
Winter had expected to stop in a clump of
trees somewhere, but the sand wing was
clearly leading them to the town itself.
Wait, he said, and Kibli immediately
circled back to take Kinkachu's stretcher
from him.
Winter shook out his talons, feeling the
blood slowly tinkling back into motion.
Where are you taking us?
Shouldn't we hide somewhere?
He gestured at the wild landscape below
them.
The sand dotted with palm trees that
stretched away south, the muddier banks
farther north, the thicker greenery near
the town in the Delta.
There was something about bringing
hailstorm into a crowded settlement that
made him nervous.
Possibility is the best place to hide.
Kibli argued.
There are 100s of dragons there, from all
the tribes these days will blend right in
and Scarlet won't dare show her face in
the town, with so many of Ruby's dragons
patrolling the streets.
Besides, Kinkaju needs a doctor.
As usual, Kibli's 9000 very good points
were impossible to counter.
Winter glanced at Kinkaju's still white
face and nodded.
The town is called possibility?
Moon asked.
Her voice was strained, but when winter
reached for her side of the canopy, she
flicked her wing at him, No, take a
longer break, she said.
I can handle it for another few minutes.
When the 2 sides merged.
Neither wanted to take the other's
original name, Kibley said.
This was about 7 years ago.
They talked and disagreed, and talked
some more, throwing around names like
hope and peace and union.
But finally, they put it to a vote, and
the majority of the citizens chose
possibility.
I like that, Moon said.
The possibility of hope and peace, but
it's not guaranteed.
They still have to work for it.
You know someone here?
Winter asked Kibley.
A lot of someone's, Kibley said.
I met practically the whole sandwing
tribe after Thorn became queen, as
everyone came to pay tribute, and to see
if they could support her as queen, which
they can, and do, of course, because she
is amazing.
Anyway, several of them were from
possibility.
I just have to find one who can help us.
They flew down to land on one of the
islands in the river as the sun clambered
over the peaks, scattering warm yellow
light that outlined the palm trees and
gold.
A hippo was planted in the mud, on the
island's shore.
It gave the dragons a resigned look as
they landed, like, fine, go ahead and eat
me.
I knew it would happen eventually.
But they were all too tired to kill
anything, and after a moment, the hippo
splashed loudly into the river and
submerged, probably congratulating itself
on its impressive stealth.
Moon climbed onto the canopy.
As soon as it was spread out on the
ground, She picked up Kinkaju's talons
trying to rub warmth into them.
I'll be back as soon as I can, Kibley
promised.
He darted off to the bridge, not far away
where merchants were already unrolling
carpets and setting out trays of food
that exhaled clouds of steam.
Winter could see Kibley in the gaps
between the stalls, pacing along the
length of the bridge and speaking to
dragons here and there.
This is weird, Hailstorm said behind
winter.
All those dragons from different tribes
just acting like it's totally normal to
be together, not as weird as you bonding
with your strange little trio, though.
Winter turned to look up at his older
brother, although it wasn't as far up as
it used to be.
Hailstorm looked so exactly like he had
the day he'd been captured.
There were no new scars, no signs of
starvation or beating, or anything winter
would have expected him to go through in
a sky wing prison.
But then, if Hailstorm hadn't been
himself all this time.
What do you remember about being
Scarlett's prisoner?
Winter asked.
Hailstorm shook his head.
I was never her prisoner, he said.
I've been a loyal soldier to her for.
I thought it was my whole life, but
now...
All my memories of being a sky wing
dragonette are fading.
I think I hatched as an ice wing.
You did, Winter said.
You're my brother, Hellstorm.
You've always been an ice wing.
Hillstorms shuddered in a big, bone
racking way.
But I know I've been fighting for Queen
Scarlet in the war, he said.
I remember bowing to her.
Worshiping her.
I fought, I killed ice wings for her.
He drew his wings in closer and clenched
his talons.
Or was it a dream?
Maybe I'm still myself, and I'm only
hallucinating memories of being a nice
wing.
With trepidation, he held out his claws
saw that they were still white, and
slammed his eyes shut.
Winter's veins felt as if they were iced
over and cracking, bits of him
splintering off inside his body.
Hailstorm looked the same, but inside, he
was nothing like the brother winter
remembered.
This lost dragon, torn in two, who had
killed some of his own tribe in service
to a queen he hated.
It was worse than all the things winter
had imagined Scarlet doing to him.
Hellstorm Focus, Winter said, flicking
his brother's tail.
If he treated him like their parents did
sharp and demanding, Maybe Hailstorm's
real personality would come back.
You are my brother Hailstorm.
You are under some kind of enchantment
but you're back.
Just forget about pyrite and be you
again.
But which me?
Hailstorm protested.
I look at that river and think, I can't
swim.
But I remember diving into dark green
oceans studded with drifting pieces of
ice.
I look at my claws and think, I'm clumsy
and useless.
But I remember winning every
competition.
I remember being at the top of the
rankings.
I feel like the air is too warm, and I
think, I can't wait to go home and roll
in snow, but I imagine being surrounded
by ice wings, and I immediately want to
kill them all to protect my queen.
He made a noise of despair and pressed
his forehead, as though he were trying to
keep his brains from spilling out.
Winter exchanged a glance with Moon, who
looked as horrified as he felt.
Was it even safe to bring hailstorm back
to the ice kingdom?
Had he been too badly damaged by living
as a sky wing for so long?
Would he ever truly be Winter's brother
again?
Chapter 17.
A trio of red and orange dragons flew
overhead.
The wind from their wings sending ripples
across the river to wash up on the shore
near winter's talons.
Hailstorm squinted up at the sky, as if
he was thinking about following the sky
wings.
You just need some time, Winter said
although it sounded stupid as soon as it
escaped his mouth.
The longer your hailstorm again, the more
you'll feel like yourself.
At least he hoped that was true.
He looked down at his claws, and picked a
piece of wet reed off one of them.
How long were you like that?
Trapped in the body of a sky wing?
I have no idea, Hailstorm answered.
The Skywing Patrol took me straight to
Queen Scarlet, I think.
And then there was a yellowy orange
dragon who did something to me.
Wait.
He dropped his talons and frowned at
them.
She looked like me.
How did I do that to myself?
I bet pyrite is a kind of mask, Moon
offered.
She was still watching Kinkaju, so she
didn't see the look of repugnance that
hailstorm shot at her, but winter did.
Not a real dragon at all.
I bet the other dragon was wearing the
pyrite mask when you saw her, and he or
she put it on you.
She looked up at winter.
Maybe it was that night wing, Scarlet's
ally.
Scarlet had a lot of confused thoughts
about what he could do for her, changing
dragons into other dragons.
I couldn't understand them because I had
no idea this was even possible.
Your sand wing is coming back.
Hillstorm said, nodding at the river
where Kibley was swooping toward them.
Directions to a doctor, he said as he
landed, brandishing a small scribbled
map.
Meerkat is going to fly ahead and tell
her we're coming.
He took the side of the canopy again as
Moon climbed off it.
Winter took the other side, checking as
he did that the necklace and pouch were
still securely tucked beside Kinkaju.
They were the key to whatever had been
done to Hailstorm, they must be animus
touched.
So the night wing is an animus, but
pyrite wasn't.
The magic he'd felt when he touched her
must have been the spell on Hellstorm.
Had he felt anything like that from the
night wing?
It was hard to remember in the confusion
of the fight, but he thought so.
Their little group got a few odd looks as
they flew through the town, but not as
many as winter would have expected.
Most dragons were still asleep, and those
that were up were busy getting ready for
the day.
The smell of bread, baking, and meat
cooking wove through the streets, and
winter could hear the tink, tink of small
hammers, the clattering of mugs, and
voices calling to each other within the
walls of the houses, some kind of
stringed instrument greeted the sunrise
with musical scales, and hints of half
played melodies.
They were on the west side of the river
now, originally on the sand wing side, but
winter wouldn't have been able to guess
which tribe had settled here first.
The structures were spread out in a
haphazard, lazy way, some with gardens
planted around them, some pressed up
against a crowded row of other buildings
some were magnificent towers that could
have fit into any queen's palace.
Others were barely more than mud huts, he
saw cascading fountains, and several
bejeweled statues of stone dragons.
He also saw a discarded, bloated
crocodile carcass gathering flies, and a
brackish puddle with a red tint that
looked like blood.
Not ice wing blood, at least.
What a strange place, Winter said to
Kibley.
There's no order to it at all.
Not like the Ice Kingdom, where your
ranking on your 7th hatching day
determined where you would be assigned to
live.
The highest ranked lived within the walls
of the palace itself, like winter's
parents.
After you turned 7, you were shifted to
the adult rankings, where if you worked
hard enough and moved high enough, you
might be able to request a transfer
closer to the center of power.
Let me guess, all your igloos look
exactly the same.
Kibley asked.
We don't live in igloos, Winter said
looking down his nose at Kibley, not
aristocrats, anyway.
Oh, that's right.
Kibley said.
Didn't you say you're related to someone
important?
Very funny, Winter said.
Yes.
Hellstorm interjected at the same time, a
little too loudly.
We're Queen Glacier's nephews.
Everyone knows that.
He lifted his chin and regarded a pair of
passing sand wings with enormous
disdain.
To his credit, Kibli managed not to laugh
although Winter was glad that Hailstorm
didn't notice the mischievous glint in
the sand wing's eyes.
So, you're not igloos don't look like
this?
Kibley asked.
Our cities are all very carefully planned
Winter explained.
It's always clear where the power and the
wealth is, and who has it, and who can
influence it.
Hailstorm was nodding, which winter found
reassuring.
Maybe his ice wing memories were taking
over.
Order and clarity are built into our
architecture, Winter said.
The only thing that seems to be built
into the architecture here is absurdity.
I love it.
Kibley inhaled deeply.
It smells like freedom.
Freedom to be whoever you want to be, not
who someone tells you you have to be.
It smells like rotting water buffalo.
Winter said.
He couldn't help but notice the way moon
was looking at Kibley, as if what he said
made more sense than what winter had
said.
Was that what she wanted?
Freedom at the expense of order?
Didn't everyone want to know where they
fit into the world?
A few young dragonets burst past them
laughing. 2 sky wings, 2 sand wings, and
a mud wing, and veered toward a bigger
building with pictures of tumbling
acrobatic dragons painted on the side.
Does Sonny know about this place?
Moon asked Kibley, her eyes on the group
of dragonettes.
It seems like her dream come true.
Well, it's not quite as utopian as that
Kibley said.
He pointed to an alley where someone had
scrawled, desert munchers go home, in red
paint.
A few doors down, a mudwing sat on a
corner with one leg wrapped in bandages
and his wings drooping.
A hollow coconut half shell sat next to
him, into which someone had dropped a
pitiful couple of fried grasshoppers.
But it's the right idea, Moon said.
Dragons from different tribes living
together and getting along, for the most
part, That's true, and Sonny does know
about it.
Kibley said, checking his map.
But I don't think she's been here yet.
Look, that's the house.
He nodded at a compact structure with
walls of whitewashed bricks and a roof of
dried reeds.
A small green flag stuck out of the wall
by the door, with the word doctor, neatly
printed on it.
A young, handsome sandwing came bustling
out of the door as they approached, and
reached for winter's side of the
stretcher.
Hello, I'm your cat.
He said with a friendly nod.
Wait out here.
We are staying with Kinkaju, Winter
insisted.
The Sandwing shook his head.
Sorry, there's not enough room in there
for 7 dragons.
Mayfly is very strict about her space.
Extra visitors can wait in the garden.
He pointed to the back of the house, where
a riot of greenery was trying to vault
over the roof.
Mayfly?
Winter said.
He kept his grip on the canopy, his claws
tingling suspiciously.
Your doctor is a mudwing?
The best impossibility, said meerkat.
Winter would not have thought there were
any mud wings smart enough to be doctors
let alone the best in town.
Maybe there wasn't much competition.
Or maybe this was the wrong place to
bring Kinkachu.
One of you can come in with her, meerkat
said.
He reached out again, and this time
Winter relinquished his grasp.
What choice did they have?
Where else could they take her?
But he reached in and fished out the
animus touched pouch first.
He wasn't letting magic like that out of
his sight.
Kibli opened his wings to let Moon take
the stretcher from him, and she
disappeared into the house with meerkat
and the unconscious dragonette.
There was an awkward pause.
Winter, hailstorm and Kibley, glanced
sideways at one another, shuffled their
wings, and squinted thoughtfully at the
sky.
I'll be in the garden.
Kibley said finally, edging away.
Hailstorm stomped over to stick his nose
in the neighbor's pond, muttering
something like, don't even know why I'm
here.
This seemed like a good time for pacing.
Which winter did, until he realized he
had accidentally trampled some bright
yellow flowers poking up around the base
of the house, he stepped back and tried
to keep still.
Maybe he could see something through the
windows.
He explored around the side of the house
until he found a window open and large
enough to poke his head in.
From here, he could see a round, sunlit
room, clean and uncluttered.
The only furniture was a large, plain
white table in the middle, and a few
shelves on one wall that held neatly
labeled bottles and jars.
Kingaju was lying on her back on the
table, looking smaller than ever, with
her wings flopping helplessly to either
side.
A brown dragon with a wide, flat face was
examining Kinkachu.
Her talons moved professionally over the
dragonette, checking her wings, her bones
her head.
She paused for a moment, glancing from
Kinkaju's tail to her snout.
Is this a rain wing?
Yes, Moon answered.
Her name is Kinkaju.
Interesting, said the doctor.
Never seen one before.
The white scales made me think I swing at
first.
She looks nothing like an ice wing.
Hailstorm exploded with great indignation
poking his nose over Winter's shoulder
and making winter jump.
Get out of my window.
The doctor snapped with a hiss.
Stop blocking the light.
Shoo!
She flapped her wings, taking a few
limping steps in their direction.
Winter realized that the doctor's back
left leg and half her tail were covered
in unmistakable frost breath scars
blackened and blistered, with 2 claws
missing.
She'd been in a battle with ice wings.
Within the last year, if he had to guess
which meant she probably didn't feel too
kindly toward ice dragons in general.
Sorry, sorry, he said, pushing Hailstorm
back.
Go sit in the garden, she barked, slamming
a jar down on the windowsill.
The smelled like something was stabbing
his eyeballs.
Garden, yes, absolutely, Winter said.
He grabbed Hailstorm's tail and tugged
him toward the back of the house.
Winter didn't have a lot of experience
with gardens, but he suspected they
didn't usually go up quite as much as
this one did.
Seven trees ringed the small plot of land
each of them exploding with different
fruits and flowers.
Vines scaled the back wall of the house
covered in blue and gold flowers, and
various ferns and shrubs took up almost
all the ground space.
In the center of everything, there was a
tower that looked as if it was made of
glass, with overflowing flower pots and
seed trays on each level, piled up to the
height of the trees.
Kibley was flying around the top of the
greenhouse tower, studying a plant that
looked like dark purple dragon tongues
but he flew down when he saw them step
through the trees.
Kind of a great idea, he said, flipping
one wing at the ascending levels of glass
I'll have to remember to tell Thorn.
Excuse me, Hailstorm said bossily to
Winter, ignoring Kibley.
Why are we obeying a mud wings orders?
This sounded so much like his real
brother that Winter's spirits rose.
Until Hailstorm added, they report to Sky
Wings, not the other way around.
Kibley regarded him thoughtfully.
He's really confused, isn't he?
You think, Winter growled.
Imagine being a totally different dragon
all of a sudden, Kibley said, with
completely different memories.
That would be very unsettling.
Oh, really?
Winter said.
Do you think that's what's wrong?
What a useful insight.
I hadn't thought of that.
All right, grouchy.
Kibley said, giving Winter an
affectionately exasperated glare.
I'm just expressing sympathy over here.
I realize that's an unfamiliar concept
for ice wings.
I don't need a sandwing feeling sorry for
me.
Hailstorm said stiffly.
It seems like an awfully complicated
spell, though, Kibley said after a
moment.
What kind of animus would agree to waste
his power, and lose bits of his soul, just
to hide a prisoner?
Why wouldn't Queen Scarlet demand
something more dramatic?
Come to think of it?
If she has an animus nightwing, why isn't
she queen again right now?
She could use him to get rid of Ruby in a
1000000 different ways.
Winter had no idea.
It didn't make sense to him either.
He opened his talons and looked down at
the crumpled pouch and chain that
Hailstorm had been wearing.
At the side of them, hailstorms shuddered
violently.
I'm supposed to wear that, he cried.
It can't ever come off.
I'll die if it does.
He stopped, felt his throat for a moment
and covered his eyes with a groan.
All right, I hear myself.
What's in there?
Kibley asked. leaning closer to study the
necklace Winter carefully picked at the
knot that tied the pouch closed.
He wished his claws were a little
smaller.
The knot was very tight.
Whatever was in here was never meant to
come out.
Finally, he was able to hook one claw
under the knot and slice it loose.
The rope fell away, and he poked the
pouch open, shaking the contents into his
other palm.
A small folded piece of paper fell out
crumpled around the corners.
He peeked into the pouch and shook it a
bit more.
There was nothing else in there.
Careful, Kibley said, his talons
twitching toward the paper.
Don't rip it.
Unfolding the paper was an even more
delicate operation than opening the pouch
but at last it was done, revealing words
scribbled in a dark red ink.
Some of them were faded, or caught in the
wrinkles and hard to read.
Winter found a patch of sunlight, where
you could smooth it out on a flat rock.
What does it say?
Kibley asked.
Hailstorm was watching curiously now
too.
Maybe if he heard the spell, he'd realize
that it wasn't real and be able to stop
thinking about pyrite.
Okay, Winter said, puzzling over the
note.
I think it says, enchant this paper so
that when any dragon wears it in the form
of a necklace, he or she shall fully
become a female sky wing named Pyrite
with the following conditions.
One, completely loyal to Queen Scarlet
and the Skywing tribe.
Two, insecure and weak.
3.
No memory of his or her former identity.
Four, compelled to wear this necklace at
all times with life or death urgency.
The writing was cramped and filled every
inch of the paper, front and back.
Winter suspected that everything from
with the following conditions on, had
been added after the 1st part, as though
it had been tailored specifically, and
spitefully for Hailstorm.
Wow, Kibley said, that is weird.
I thought animus dragons just thought
their spells to enchant whatever they
wanted to animus touch.
I didn't know they ever wrote them down.
He leaned over to tap the edges of the
scrap of paper.
This looks like it was torn from a larger
piece.
Maybe a scroll, since it still wants to
roll that way.
Did you hear that?
Winter asked, turning toward Hailstorm.
See?
Pyrite was just a spell.
Now you're your own real self.
It was staggering to him how unconvinced
hailstorm looked.
Here was evidence. written proof that his
life as pyrite was all a lie.
And yet, Hailstorm kept sneaking looks at
his claws, as if they might change back
at any moment.
Winter folded the paper back up and
crammed it into the pouch.
He took the chain, threaded it through
the pouch strings again, and tied a knot
with a broken links.
What are you doing?
Kibley asked, in a tone of voice that
suggested he knew perfectly well what
winter was doing?
I sense a terrible idea coming on.
I need to see what it feels like, Winter
said.
Well, you're here to.
Well, I'm not alone.
But it'll turn you into pyrite, who, let's
face it, is no great loss to the world.
I mean, it's a tough call, but I'm pretty
sure we'd rather have you.
Reasonably sure.
Like 80% sure.
Winter whacked one of Kibley's wings with
his own.
This isn't a joke.
I want to know how it works.
I want to know what hailstorm felt like
being her.
I think, well, maybe it'll help me
understand what he's going through.
I get it, Kibley said, nodding slowly.
It just seems like a risk.
I mean, look at him.
What if it messes you up the same way?
That's not going to happen, Winter said.
I'll only wear it for a moment.
But that's what you're here for.
To take the necklace off me, because I
won't be able to do it myself.
Don't let me be a Skywing for more than 3
minutes, all right?
I don't want her in my head any longer
than that.
Hang on, let me see the paper.
Khibli held out its talons and winter
passed over the necklace.
The sandwing fished the scrap out of the
pouch and read it over, and then, before
winter realized what he was doing, Kibli
carefully tore a tiny peas off the
bottom.
What did you just do?
Winter demanded, flaring his wings.
I ripped off number four, Kibley said.
The part about needing to wear the
necklace all the time.
Let's see if that makes it possible for
you to take it off yourself.
He stuffed the spell back into the
pouch.
Winter accepted the necklace back
disgruntled.
It hadn't even occurred to him to try
changing the spell.
What if it didn't work now?
He realized, though, that he wasn't
really upset.
A large part of him didn't expect the
spell to work on him anyway.
Even with a high right mask on, as Moon
had called it, he'd still be winter
underneath.
All right, he said, taking a deep
breath.
Here we go.
He dropped the necklace over his head.
Chapter 18.
Whoa.
Where am I?
Pyrite looked around blinking.
Was this a garden?
Why did everything smell like peaches and
the ocean?
Hadn't she been in the mountains just a
minute ago?
At night?
Her brain was so useless.
There were so many things she couldn't
remember, because she wasn't any good at
anything. 3 moons.
It was awful being so pathetic.
What just happened?
she asked, turning in a lumbering
circle.
There go my stupid talons, getting in my
way as usual.
I wish I weren't so clumsy and useless.
The sand wing was standing nearby
watching her in a super weird way.
Did we find Queen Scarlet?
She asked.
A surge of powerful emotion rolled
through her scales, the queen, her most
wondrous majesty, Queen Scarlet always
knew what to do.
She was such an amazing dragon.
Pyrite missed her awfully.
When she'd lived in the Sky Palace, she'd
found a way to see the queen every day
even if it was just from a distance.
I'm glad I'm a Sky Wing.
She looked up at the clouds, streaked
with pink and gold in a blue sky.
She could be soaring up there, her wings
fully extended, diving and spinning like
she used to with the other Skywing
dragonettes.
They were freer than any other tribe, more
loyal to one another and more
independent.
Queen Scarlet trusted them to make
decisions in battle without her.
They were the smartest, fastest dragons
in all of Pyria.
I am completely loyal to Queen Scarlet.
One day she would see her queen again.
And then everything would be all right.
It would feel like coming home.
It would feel like flying.
Pirate.
The sand wing said slowly.
What was his name again?
How do you feel?
Oh, fine, she said.
Her memory was a little fuzzy, but that
wasn't worth mentioning.
Where are the other three?
Do you remember anything about winter?
he asked.
You mean like that he's an enormous
grump?
Pyrite said.
She saw silvery scales moving out of the
corner of her eye and turned, but it was
a different ice wing, bigger than winter
staring at her.
What was his problem?
He looked as if she was his mother back
from the dead or something, like he knew
her.
Although she was sure she'd never seen
him before.
Eee, ugh.
Ice Wings.
Can I look at your necklace?
The Sandwing asked.
Pyrite glanced down and realized she had
some kind of pouch on a chain around her
neck.
Huh, she said.
Sure, I guess.
As she reached for it, She felt a twinge
of, should I do this?
And then she was lifting it over her neck
and then she was gone.
Winter dropped the necklace as if it were
made of lava and leaped away from it.
Yah!
He shouted.
He clawed at his head.
Get her out.
Winter, it's over, Kibley called, catching
his talons.
You're you again.
She's not real.
But winter could still feel pyrites
scraping banal thoughts, like a damp
mildew lingering around his mind.
No wonder a hailstorm was so disturbed.
Pyrite thinking was not just different
from his own personality, but it had an
insidious dullness to it that left a
miasma after only a few minutes.
He couldn't imagine living with it for 2
entire years, and then trying to shake it
all off.
Except for the part about being a Skywing
loyal to Scarlet, that part was crystal
clear in a shiny way that was equally
horrible.
Winter had known, with a logical part of
his mind, that other dragons were loyal
to their own tribes, but obviously they
were wrong.
Ice Wings were the greatest tribe in
Pyria, and that was a fact.
Except now he had this memory of
believing the same thing about Skywings
and believing it with all his heart.
Was that really how Skywings felt?
And sea wings and rain wings?
and even night wings?
He did not want to try turning into any
other dragons to find out.
He turned to pick up the pouch again
perhaps to destroy it, to rip the scroll
and pyrites very existence into tiny
shreds, and found hailstorm reaching for
it.
No, Winter shouted, snatching it out of
his grasp.
Hillstorm, don't even touch it.
Maybe I should change back, Hellstorm
said.
His face twisting, as though crocodiles
might come crawling out of it.
At least when I'm pyrite.
I only have one set of memories, right?
That's what the scroll said.
And I was happy as a sky wing.
It was easier than being a nice wing.
No rankings, no one comparing me to
everyone else all the time.
No mother and father expecting me to be
perfect.
And I had fire.
Fire was amazing.
Winter, please, let me change back.
That is completely insane.
Winter said.
He tried to make his voice as cutting as
their mother's.
When you're fully yourself again.
You'll recognize that there is nothing
preferable about being a sky wing.
No one would ever choose to be anything
but an ice wing.
Kibley cleared his throat significantly
and Winter shot him a glare.
The problem was, he felt it now, not the
desire to be pyrite, but the appeal of
being a sky wing.
He couldn't let hailstorm see that
though.
He needed to be strong so that hailstorm
could be too.
You will never be pyrite again, Winter
said.
Get that through your frozen head.
Hailstorm growled furiously, and for a
moment Winter wondered if he would
actually attack his brother to get the
necklace back.
But finally, hailstorm spun on his heels
and marched to the far end of the garden
where the trees gave way to a street that
was starting to be crowded with dragons
and rolling carts.
Good speech, Kibley said.
All kind of mean, but in a convincing
way.
I need to be alone for a moment, winter
said.
Kibli raised his wings and stepped back
with a little bow of acknowledgment.
Winter needed to straighten out his own
brain.
He'd wanted to step into pyrite talons so
he could understand hailstorm, but he
didn't want to understand him this well.
He sat down under a fig tree and closed
his eyes, taking deep breaths.
I am Winter the Ice Wing.
I have always been an ice wing.
Slowly, the pyriteness began to clear.
I am Winter the Ice Wing.
I am loyal to Queen Glacier.
I will reach the top of the rankings one
day.
What would life have been like as a
skywing?
Would he really have loved the tribe of
Sky Dragons that much?
I am Winter the Ice Wing.
Be strong, be vigilant, strike first
trust nobody.
His father's mantra didn't quite sit
right in his mind anymore, but that
wasn't because of pyrite.
It was because of Kibli and Kinkaju, and
most of all, Moon.
As he thought of her, he heard a door
close, and opened his eyes to see her
emerging from the back of the doctor's
house.
I am Winter, the ice wing.
I do not make friends with dragons from
other tribes.
I am not in love with a dragon.
I am sworn to hate.
Is Kinkaju all right?
Kibley asked Moon.
Winter stood up and went over to join
them.
He glanced over at his brother as he did
and saw him standing under a tree with
round orange fruit, banging his head on
the trunk.
Winter sighed.
Moon shook her head, curling her tail
around her talons.
She has a skull fracture, and 3 or 4
broken ribs.
She said.
She sounded as though she was trying to
imitate the doctor's professional
delivery, but her voice wavered as she
spoke.
Also, a hairline break near one elbow, and
bruising all along her spine and left
side.
The doctor says she needs to stay
completely still for probably a month
maybe longer.
Is she awake?
Winter asked.
No.
Moon ducked her head, shaking back
tears.
The.
The doctor doesn't know when Kinkachu
might wake up.
Mayfly stuck her snout out one of the
back windows and beckoned to moon.
I need your authorization on this, she
said.
Brandishing a small scroll and an ink
pot.
To have her transferred to the clinic
they'll take care of her, although
they'll want to know what really happened
to her.
I told you, Moon said, with a hint of
exasperation.
A dragon attacked her.
Are you sure?
the doctor asked.
She wasn't hit by an avalanche, or thrown
off a cliff, or trampled by a herd of
hippos?
That really happened to a patient of mine
once?
There's no shame in admitting it.
Hippos can happen to anybody.
Just a dragon. knocking her into a tree
Moon said firmly.
She took the scroll and ink pot, dipped
her claw into the black ink, and signed
her name.
I promise.
I saw it too, Winter agreed.
He was really big.
Kibley offered.
With Super Dragon strength, Mayfly
muttered skeptically.
She took the scroll back from Moon and
stomped back inside.
Moon looked around, then carefully set
the ink pot on the windowsill.
Oh, good, Kibley said.
So our new mystery nightwing friend has
inexplicable animus powers and unusual
strength.
Super.
Also, now he hates us.
Don't forget, Winter added.
But you saw what we did to his face.
Moon said.
Between my fire and your frost breath.
He's probably much less dangerous now.
The creeping spider legs feeling under
Winter's scales suggested otherwise.
In his experience, no good could come of
adding vengeance to a dragon's list of
reasons to get up in the morning.
Eagle!
Hailstorm shouted suddenly, sending a
jolt of alarm through winter.
He rolled around to see his brother at
the back gate, craning his neck to see
over a sea wing pulling a fish laden
cart.
Eagle!
Hailstrong called again, his voice full
of excitement.
Eagle, over here.
Uh-oh, Kibley muttered.
Winter bolted over to his brother's side
as a large sky wing, the color of raw
tuna, shouldered his way through the
crowd and stared down at them.
Two more burly sky wings stepped up
behind him, glowering.
How do you know my name?
The Sky Wing demanded.
Who are you?
I'm Hailstorm faltered, but don't you, I'm
we fought together under General Ruby.
She's queen, Ruby, now, Eagle snapped, and
I don't remember fighting any ice wings
and leaving them alive.
He eyed hailstorm up and down.
I suppose if I did, that's a mistake that
could be corrected.
But how did he know your name?
asked one of the other Skywings.
Right.
Eagles said, his eyes narrowing to
slits.
Explain that, whale leader.
He doesn't?
Winter started.
But Eagle growled low in his throat
cutting him off.
Let the lizard speak.
Hailstorm stammered for a minute and
finally mumbled, I, I, I thought we were
friends.
He rubbed his eyes miserably.
The 2 flanking sky wings looked
incredulous.
Eagles swelled with fury.
What?
he roared.
He lashed out, reaching over the gate, and
grabbed hailstorm by the throat.
How dare you?
I would never be friends with an ice
wing.
Is this a joke?
Did someone pay you to make a fool out of
me?
He didn't mean it.
Winter yelled, trying to pull eagle's
talons off his brother.
He's just confused.
Kibley darted up on Hailstorm's other
side and grabbed the Sky Wing too.
He was hit on the head.
Kibley explained quickly, a war injury.
His memory is all messed up.
Please don't hurt him.
Winter cried.
Hillstorm's face was turning bluer than
usual.
Drop that ice wing right now, said
another voice behind Winter.
He turned and saw meerkat standing in the
garden beside Moon, arching his venomous
tail menacingly.
I order you by the authority of the
enclave.
To winter's surprise, Eagle immediately
let go of Hailstorm.
The ice wing collapsed back against the
tree, gasping for breath.
Sorry, the Sky Wing said to Meerkat, all
the rage gone from his voice.
Didn't realize he was with you, meerkat.
He took a step back.
He was saying some mighty stupid things
that's all.
Head injury.
Kibley said again.
Winter crouched beside his brother, but
Hailstorm pushed him away.
Oh, another wounded veteran, Eagles
said.
All 3 Skywings were nodding.
I've seen plenty of those.
Hope he recovers.
He jerked his chin at winter, then turned
and shoved his way back into the throng
half of whom had stopped to stare at the
fight.
Moving right along, Mirkat said, waving
at the audience until they all started
moving again.
It was just a mistake, Hillstorm, Winter
said to his brother, in a low voice.
You've only been out from under the spell
for a few hours.
Give it some time.
You'll forget all about pyrite once
you're surrounded by ice wings again.
Hailstorm shook his head.
Winter didn't know if that meant
disagreement or despair.
Winter.
Hailstorm croaked softly.
Winter leaned closer to here, and
Hailstorm turned hopeless blue eyes up
toward him.
Winter.
I want to go home.
Chapter 19.
You're leaving now?
Moon asked, dismayed.
I have to get him back to the Ice Kingdom
Winter said, glancing over Tailstorm.
His brother was sitting at the base of
the greenhouse tower, with his wings
folded close around him, and his face
hidden.
I feel like he won't be safe until he's
with our tribe again.
And then he'll remember he's really an
ice wing.
I hope.
But Kinkaju.
Moon started then trailed off.
There's nothing I can do for her.
Winter pointed out.
Right?
We're just waiting until she wakes up.
Moon looked down at her clause, leaving
the if she wakes up, unsaid.
None of you can come with us to the Ice
Kingdom anyway, Winter said.
You should go back to Jade Mountain.
No way.
Kibley said, and Moon glanced up at him
in surprise.
We have to find the lost city of night.
Remember the Thunder and Eyes.
Earth shaking, ground being scorched, all
of that?
I don't know about you, but I'm in favor
of that prophecy, not coming true.
Now that we've found hailstorm.
I say it's time to get on top of the
whole saving the world thing.
That's what I was going to do, Moon
cried.
I've been having these awful nightmares
every night.
I mean, worse than ever.
I've got to figure out the prophecy.
But I wasn't sure if anyone would want to
come with me.
Um, me.
Kibble said, waving a wing at himself as
though that was as obvious as the sun.
Sign me up.
Moon turned hopeful eyes toward winter.
Maybe after you take hailstorm home?
she asked.
Then you could come back, and we could
all look for the lost city of night
together.
He wanted to say yes.
He wasn't even sure which reason was
strongest.
Was it because he believed the world
needed saving?
Because he wanted to protect Jade
Mountain?
Or because he couldn't stand the idea of
Moon and Kibley searching Pyria, alone
together.
I, I can't, he said.
Ah, that was why.
Because he hadn't wanted to watch her
face do this, this crumbling into
disappointment.
But there were 50,000 reasons why he
couldn't say yes.
Reasons like Moon's safety of Winter's
parents found out about her.
Reasons like needing to prove his loyalty
to the ice wings and struggle back into
the rankings.
Reasons like his own sanity.
I can't.
He said again.
All at once, he was aware of hailstorms
standing behind him, listening, hailstorms
blue eyes, watching Winter's next move.
Listen, get this into your head.
I'm an ice wing.
He hated that it came out sounding almost
like a question.
He wasn't like Hillstorm.
He knew who he was.
I'm an ice wing, he said again, firmly.
That means I belong in the Ice Kingdom
with my own tribe.
I should never have gone to Jade
Mountain.
This prophecy.
If it's even real, has nothing to do with
me, and I should have nothing to do with
you.
But, Moon said, I thought, She reached
toward him, her dark eyes puzzled and
hurt.
What?
That we were friends?
Winter spat, shoving her talons away.
We can't be friends.
We can't be anything.
We can never, never be what I dream of us
being.
You're my sworn enemy, Nightwing.
I never asked for you to follow me
around.
Hey, Kibley said.
He sounded genuinely angry.
Don't talk to her like that.
She helped you find your brother, and she
risked her life to do it.
What is wrong with you?
It's all right, Moon said, brushing
Kibley's wing with her own.
Her eyes flickered to Hillstorm, close
behind winter.
He's striking first.
That's all.
Winter.
I believe that you're one of the best
bravest, truest dragons in Pyria.
I'll never be your enemy, no matter what
you say.
But go ahead and leave, if that's what
you want.
It's not what I want.
His chest felt as if it might burst.
Spilling shattered ice everywhere.
It's how things have to be.
We'll wait for you, Kibley said.
Right here.
In case you change your mind and realize
that stopping a big world destroying
prophecy is what you were hatched to do.
Don't bother, Winter said, hoping his
cold snarl was still as intimidating as
he'd once been able to make it.
One week, Moon said, glancing at Kibley
for confirmation.
We can wait one week, and then we're
leaving.
Then you're idiots.
I don't care.
Winter nearly shouted.
Why did it have to be so impossible?
How could they still even want to be his
friends when he was pushing them away so
hard?
Three moons.
Leave me alone.
He turned to Hailstorm.
Let's go.
As he spread his wings and leaped into
the sky.
Kibli called, don't be a stranger.
And he thought he heard Moon say, We'll
miss you.
Hailstorm soared into the lead, his wings
glittering silver and white, with
reflections of rose from the setting sun
ahead of them.
He grinned over his shoulder at his
little brother.
The 1st happy expression Winter had seen
from him all day.
Winter forced himself to look forward.
He would not look back at the garden.
At the black and pale yellow dragons
watching him go.
He would not admit to himself that he
would miss them too.
He would ice over the hole in his chest
the way he'd cleared out the pyrite
memories, ahead were his parents and
Queen Glacier, and he would need to be
perfect again before he faced them.
The Ice Kingdom was waiting for him.
Part three.
Beneath the ice.
Chapter 20.
Winter and Hailstorm reached the southern
border of the Ice Kingdom the next day at
Twilight.
A few stars and one claw shaped moon were
already glimmering in the violet sky.
Winter could see the great ice cliff that
marked the border, stretching from one
horizon to the other in a sheer unbroken
line.
Hillstorm squinted at it as they
approached.
Is that a wall?
He asked.
What's the point of that?
A wall can't keep out dragons.
You don't remember the great ice cliff?
Winter replied, startled.
It's probably our oldest animus gift.
Hailstorm shrugged.
Seems like a waste of magic, he said.
We're going to fly right over it.
Right, because we're ice wings.
Winter said.
But if we were from any other tribe, the
great ice cliff would shoot icicle spears
at us and most likely kill us.
It's secret defense of magic.
The other tribes don't know about it.
Usually no one else ventures this far
north anyway.
But if they did, they'd get a chilly
pointy surprise.
Hailstorm balked in midair.
What if it doesn't let me pass?
he cried.
It will, Winter said, a little
irritated.
You're an ice wing hillstorm.
The wall will recognize that, and so will
everyone else.
His brother did not look convinced, but
some of his old bravados seem to be
coming back, even if he was scared, he
was clearly determined not to show it.
Of course, the wall did not react as they
flew over it.
Winter remembered the last time it had
gone off, a year and a half ago when one
of Blaze's sand wings had apparently
decided to wrap herself in a few blankets
and explore the mysterious ice kingdom.
They'd found her, what must have been
days later, on the north side of the wall
she was half buried in a snowdrift, with
a spear through her heart.
Her sky colored blankets frozen to her
scales, so at 1st they thought she was a
sea wing.
Other than that, the wall had been quiet
for winter's entire life.
The other tribes didn't know about it, but
they did know about the subzero
temperatures and freezing wind in the ice
kingdom.
Even during the war of Sandwing
succession, no one had dared send troops
into their territory.
It would have been a complete massacre if
they had.
Which made Winter think about the animus
who had built and enchanted the wall
1000s of years ago, the gift of defense
it was called.
Was it worth it at the time?
Were there more attacks on the kingdom
back then?
Were there dragons from other tribes who
had figured out how to survive in the
Arctic cold long enough to stage an
invasion, at least?
Or perhaps the animus was looking forward
not back.
Perhaps he anticipated a day when some
other tribe's animus might craft heat
generating armor that could carry
soldiers into the farthest reaches of the
north.
But even if someone did that, why conquer
a land you couldn't possibly live in?
In any case, if winter were an animus
dragon, building a wall like that would
not have been his major contribution to
ice wing society.
The Ice Kingdom didn't need defensive
magic.
What it needed now was something to help
them conquer other tribes.
If they still had Animas Dragons, they
could have won the War of Sandwing
succession in no time at all.
And then all the territory Blaze had
promised Queen Glacier would now be
theirs.
More important, no ice wing soldiers
would have had to die.
And Hailstorm would never have ended up
as Scarlet's prisoner.
It all goes back to Faux Slayer.
If she had never stolen Prince Arctic
imagine how powerful we could be now.
We'd have another 2000 years of animus
gifts.
We could have been the rulers of all
Pyria.
We definitely have something that helped
us in battle.
Exploding snowballs that kill every
dragon they touch, or maps that tell us
exactly where all our enemies are, or
diamonds that hypnotize every other queen
into surrendering to us.
When he thought of the ice wing lives
lost in the war, and for nothing in the
end, he wished he could climb back
through time, find an animus ice wing
maybe the one who wasted her gift on
defense, and force her to make something
that would wipe out all the night wings
at once.
Uneasiness whispered through his bones at
that thought.
I thought he'd had a 100 times before.
But now he could picture the night wings
in their ramshackle rainforest village
trying to rebuild after the horrors of
the volcano.
He could remember the shivering
dragonette and the wingery. and the
protective parents he'd seen, including
Moon's mother.
It was actually completely terrifying to
think that any dragon with magic could
easily wipe out an entire tribe with just
one enchanted object.
It was even more terrifying to realize
that your own tribe no longer had that
magic.
But your worst enemies did.
Why hadn't the Night Wings used Anna's
power to destroy the ice wings long ago?
Did they have so little control over
their animus dragons?
Or so little vision of what their stolen
magic could do?
He worried around these questions as he
and Hailstorm flew over the snowy
landscape, dotted with sheer cliffs, and
pure blue lakes, and the sky grew darker
and darker.
A couple of white owls swept past below
them, pale flickers, like moths in the
moonlight, screeching to each other, a
herd of shaggy caribou surrounded one of
the lakes, stamping nervously as the
dragons passed overhead.
Winter thought about grabbing one to eat
but they'd already stopped earlier that
day to hunt, and now, with home so close
he just wanted to get there and face the
queen already.
It was close to midnight when they saw
the lights of Queen Glacier's Palace
ahead of them, shimmering blue, green
silver, like captured starlight.
The dark ocean acted as a mirror, sending
the same lights dancing in blurred
mimicry around the base of the palace.
A galaxy of smaller lights spiraled out
in 5 curved arms from the palace
illuminating the dwellings of lower
aristocrats.
The training schools that were open all
night, and the shimmering ice sculpture
gardens.
Winter heard hailstorm catch his breath
beside him.
It's beautiful, he murmured.
I'd forgotten.
Wait until you see it up close, Winter
said.
His chest swelling with pride.
The ice kingdom was beautiful, without
question.
He wished he could show it to Moon.
But she would never get past the great
ice cliff alive, and his parents would
send her to the bottom of a frozen lake
if she did.
They swooped down to land at the grand
entrance of the palace, a set of crystal
studded gates about halfway up the
central keep.
The gates were carved in the shape of
giant dragon wings, making the small ice
sculptures of dragons and wings and
talons that topped all the columns and
vinials.
Although it was possible to fly over the
palace walls straight into the interior
courtyards, it was considered gauche, and
therefore career suicide.
According to protocol, visitors waited at
the gates to be admitted.
Queen Glacier's Astonishing Palace was
also animus touched, the gift of splendor
designed, built, and enchanted centuries
ago by a pair of animus twins, with magic
that ensured its walls of ice would never
melt, never crack, and never be harmed by
outside attack.
It soared miles into the air, with towers
and balconies and spires that pierced the
clouds.
There were so many rooms on so many
levels that Winter, who had lived there
his entire life, had never seen them
all.
A low ranked guard stood outside the
gates. wearing the chain of 5 concentric
silver circles that marked him as 5th
circle in the adult rankings.
His posture and form were perfect
although his eyelids were drooping
dangerously.
He snapped to attention as they landed
stamping his spear twice.
Nephews of Queen Glacier, Winter
announced, although he was sure the guard
must recognize them.
He hesitated.
I swing etiquette demanded that the
higher ranked dragon should be introduced
first.
But hailstorm wasn't even listed in the
rankings anymore.
His name had been scratched out along
with all the other murdered ice wing
prisoners.
But surely the correct introduction was
still hailstorm and winter, wasn't it?
The guard saved him the trouble.
Hillstorm?
He blinked and rubbed his eyes
violently.
Aren't you hailstorm?
I guess.
Hailstorm answered, in the least
convincing tone of voice possible.
The guard couldn't hide how rattled he
was, although he did his best.
My apology, sir, he said, bowing.
We believed you were dead.
It is a wondrous day indeed that you are
returned to us.
We should report straight to the queen
Winter said.
She'll want to be woken for this, if
she's not still awake.
Thousands of years ago, Ice Wings must
have been restricted to daylight hours, or
as some speculated, perhaps their night
vision had once been stronger, but nobody
said that too loud, lest it sound like
criticism of the animus gifts or the
royal family.
But ever since the gift of light, they
could stay up all night long if they
wanted to, and many of them did, seizing
every hour they could for working and
training.
Queen Glacier is on a diplomatic mission
the guard said, flinching in a strange
embarrassed way.
Her brother Narwhal is overseeing palace
matters in her absence.
Right now, he's at work on the rankings
in the courtyard.
Our father, Winter thought.
Beside him hailstorm's wings twitched.
Thank you, Winter said to the guard, with
a small nod.
The older ice wing looked slightly
outraged, but he stepped aside and let
them pass without further comment.
It wasn't until they were through the
gates, that Winter realized he might have
handled that interaction entirely wrong.
He'd approached it with his last known
rank in mind.
He'd been in the 2nd circle the day he
left for Jade Mountain Academy.
But perhaps his position had slipped in
his time away.
Especially if Queen Glacier knew what had
happened with Icicle.
If he'd fallen into a circle below that
of the guard, Winter should have been
much more deferential.
But surely it couldn't have dived so low
in just a few weeks, could it?
Into the 6th circle?
Winter, I'd only ever gone that low after
hailstorm's capture.
Hailstorm was silent as they flew through
the vast entrance hall, spiraling down
toward the 3 arched openings that led to
the central courtyard.
Winter glanced sideways at him, wondering
if the familiar surroundings were helping
clarify his memories.
All around them, pale blue stars seemed
to be drifting slowly through the
otherwise bare, translucent walls of the
palace.
It wasn't until you got close to the
walls that you could see the small glass
snowflakes encased in the ice, glowing
silvery blue as they fell, mimicking the
weather outside.
This was the gift of elegance, which
winter appreciated for its beauty, but
thought was a waste of magic.
The phosphorescent snowflakes must have
been created, in a time when ice wings
were comfortable, and did need anything
more urgent, a time when they thought
they would always have animus dragons, or
perhaps it was enchanted by an animus who
was artistic, but not very practical.
Ice wing history included a few animus
dragons, who chose their gifts against
the wishes of their queens.
The gift of subsistence was one.
A trio of holes in the ice located on the
outskirts of the kingdom, where the
poorest, weakest ice wings could reach
into the dark ocean beneath, and always
pull out a seal.
No ice dragon who cared about the
rankings.
In other words, no aristocrat, would ever
accept food that came so easily to their
claws, however.
It was a gift that only benefited the
lowest of the kingdom, which made it seem
narrow minded and useless to all the ice
wings winter knew.
But perhaps it would seem like a kinder
wiser gift in the eyes of the other
tribes, rain wings, for instance, who
took care of one another so easily, and
had, apparently, no hierarchy at all.
Winter thought uncomfortably of all the
dragons and possibility, like the wounded
mudwing, who could use a source of food
like that.
Stop thinking about other tribes.
Father will smell doubt on you.
Winter had once dreamed that he was an
animus dragon, and in his dream, he gave
his tribe the gift of observation.
A scavenger den in the ice kingdom
constructed so the scavengers could
survive without freezing, a perfect setup
for winter to study them.
That was probably another example of a
gift that a queen wouldn't approve of.
A couple of dragons in the hall did a
double take as the brothers flew by, but
Hailstorm didn't seem to notice.
He swept unerringly through the center
archway into the snow covered courtyard, a
vast space dominated by the 2 most
important animus gifts and ice wing
history, the gifts of light, and order.
As a young dragonette, Winter had loved
to climb the tree of light, his small
serrated claws would dig into the ice of
the trunk and propel him up into the
branches, where he could curl up and
pretend he was sitting on one of the
moons.
Sometimes he would imagine he was the
animus who'd created the tree, a dragon
named Frostbite, according to his history
tutor, who had spent more time and care
on her gift than perhaps any other animus
the tribe had ever seen.
She had an enchanted the eyes to sculpt
itself, like the designers of the palace
or the great ice cliff.
She'd spent years painstakingly carving
the tree with her own claws, each branch
in twig and frost kissed leaf.
For the 1st time, Winter wondered if
frostbite had left the kingdom for a
while to study real trees.
He'd spent enough time in actual forests
now, to realize that she had gotten the
details exactly right.
The magic came once the tree was
finished.
The animus touch gave the tree a kind of
eternal life, and most important, the
moon globes that grew on it all year
round.
To Winter's surprise, Hailstorm went to
the tree and picked a globe right away
like most dragons did when they 1st
arrived at the palace.
Did that mean his instincts were kicking
in?
The glow floated quietly over his left
shoulder, casting pale light that
accentuated the shadows between his
horns.
Winter followed, choosing a light of his
own, and releasing it over his own
shoulder, a small bud appeared instantly
in its place on the branch, where a new
moon globe would grow within a day or
two.
He turned and realized that everyone in
the courtyard was staring at them.
He hadn't even noticed the quiet murmur
of conversation in the air. until it
abruptly stopped. 9 ice wings watched in
silence as hailstorm and winter walked
under the tree and down the long path to
the wall of rankings.
Standing in front of the rankings
watching them approach with a cold
unreadable expression, was their father
Narwhal.
Winter didn't wait for hailstorm to bow
first, whatever their respective ranking
was in whoever's mind, he couldn't face
his father's gaze anymore, he dropped
into a crouch, spread his wings, and
bowed his head.
The wet snow crept between his scales
comforting and chilling at the same
time.
Beside him, more slowly, Hailstorm did
the same.
In the long silence that followed, Winter
imagined he could hear glaciers moving
the world spinning, the stars weeping
softly.
What is father thinking?
He didn't dare look up.
He knew Narwhal's expression wouldn't
hold any clues anyway.
So, Narwhal finally hissed, in a voice
that could slice an iceberg in half, my 2
sons have returned to me.
One I thought would never come back, the
other I hoped, never would.
Winter lifted his eyes, shocked into
meeting narwhal's gaze, behind his father
the 7 circles of dragonette rankings
blazed like comets against a dark sky.
This wall was the gift of order, where
every dragon in the aristocracy was
listed.
Their names were all carved into the ice
but enchanted, so that the queen and her
chosen advisors could slide them around
like beads on an abacus.
Every dragonette that hatched appeared
here as soon as he or she was given a
name.
Every night, the queen considered the
current standings and changed them
according to the rules and her own
judgment.
Winter spotted his name right away.
In dead last, at the bottom of the 7th
circle, was icicle's name, and one step
above her, 2nd to last, lower than all
the new hatched dragonettes on the list
lower than any royal had ever been before
was winter.
Chapter 21.
A gust of wind swept a cloud across one
of the moons, and it began to snow
harder.
Winter stared down at the tracks of
dragon prints that crisscrossed the
courtyard.
He couldn't think.
He could barely breathe.
We did not think you could possibly be
alive, Hellstorm.
Narwhal said, inspecting his older son
from wings to claws.
Congratulations on your survival.
The queen will be pleased to welcome you
back to her army.
Hailstorm swept his tail in a slow arc
through the snow, his head drooping
lower.
As for you, winter, Narwhal went on, we
have heard a lot of stories about your
behavior.
Perhaps you can clarify some of them for
us.
Attacking your own sister at Jade
Mountain Academy, leaving the school
without your queen's permission.
Traveling with a night wing.
Leading the rain wing straight to
Icicle's hiding place, so she could be
imprisoned, and then abandoning her
unconscious in the rainforest, where any
night wing might have murdered her.
Disappearing into Pireo without
consulting your queen.
Consorting with dragons from other tribes
gone for days with no message sent home
and no oversight or explanation for your
behavior.
He took a step toward winter, his talons
crunching in the snow.
What were we supposed to think?
How are we supposed to account for you in
the rankings?
What choice?
Did the queen have?
He swept one wing toward the wall.
That's where she's gone, Winter
realized.
Queen Glacier is in the rainforest to
deal with the icicle situation.
He wondered if his sister was still
asleep, and whether Scarlet had returned
to torment her dreams.
How would the queens decide to punish his
sister for everything she had done?
Queen Glory wasn't likely to accept
demotion to the bottom of the 7th circle
of the rankings as sufficient justice.
No one but an ice wing would understand
what that meant.
Father, Hailstorm said suddenly.
I see I am no longer listed in the
rankings, but may I have permission to
speak?
Narwhal inclined his head.
Briefly, if you please.
My brother acted rashly, and without
oversight, said Hailstorm, but he did so
to save my life.
I would have been executed within hours
if he had not saved me in time.
He was courageous, and honorable in his
time away from the ice kingdom.
I am prepared to attest to that before
the queen.
His eyes flickered sideways to winter.
The only betrayal that he was not telling
the entire truth.
Winter knew he couldn't possibly approve
of Winter's friendship with Kibley, Moon
and Kinkaju, but would he hide it to
protect Winter?
Was he expecting winter to hide the truth
about pyrite in exchange?
Come to my chambers, Narwhal said, shaking
snow off his wings.
Tell me the whole story there.
Winter, go to your room, and I will
summon you shortly.
Hailstorm shot Winter another significant
look as he followed their father away.
A minute later, the other ice wings in
the courtyard had dispersed, leaving
winter alone.
He spent several minutes scanning the
rankings, taking note of what had changed
in his absence.
His cousin Snowfall was the new top of
the 1st circle on the dragonette side
which was disheartening, as she was
already abundantly blessed with mean
smugness.
Lynx was in 2nd place behind Snowfall, and
that was much better news.
She was only the daughter of a minor
noble, but a hard worker, and very
smart.
On the adult side, he saw that his
parents had fallen several spots, nearly
into the 3rd circle, which meant they
were almost in danger of losing their
right to live in the palace.
That's our fault, he realized.
Having me and Icicle at the bottom of our
rankings reflects badly on them.
We drag them down.
No wonder father's so angry.
At least Winter thought he was angry.
It was hard to tell.
Narwhal's outward demeanor was much the
same whether he was proud or furious.
That wasn't quite the homecoming I was
hoping for.
He admitted to himself, but he hadn't
exactly expected a parade either.
A nod of approval was as much as his
imagination had been able to come up with
but apparently that was still hoping for
too much.
He dragged himself through the palace to
his old room, bowing low to everyone he
passed, most of whom were too startled by
his appearance to respond.
In a way, it did make things simple, being
at the very bottom.
He didn't have to keep the list memorized
when he knew that everyone was above
him.
He hoped seeing his old room would cheer
him up.
But instead it struck him as a bare
joyless box.
They seemed to have shrunk while he was
away.
The one window overlooked the courtyard
which he definitely did not want to look
at right now.
The snowflakes in the walls had become a
blizzard, matching the oncoming snowstorm
outside.
Winter set the moon globe on his desk
turning it one rotation to dim the light
to a sleep appropriate glow.
He dropped onto the shelf of ice that
served as a bed, and then after an
uncomfortable minute, he got up and
pulled the 2 polar bear rugs up onto the
bed with him.
Perhaps sleeping in grass had made him
soft, but he was too tired to punish his
aching bones anymore.
He curled into the warm white fur
remembering the bright colors of the
rainforest, the busy sounds and smells of
possibility.
The voices calling and talons thumping
through the halls of the Jade Mountain
Academy.
The flash of silver scales against black
dark eyes in the moonlight.
The fire that roared forth to protect her
friends.
Don't dream about Moon, he told himself
with his last waking thought, and then
fell asleep knowing perfectly well that
he would, and unable to feel anything but
relief at the prospect.
He had expected to be prodded into
wakefulness with sharp claws by some
messenger from his father.
So it was unsettling to wake up slowly
and realized that morning light was
pouring through the window.
It was even more unsettling to roll over
and find his mother's eyes fixed on him
from only a few inches away.
Winter let out a yelp and set up fast
knocking one of the rugs to the floor.
Tundra frowned at it for a moment, looking
more puzzled than disapproving, and
finally kicked it out of her way with one
foot.
The sky wing teeth in her necklace made
the jittery, small, clattering sound they
always made when she moved, a sound that
still made winter want to run and hide in
a snowbank.
The sun has been out for an hour, she
said.
Winter took a deep, stabilizing breath
and tried to match her flat.
Here is some information tone.
I did not stop to sleep after finding
Hillstorm. said.
We flew home as fast as we could.
Apart from one detour to drop an injured
rain wing, in a town of overlapping
dragon tribes that you would hate on
site.
He wondered how Kinkaju was doing, and
whether she'd woken up yet.
Tundras studied him for a moment with her
stormy gray eyes.
Good, she said at length.
No apologies, but now it is time to
rise.
There will be a ceremony in the courtyard
in 7 minutes that you must attend.
Yes, mother, Winter said, stepping off
the bed shelf.
A ceremony, most likely restoring
hailstorm to the rankings, but where?
At the top, where he'd been when he was
captured?
Winter hoped he'd get to see Snowfall's
face if that happened.
That would make the torture of a rankings
ceremony worthwhile.
His mother paused in the doorway and gave
him another assessing look.
Finally, she said, Thank you for bringing
Hillstorm home.
What is this feeling?
Winter wondered.
Elation?
Pride?
He'd never felt anything quite like this
swelling in his chest before.
He dared to give her the smallest of
smiles.
Tundra blinked slowly.
It was the least you could do.
She added, and then she turned and left.
Winter could practically hear Kibley's
voice in the room beside him.
So that didn't last very long.
He startled himself by laughing.
I'd better not do that again.
Not in front of mother and father.
I'm going to have to work harder than
ever to climb back up the rankings.
He scooped some snow off the windowsill
and rubbed it all over his scales
polishing them as clean as he could get
them in 3 minutes.
He made it down to the courtyard 2
minutes before the ceremony.
Almost every dragonette in the palace was
there, lined up in order, wings folded in
attention position.
He found his way to the end of the line
in the back corner farthest from the
rankings wall.
The tiny dragonettes back there with him
gave him curious looks, and whispered to
one another in voices that were really
not whispers at all.
Adult dragons were gathered around the
perimeter of the courtyard.
More than were ever usually present for a
dragonette ranking ceremony.
The sun glinted off white scales in many
of the windows, indicating that even more
were watching from overhead.
They want to see how father will handle
this situation, Winter thought.
Can he be impartial with his own son?
Will everyone still think his decision is
fair?
Tundra, Narwhal, and Hailstorm, swept
into the courtyard in a triangle
formation, with narwhal at the front?
This was something winter had seen so
many times growing up, but had never
expected to see again.
Their tails swept majestically through
the snow, leaving long, snaking trails
behind them.
Narwhal pivoted to face the gathered
dragonettes, who all fell instantly
silent.
We have some changes to make to the
rankings of which you all should be
aware.
Winter's father said.
His resonant voice echoing around the
courtyard.
He sounded just like Queen Glacier
straight to business, without any
meandering preambles.
Several months ago.
A dragonette was removed from the wall
due to reports of his death.
He has now returned to us, alive after
all.
This is my son, Queen Glacier's nephew
Hailstorm.
Norwhal indicated Winter's brother with a
sideways flick of his wing.
Therefore, he must be added back to the
rankings.
He turned to Tundra, who flexed her claws
ready to write.
At the time of his capture, Hailstorm was
in 1st place.
Winter risked craning his neck to see
snowfall, right at the front of the
crowd.
Her face was turned away from him, but he
could see rigid tension all the way
through her spine and wings.
But he has been without oversight for
almost 2 years, and by his own admission
and that time has not behaved according
to our ice wing standards.
We must also factor in the clumsiness of
allowing himself to be caught by sky
wings in the 1st place.
Winter flinched.
What a thing for hailstorm to hear upon
his homecoming.
Therefore, after careful consideration
Narwhal announced, we are slotting
Hailstorm into last place in the 7th
circle.
May he claw his way back up with his own
talents.
A collective gasp and a murmur of
bewilderment ran through the gathered
dragons.
Even the most rigorously trained ice
wings couldn't suppress their reactions.
No one had ever, ever expected to see
hailstorm's name at the bottom of the
rankings list.
Tundra bent toward the wall, scratching
hailstorm's name below icicles.
Wow.
Winter felt faintly dizzy.
It had to be unprecedented in ice wing
history for one set of parents to have
all 3 of their nearly grown dragonettes
in the last 3 spots.
This would be devastating for tundras and
narwhals rankings as well.
Would they all have to move out of the
palace?
Where would they be assigned?
What would mother and father do if they
were no longer advisors to the queen?
At least no one could accuse Narwhale of
sentimentality or favoritism.
Hailstorm was watching their mother with
a perfectly impassive expression.
Did he remember that he'd once been on
track to be ranked even higher than his
parents?
No one had ever been number one in the
Dragonette rankings for as long as he had
been.
Expectations had been high for where he
might climb once he turned 7 and shifted
to the adult rankings.
A deep chill suddenly ran through winter
scales, turning seven.
He'd completely forgotten.
He hadn't even thought about how old
Hellstorm was.
Hailstorm's 7th hatching day was only 12
days away.
And wherever he was in the rankings on
that day, would determine the course of
the rest of his life.
Could even hailstorm rise back to the top
that fast?
Would he choose to risk the trial?
Or would he be exiled to an island
outpost 2 weeks from now?
Perhaps winter had rescued his brother
from one terrible fate, only to doom him
to another.
One more announcement, father said
brusquely.
Another dragonette was recently shifted
to the bottom of the list due to
unsupervised, unauthorized activity.
However, new light has been shed on his
behavior for the last week.
According to the newest information, he
has conducted himself with courage and
intelligence befitting an ice swing.
While we cannot approve of any dragonette
acting outside approved orders as he
has.
In this case, the final result, returning
a missing dragon to the tribe, outweighs
our disapproval.
Winter could scarcely believe his father
was talking about him.
The balance of praise to criticism, had
never tilted in his direction before.
Would this get him back up to the 4th
circle?
Maybe even the third?
Therefore, we are obligated to adjust his
ranking accordingly.
All present advisors have been
consulted.
And by general agreement, We are slotting
my other son, winter, into 1st place. in
the rankings.
Tundra lifted her talents and stabbed
Winter's name on the wall.
With a crackling sound and a shower of
icy sparks, she slid the name sideways
and up, flapping her wings to reach the
very top of the 1st circle.
First place.
Me?
What?
Hundreds of eyes were staring at winter
now.
The crowd reaction was less shocked than
the reaction to hailstorms placement.
Other dragons had performed deeds worthy
of jumping to the front of the rankings
before, although perhaps there was an
undercurrent of surprise that it was
winter, of all dragonettes who'd managed
it.
Did I really earn it though?
Winter wondered.
What did Hailstorm tell them?
Also, although he didn't want to admit
this to himself, he couldn't fight off
the lurking suspicion that this was truly
narwhal's way of maintaining his own
status, a son in 1st place would
counterbalance the weight of one and last
and if the story of his heroic rescue was
impressive enough, it might even drag
tundra and narwhal back up a few
numbers.
Winter, his father said, indicating the
front row with his tail, Winter wondered
if he was the only one who could hear the
tiny note of impatience in narwhal's
voice.
He spread his wings and rose into the air
feeling the wide eyed gaze of baby
dragonettes following him.
As he flew to the front, he passed
Hailstorm in midair, but his brother only
nodded on his way by.
The glare winter got from snowfall should
have melted all the ice in the
courtyard.
She edged sideways to let him take her
spot, fuming.
First place.
Number one.
It was really up there.
His own name shining at the very top of
the rankings.
Maybe I can take a minute to enjoy it
even if I'm not quite sure how I got
there.
He gave Snowfall a dazzling smile, and
she hunched her wings with a scowl.
On her other side, Lynx smiled back
mouthing the words, so great.
Narwhal cleared his throat.
As per the usual protocol, the queen will
review the new assignments upon her
return, which we anticipate will be
tomorrow.
Further changes may be in order then.
Winter saw his mother glance at Icicle's
name, then drop an expressionless mask
over her features, but for now, these are
your new rankings.
Dragonettes dismissed.
The courtyard instantly filled with a
murmur of shocked conversations.
Winter saw a few older, extremely high
ranked dragons coming toward him.
He wished he could cover himself in snow
and hide.
Well, Snowfall said, looking down her
nose at a spot just behind his left ear
that was unexpected.
Yes, he agreed.
Congratulations, Link said.
You must have had such an adventure.
She had an unusual pattern of dark blue
scales scattered across her white snout
and wings.
Winter had always found them pretty, but
now they just reminded him of Moon's
silver scales.
He wished he could tell Moon that he was
number one in the rankings, although, of
course, that wouldn't mean anything to
her.
Indeed, said Snowfall.
I can't wait to hear all the details.
On that ominous note, winter was swept
into a whirlwind of congratulations
questions, bowing, and advice.
Every adult dragon in the palace had an
opinion on how to maintain your spot, and
many of them had suggestions for his
future, if he could keep 1st place all
the way until his 7th hatching day.
Behind them, snowfall's smirk clearly
expressed that she didn't expect it to
last even a week.
One week.
Kibley's voice echoed in Winter's head.
He still had 5 days to decide to go back
to them, for since one would be needed
for traveling.
What am I thinking?
No one would ever leave after reaching
1st place.
This is every ice wing dragonette's
dream.
Firmly, he focused his mind on the nobles
around him.
Was it hours later that the courtyard
finally cleared?
The last noble gave him a respectful nod
and flew away.
Only a few dragonettes remained, including
snowfall and hailstorm, who were both
staring at their rankings, as if they
could reshape them with the sheer force
of their eyeballs.
Winter's stomach ached with hunger, but
he needed to talk to Hillstorm before
going hunting.
Maybe they could even go together.
One of the things Winter had missed most
while Hailstorm was away.
Was the dragonette in 1st place allowed
to hunt with a dragonette in last?
Could he lose his new ranking if he
associated with someone in the 7th
circle?
There had never been such a gap between
family members before.
So I wasn't quite sure what the protocol
should be.
But he was going to talk to Hailstorm
anyway.
The watching dragons could eat the moons
if they cared.
He needed to reassure his brother that
climbing back up their rankings could be
done and remind him that it had to be
done fast, in case hailstorm's muddled
memory couldn't recall his hatching day.
The snow was packed down by the 100s of
dragon feet that had passed through this
morning.
Shards of blue sunlight reflected off the
tallest towers, illuminating odd
splotches of the courtyard.
Snowfall watched the brothers with
slitted eyes as winter slid up to
Hillstorm.
Are you all right?
Winter whispered.
Hailstorm frowned at him.
That's not a very ice wing question, he
pointed out.
He hesitated and then bowed deeply to
Winter.
Stop it.
Stand up.
Winter hissed.
What a horrible feeling to have his
exceptional older brother bowing to him
like that.
It made the whole world feel out of order
as if the palace had been flipped upside
down.
He tried to hide how flustered he was as
hailstorm stood back up.
It seems like a good sign that you
remember what is and isn't a nice wing
question.
He pointed out.
Of course I do.
Hailstorm said in a distant way.
Everything is very clear.
Now that I'm home.
And yet, the way he glanced at the sky?
Winter wondered if he had really shaken
off all those sky wing memories yet.
Perhaps he remembered how to be a nice
wing, but he hadn't yet found his way
back to being hailstorm.
The brother Winter had missed for so long
would have had a laughing comment about
Winter's new rank.
Hillstorm.
Winter said hesitantly.
What did you tell mother and father?
He wished they'd thought to compare
stories before coming home.
He needed to know what he should say
about pyrite and where hailstorm had been
for the last 2 years.
I told them the truth.
Hailstorm drew himself up, looking
offended.
What else would I tell them?
The truth about everything?
Winter asked, about, about my friends
too.
Hailstorm's expression now was pure Ice
Wing.
If that's what you want to call them, he
spat, yes, I told them about your little
band of misfits.
I hoped they would promote you up the
rankings.
I owed you that much, but I did not
expect them to raise you so high, not
with the entire truth in front of them.
He fell silent, scowling at the wall
again.
This is so interesting, isn't it?
Snowfall strutted toward them.
Casting arch looks at the circles. 3
moon's hailstorm.
I bet you feel so peculiar right now.
Leave him alone, Winter growled.
She laughed.
There's not quite enough distance between
our numbers for you to be giving me
orders, she said.
Her snout was smiling, but her voice was
all murderous stalactites.
Besides, she added, I'm sure I won't be
the only dragon who wants to ask
Hailstorm about the diamond trial.
Are you considering it?
Hellstorm, dear?
With only 12 days until you're 7?
I certainly hope so.
Hailstorm didn't answer her.
Winter wondered if he remembered what the
trial was.
It had never been attempted in Winter's
lifetime.
He wasn't even sure it had happened in
his father's lifetime.
It was so rare for a dragonette to still
be in the 6th or 7th circle when he
reached his 7th hatching day, and rarer
still, for any dragonette that inadequate
to risk his life on the mysterious
trial.
But Hailstorm wasn't inadequate.
It was pure bad luck that had him so low
right now.
Whatever the trial involved, surely he
could conquer it easily.
I mean, if you succeed, you'll move up to
1st place.
Snowfall said archly, your life would be
right back on track instantaneously.
You're going to do it, aren't you?
Winter asked his brother.
He couldn't understand why Hailstorm was
staring fixedly down at his talons.
Oh, how funny.
I wouldn't have thought you'd want him to
Snowfall went on, her voice sugary sweet
and mocking.
Have you forgotten that the diamond trial
must also be undertaken by defending
Challenger?
That's whoever is currently in 1st place
of course, but only one dragon can
survive the trial.
Dear me.
It means it'll be brother against brother
won't it?
Tisk, tisk.
What a conundrum for poor Hellstorm.
Winter felt ice grip his heart and spread
down to his talons, rooting him to the
snow.
He had forgotten about that part of the
trial rules, or rather, it had never
occurred to him that he might be on the
other end, the defending 1st place
dragonette, instead of the struggling
lower circle challenger.
But Hailstorm knew exactly how it
worked.
He knew it would have to be him or winter
that only one could survive.
And of course, Winter's parents did too.
This was their plan.
To move a dragon into 1st place, who
would be no trouble for hailstorm to
defeat.
Snowfall was Glacier's daughter, and
formidable in her own way.
Only a few months from her hatching day
but winter.
Winter was expendable.
Sacrifice one brother.
To save the other.
They couldn't give both of us high
rankings.
Someone would have called it unfair.
This is more dramatic, more like my
parents.
A higher risk for much higher gain.
They had to do it.
Hailstorm's future is too valuable to
throw away.
He understood his parents' motivations
completely.
Whatever happened at the diamond trial
they'd end up with a son in 1st place, and
they'd get rid of a disgraceful last
place offender.
But hailstorm.
His brother finally looked up at him, with
his blue eyes sharp and alert once
again.
This is what you told me to do.
His eyes seemed to say, You wanted me to
be a true ice wing again.
Well, here I am.
And without a word, Hailstorm turned and
left the courtyard, leaving winter behind
as a new snow softly began to fall.
Chapter 22.
The summons arrived later that day.
Hillstorm's messenger found winter on one
of the tallest spires, gloomily picking
apart the seal he'd caught.
He hadn't been able to find anywhere else
to eat in peace.
Everywhere he went, dragons bowed or
hurried over to offer him things, or
buzzed around with a 1000000 questions.
And as the day wore on, he'd heard the
whispered phrase more and more.
The diamond trial, the diamond trial.
Every dragon over the age of 3 knew what
it was, but no one could give him any
details.
The trial was shrouded in mystery, and
there was no one left in the palace who'd
survived it, since it hadn't been used in
so long.
Prince Winter, said a clipped voice
behind him, shaking Winter out of his
thoughts.
The messenger handed over a small slab of
ice, marked with precisely carved
letters.
She stepped back and bowed deeply.
Good luck, sir.
According to the brief, impersonal
message.
The trial was scheduled for sunset the
next day.
What would happen if I did something
terrible between now and then?
Winter wondered, if I snubbed the wrong
dragon, or dripped seal blood in the
pristine courtyard, or broke one of the
queen's ice sculptures?
Would I drop down the ranks?
Would someone else have to face the trial
with hailstorm?
He had a feeling nothing like that would
work.
The plan was in motion.
And Narwhal wouldn't put snowfall into
the trial, no matter what winter did
Queen Glacier would be too furious if she
came back and found her daughter's life
in jeopardy.
And if he fled, or tried to refuse the
challenge, he brings shame upon his whole
family, and caused Hailstorm any chance
he had at climbing their rankings before
his hatching day.
For a moment, winter turned the message
slab over in his talons, and then he
spread his wings.
The only thing he could do was fight.
Fight for his new position at the top of
the rankings, fight for his family's
melting honor, fight for his own life.
It was what Hailstorm and his parents
would want him to do, even if they hoped
he would lose in the end.
He still had to go down like an ice wing
warrior.
He spent the rest of the day in the
palace library, looking for the diamond
caves mentioned in the summons.
He'd never heard of them, but there they
were, on an old map.
If the ice kingdom's peninsula was shaped
like a dragon's head, the caves were
located where her frost breath would come
out.
Diamond Caves.
The most famous diamond and ice wing
history was Queen Diamond, the mother of
Prince Arctic, the animas who had been
stolen by Foe Slayer, and the Night
Wings.
As a young dragon, Queen Diamond had
given the tribe the gift of healing, 5
narwhal horns enchanted to cure frost
breath injuries, in case any ice wing
ever wounded another, but there had been
a few other diamonds over the years as
well.
He wondered if the caves and the trial
were named after one of the historic
diamonds, and why.
He slept poorly that night, troubled by
dreams of moon, and Kibley, and hailstorm
all in danger, their scales melting and
shifting into other colors, as he
searched for them in the halls of the ice
palace.
Every time he woke, he wondered why he
hadn't been visited by Scarlet again.
He could only imagine her wrath when she
discovered that pyrite hailstorm was
gone.
The next morning he found links, and
asked her to train with him.
The familiar fighting patterns came
naturally, and focusing on her attacks
helped drive out all the other worries in
his head.
They leaped and wrestled in the snow
outside the palace until they were
exhausted.
Afterward, as they washed each other's
dark blue blood off their claws and
scales, they heard wing beats and looked
up.
Queen Glacier was back.
Behind her flew 2 generals, and icicle.
Winter watched them soar into the
palace.
He wondered what the queen would think of
narwhal scheme.
Would she stop it?
Would she rearrange their rankings before
sunset?
Could she do that?
Even with a summons already issued?
If she could, she didn't.
A few hours later, she was among the 12
dragons assembling in the courtyard to
fly to the diamond caves.
Prince Winter, she said, and he bowed as
deeply as he could.
The ice wing queen was huge and majestic
far more beautiful and imposing than any
other queen in Pyria.
He wondered if he was only imagining that
he could see sympathy in her eyes.
You've served the tribe well, returning
Prince Hailstorm to us, she said, I wish
you luck in the trial.
Thank you, Your Majesty.
He said.
There was an uncomfortable prickle at the
back of his neck, that he suspected meant
hailstorm was nearby, staring at him.
You will fly alongside me on the way to
the caves, she said.
I wish to hear about everything that has
happened since you left us for Jade
Mountain.
I've heard your sister's version of
events, but I suspect another perspective
would be instructive.
Yes, Your Majesty, he said.
May I ask what's going to happen to
Icicle?
She looked grave.
It's a good question.
Queen Glory is not like other queens.
I thought she would demand icicles
execution, but instead she said she would
leave icicles punishment, entirely to me
in exchange for something unusual.
A cutting from our moon globe tree.
What does that mean?
Winter asked.
I wasn't sure either, said the Queen.
Apparently with plans.
You can take a piece of it, and bury that
somewhere else, and then a new plant will
grow from that piece.
The idea, I think, is that she wants to
grow moon globe trees in her rainforest
to bring the gift of light to the rain
wings and night wings.
Oh, Winter said, startled.
He didn't know quite how to wrap his head
around this.
Will it work?
It might, said Queen Glacier.
The tree is enchanted to behave like a
real tree.
And I can see how such a thing would
benefit her tribes greatly.
Although, as I said, it's an unusual
queen who would choose a path toward
peace and cooperation over clear and
simple vengeance.
She flicked her wings, frowning
thoughtfully.
The question is whether her tribes will
be satisfied with this solution.
I suppose we'll see.
It may partly depend on how I ultimately
punish icicle, but I haven't decided that
yet.
They lifted off into a cloudy gray sky
flying southwest, with tundra and narwhal
in the lead, and hailstorm trailing at
the back, as befitted his last place
ranking.
Winter had to struggle to keep up with
Queen Glacier's pace, but she didn't seem
to notice.
And since he had a feeling he was about
to die, He told her almost everything
about icicle trying to kill Starflight
and how winter stopped her, about the
rainforest and the volcano, about going
in search of Scarlet, meeting Pyrite, and
encountering the mysterious night wing in
the valley.
He left out a few things, though, Moon's
powers and her prophecy.
The fact that his friends were waiting
for him in possibility at that very
moment, the way he felt about them
especially Moon.
The queen only stopped him once during
his story.
Who?
she asked.
He paused, startled.
Your majesty?
You said there was an ice wing with the
talons of peace.
Queen Glacier shot a glance at the hole
in the clouds where a piece of sunlight
had muscled through.
Who was it?
His name was Sirius, Winter answered.
I didn't know him, and he didn't know
me.
He was confusing.
We haven't had a seris in many years, the
queen mused.
And I don't recall any ice wings leaving
us for the talons of peace. unless they
were from the lower classes, outside the
rankings.
Perhaps that's why I don't know him.
Or perhaps he changed his name.
He acted like an aristocrat, winter
said.
It hadn't even occurred to him that
Sirius might be from the outskirts of the
ice kingdom.
That would explain why he didn't tell
winter his ranking, though.
He implied that he knew my parents, but
in a way that seemed like he was lying.
Hmm, Queen Glacier said.
I'll look into it Go on.
Most of the clouds had cleared, and the
sky was shading into a brilliant orange
red, when they finally dove out of the
sky toward a snow covered evergreen
forest, clustered at the base of an
enormous white cliff.
Pine needles jabbed Winter's snout as he
dropped through the trees to the forest
floor.
The scent of the pines surrounded them
and the snow crunched, like crushed paper
under their talons.
He thought of the pyrite scroll spell, now
carefully tucked away in the skyfire
pouch around his ankle.
A cave mouth yawned in the side of the
cliff, glittering with stalactites as
sharp as teeth, eyes cover the walls
floor, and ceiling all the way into the
tunnel, as far as winter could see before
darkness took over.
He touched the moon globe over his
shoulder. making sure it was there and
still working.
Prince his winter and hailstorm, the
queen said briskly, your task is simple.
Enter the diamond caves and search until
you find the frozen dragon by the river
chasm.
Touch one of these spears to her.
She took 2 gleaming diamond tipped spears
from one of her guards and handed them to
the brothers, one apiece.
Whoever returns shall take 1st place in
the rankings.
The other.
We bid farewell.
Huh.
Ominous and unspecific, snarked Kibley's
voice in Winter's head.
Norwhal stepped forward and tipped his
long snout down to study his son's.
Remember, be strong, he said, be vigilant
strike first.
We still are our families rank, added
tundra.
Narwhal's gaze rested on winter for a
moment.
Farewell.
He said finally.
Whichever of you does not return.
I know you will accept defeat with
honor.
Sounds great, Winter thought, feeling
lightheaded.
Always wanted some defeat with a side of
honor.
He had a feeling he should say something
here, but Hailstorm was already pivoting
and marching into the cave.
Winter glanced around at the assembled
ice wings one more time.
Was this the last time he would see his
parents?
His queen, and the sky.
When he'd said goodbye to Moon, had it
really been forever?
He found he didn't have anything to say
to his parents after all.
Winter turned in silence and followed
hailstorm into the icy tunnel.
The diamond caves, according to the one
map Winter had found, apparently
stretched for miles in a kind of
underground labyrinth with only one
exit.
Walls of ice hemmed them in on all sides
glittering blue white in the light of
their moon globes.
In places, the ceiling brushed the horns
on winter's head.
In others, they had to creep along narrow
ledges, over dark crevasses, gripping the
ice with their claws, because if they
tried to fly into that vast dark space
they might not find their way back before
tiring and falling to their deaths.
Hailstorm glanced back at winter once or
twice with a frown, as if he'd expected
winter to choose a different path.
But winter did not want to wander this
labyrinth alone, with no way to know if
hailstorm had completed the task yet or
not, better to stick together and know
for sure.
They wandered for hours, perhaps in
circles.
Perhaps in spirals ever downward.
Winter was beginning to wonder if the
frozen dragon even existed at all, when
they came out of a narrow tunnel and
found the river chasm before them.
This had to be it.
A wide slash in the ice ahead of them
with sheer walls that plunged down into a
darkness that echoed with a rushing sound
of a river.
Winter lifted his moon globe higher
scanning the cave, and felt a terrible
chill run through his veins.
The cave was filled with frozen dragons.
Nearly 100 of them, glittered in the moon
globe's light, some on this side of the
chasm, but most of them on the other
side.
The one closest to him looked like an
ordinary ice wing, with an almost
cheerful expression on his face, stepping
toward winter as though he were about to
saunter out the door.
But others were frozen in positions of
terror, their talons covering their faces
or their wings flung out as though they
were trying to leap away, and he could
see a few that had clearly been fighting
when they were frozen, wearing
expressions of fury.
There were no other ways in or out, apart
from the chasm and the tunnel behind
him.
Eerie blue bubbles morphed and twisted
within the shining ice walls, moving, as
though the cave itself was breathing.
Which statue was the frozen dragon?
Which one were they supposed to touch
with a spear?
Hailstorm was staring around at the ice
sculptures as though he were one of
them.
Winter took a step into the cave, and
noticed a sparkling pile of crushed ice
near the entrance.
He nudged his moon globe toward it
wondering why the pile was so big, and
then he saw a dragon's talon buried in
the ice, with a few of its claws snapped
off.
Maybe this one had been mid-flight when
he was frozen, and he smashed to pieces
when he fell to the ground.
Or maybe whoever froze him decided to
finish the job by bashing his frozen
corpse to smithereens.
Winter shuddered.
His tail spikes rattling along the
floor.
Suddenly, hailstorm leaped forward.
Winter whirled and saw him racing toward
a dragon on the far side of the chasm, a
dragon larger than any of the others, with
her claws outstretched, and her wings
flared.
Hailstorm sailed across the gap, landed
pivoted, and struck the statue with his
spear.
It all happened in a moment, like a burst
of lightning.
By the time winter landed beside him
Hailstorm was in battle position
brandishing the spear against whatever
happened next.
A crackling sound came from the dragon
and then, slowly, bits of ice began to
break off, splintering into falling
shards and shattering against the floor.
The frozen dragon comes to life, Winter
realized.
It made sense.
Then we fight her, and she kills one of
us, and the other wins.
He looked around at the frozen statues
and winced.
Or she freezes one of us.
These must be all the dragons who've lost
the trial, and I could be one of them
soon.
He looked back at the large frozen dragon
and realized that she was not actually
made of ice.
She was encased inside the ice, and as
her prison came apart, he saw her scales
and they were as dark as a moonless
night.
This was a night wing.
She pulled in her wings, and then flung
out her claws, shaking the last of the
ice off.
Only 2 spots still glittered against her
scales, a pair of shackles around her
back ankles, although they didn't seem to
be connected to anything.
With a hiss, she turned in a circle, then
whipped around to drop the full force of
her glare on the princes.
Oh, good.
She rasped in a hoarse voice.
More ice swing dragonettes with spears.
I'm here to kill you.
Hellstorm announced, without a tremor of
insecurity in his voice.
Aren't you all, she said dryly.
Shall we introduce ourselves first?
Hailstorm and Winter exchanged glances.
Was that normal?
Conversation with a creatively imprisoned
night wing?
I'm Prince Winter, said Winter, after an
awkward pause, and this is my brother
hailstorm.
Brothers?
Oh my, how devastating. said the night
wing.
Welcome to my prison.
I am Those Slayer.
Winter started back, his head reeling.
Foe Slayer, the same foe Slayer who stole
the Ice Wing Animus Prince, Arctic?
The mother of Dark Stalker?
Chapter 23.
You've heard of me, she observed, with a
hint of amusement.
That's your, you don't mean, Winter
couldn't seem to put the words together.
Yes, the night wing said.
You are ancient and terrible enemy.
Everyone is always surprised.
I want to know what the point is, of
abducting and freezing your arch nemesis
and then never telling anyone about it.
Don't you want to shout it from the
clouds, so everyone will know how
dangerous and powerful you are.
You can be alive after all this time
though.
Winter finally managed to get out.
She folded in her wings.
A curl of smoke rose from her snout.
After a moment, she said, No, don't tell
me.
I don't want to know how long it's been.
I'll never see them again anyway.
Her tail flicked toward the icy cave
walls.
It's part of your queen's gift, ice
wing.
I've been frozen in time, so I only age
in the moments when I'm unfrozen like
this.
The plan, evidently, is to keep me here a
very, very long time.
Thousands of years.
Winter thought, aghast.
She's been down here for 2000 years
already.
The gift of vengeance, he said.
But Queen Diamond had already given the
tribe her gift. long before her son was
stolen, which meant she must have used
her animus magic again to create this
prison, had it driven her mad?
He couldn't remember anything in the
history books about what happened to her
after Prince Arctic was gone.
Indeed, said Foslayer.
You could say my mother-in-law and I have
a complicated relationship.
He heard the scratch of claws on ice
behind him, and then suddenly there was a
blur of blue white motion.
Hailstorm launched himself at Faux Slayer
swinging the spear around to stab her
through the heart.
The night wing dodged aside and seized
the spear, jerking it out of his talons.
Hailstorm caught his balance, whirled, and
attacked again.
His claws slashed at her throat, and she
slammed the blunt end of the spear
against his side, knocking him into the
wall.
With a roar, he was up again, this time
seizing her tail, and clambering up it
onto her back, he sank his fierce claws
into the flesh between her shoulder
blades, and heaved up as though he was
trying to yank out her spine.
Thoslayer shrieked and threw herself into
a roll, tucking her wings and landing
heavily on Hellstorm.
He lost his grip on her, amid an
explosion of sharp cracks, which sounded
to winter like bones snapping.
The night wing leaped free again, and
came straight at Hailstorm, while his
underbelly was exposed.
Her back talons pinned down his tail, and
she raised the spear to impale him
through the heart.
Winter threw himself at her without a 2nd
thought, tackling her to the ground.
They rolled and twisted, and slid across
the icy floor, kicking at each other with
their claws.
You idiot, she yelled at him.
His head bashed into the cave wall, and
tears of pain sprang into his eyes.
Do ice wings get dumber every year.
Don't you want to win?
He flung her off so hard.
She spun across the ice and nearly slid
over the edge into the chasm.
That's not what I want, Winter shouted.
I don't want to win if it means hailstorm
has to die.
He whirled to face his brother, who was
on his feet and panting.
His sides splattered with red and blue
blood.
What are we fighting for?
A number on a wall?
Your life is more important to me than
the rankings hailstorm.
Hailstorm growled.
I would have said the same thing, brother
he said, but I sacrificed myself for you
once already.
And it was the worst thing that ever
happened to me.
You can't imagine how it feels to know
what I've done.
To have these memories in my head.
He clawed at his temples.
I want my life back.
I want myself back.
And I won't get it.
If I reach my hatching day in last
place.
I have to be 1st again.
The old familiar guilt with surging back
through winter.
My fault.
My fault, my fault.
I didn't think it would be you.
I'd have to destroy. in order to get back
to first.
Hellstorm admitted.
But it had to be someone.
I won't be a traitor to my tribe
anymore.
When I'm number one.
I can prove it.
Winter looked back at Foslayer, who had
slowly risen to her feet, and was
listening with a curious expression.
Is there any other way?
He asked her.
A way we can both live?
I'm not the right dragon to ask, she
said.
Frankly, I'd rather see you all dead.
I'll take last place, Winter said to
Hailstorm.
What if we told the queen that?
Would you let a switch?
Hailstorm snorted.
Where's the honor in that for me?
he asked.
No, they won't agree to it.
If we both come out of the caves, they'll
just kill one of us, and probably leave
the other and last place.
He picked up the spear Foslayer had
dropped and twisted it between his
talons.
The Nightwing breathed a jet of flame
that melted the wing of the statue
closest to her.
This is very moving.
But would one of you please kill me
already?
She paced toward them, her dark eyes
reflecting the light of their moon
globes.
I'm tired.
I haven't eaten in 100s of years, and
these days it's more painful to be awake
than to go through the process of dying
again.
Dying?
Winter asked.
Yes, she said, stopping in front of them
and spreading her wings.
You stab me, I die painfully, and then I
go back to being frozen until someone
wakes me up again.
It's a cunning enchantment.
The 1st 40 times Queen Diamond killed me
herself.
Voslayer let out a bitter chuckle.
I suspect, the original point of the
spell was that she wasn't satisfied with
killing me just once.
But then the 401st time.
There were 2 dragonettes here.
So she must have decided I could be used
for this other purpose.
Whatever you 2 are here for.
So you just get murdered?
Over and over again?
Winter asked.
That's my punishment.
Beauslayer shrugged eloquently.
Here's some advice for you.
Never make an animus angry.
Winter turned to hailstorm, puzzled.
Then how did all these other dragons get
frozen?
Maybe that's part of the spell too.
One kills Foe Slayer, and then the other
one freezes.
It seemed more complicated than the usual
animus spell.
Hailstorm's eyes were fixed on the
spear.
You do it, he said gruffly.
You kill her.
No Winter said.
Hillstorm, you're right.
You've already sacrificed yourself for
me.
I've been waiting for 2 years to make it
up to you.
Winter, Hellstorm said.
I'm not going to be responsible for your
death a 2nd time, Winter insisted.
It's my turn, and let's face it.
This is what mother and father would
want.
Hailstorm winced, but didn't argue.
Just be a great ice wing, Winter said.
Help keep the tribes at peace.
That's what I would want.
This is peculiar, Those Slayer spoke up
but not as peculiar as you might think.
I've seen a surprising amount of this
I'll die for you.
No, I'll die for you.
No, let me be the brave sacrifice.
Nonsense from ice wings over the years.
Do it, Winter said to Hellstorm.
I'm ready.
Me too, said Foslayer.
As fast and clean as you can, please.
Hailstorm took the spear, leveled it at
Thoe Slayer's heart and drove it swiftly
through her chest.
She gritted her teeth, her face twisted
in pain, and then the ice came crawling
up from the shackles on her ankles
freezing her from her tail forward to her
wings, neck, and head.
Hailstorm pulled the spear free before
the ice got there, and Winter saw the
wound heal over just before Foslayer was
completely frozen.
He closed his eyes, expecting the world
to go dark, but it didn't.
Nothing happened at all.
After a moment, he opened his eyes again
and saw a hailstorm, standing by the edge
of the chasm.
Why didn't it work?
Winter asked.
I'm not frozen.
He looked around at the other statues.
Something whispered in his mind.
An explanation, although it still didn't
quite fit together.
Right, Hailstorm said.
He turned to look at his brother.
That's because it's not part of the
original enchantment.
The spell on the night wing isn't what
froze these dragons.
He lifted the spear.
That's what these do.
That's what.
That's what I'm supposed to do to you.
Winter was silent.
Everything was starting to make a kind of
awful sense.
Mother and father told me earlier today.
Hailstorm's wings drooped to the floor.
They told me that no matter who killed
Foslayer.
I was the one chosen to win.
That I was to take this spear, and stab
you the same way I stabbed her.
Freezing you like all these other
dragons.
Then I was guaranteed, 1st place.
Do they do this every time?
Winter wondered.
Choose one dragonette to win?
Tell only that dragonette the secret of
the spears, and how to freeze the other.
He shouldn't have felt surprised. or
betrayed.
Of course his parents would choose
hailstorm.
This was really quite normal, given the
patterns of their lives so far, but it's
still.
It still hurt.
Deep inside him, where he'd thought his
family couldn't hurt him anymore.
Moon, Kibli, and Kinkachu wouldn't do
something like this to me.
He thought.
All right, he said out loud.
Then I guess that's what you have to do.
He set down his own spear and braced
himself.
You know I can't, Hellstorm snapped.
You're the one who rescued me.
You're my brother.
I'm not going to murder you now.
So you're just going to have to do it to
me.
He tossed his spirit to winter, who
jumped aside and let it clatter to the
ground.
They stared at each other for a long
moment as the rush of the river below
filled the cavern.
All the frozen dragons seemed to be
waiting, like a captive audience enjoying
the suspense.
If we can't kill each other, Winter
said.
Maybe we leave it like this.
You go out and claim victory, and I wait
to sneak out later.
We both live.
Hailstorm shook his head.
As soon as you got home, they throw me
back into last place, and probably you as
well.
I won't go home.
Winter said.
He felt a lump forming in his throat.
Like frost breath icing over his
windpipe.
I'll stay away from the ice kingdom.
It didn't sound possible.
His whole life was about being an ice
wing.
Being Queen Glacier's nephew, proving
something to tundra and narwhal.
He believed in the perfection and
superiority of the ice kingdom.
How could he ever be happy anywhere
else?
But now he'd been to so many other
places.
He'd seen the world beyond the ice
kingdom.
And it wasn't so terrible, really.
Because happiness is not where I am.
It's who I'm with.
And he knew exactly who he wanted to be
with.
Hailstorm's claws curled in and out as he
thought.
He reached out and picked up one of the
diamond tipped spears, and Winter felt a
quick bolt of fear that his brother had
decided to kill him anyway.
But Hailstorm just bowed, and took a step
backward.
Thank you, brother, he said.
I hope.
I hope one day I'll see you again.
Winter nodded, not trusting himself to
speak.
Hailstorm turned and flew across the
chasm.
In the entrance to the tunnel, he paused
glancing back at Winter, and then he fled
his footsteps echoing behind him.
A long time past.
Winter tried to keep track of the hours
in his head, calculating when it would be
dawn.
Finally, he stood up, stretched, and
picked up the other diamond tipped
spear.
Taking a deep breath, he reached out and
tapped Foe Slayer with it.
Chapter 24.
The ice around the night wing cracked and
splintered, just as it had before, and
Thoe Slayer slowly opened her eyes.
Surprise flashed across her face when she
saw winter there.
This is a first, she said.
I've never been brought back by the same
dragonettes before.
Did you want a chance to kill me too?
Seems a little over the top if you don't
mind my saying so.
Listen, Winter said.
I don't know if you even realize how much
you stole from us when you took away our
animus magic.
The gifts of light, of order, and running
like a hidden current through every
dragonette's understanding of himself, the
gift of faith in their tribe that came
from the indisputable wisdom of how ice
wings handled their magic.
Imagine what our kingdom would be like if
we still had animus dragons, Winter went
on.
What else would we have invented?
I suspect, you wouldn't have stayed in
your little kingdom much longer, Thoslayer
answered him.
Have you considered that your perfect
tribe might have used the magic for evil
as well as good?
Was that true?
Would we have done something terrible
with it?
What kind of gift might Queen Glacier
have asked for during the War of Sand
Wing succession?
He shook out his wings.
When you stole Prince Arctic, you stole
all our future gifts, everything that we
might have become.
And I can see why some dragons would
think that's unforgivable.
His scales felt heavier and heavier as he
went on.
But, this, this imprisonment, for
centuries.
Keeping you alive only to die over and
over again.
I feel like I feel like perhaps you've
been punished enough.
Foslayer turned away from him, and rested
her talons on one of the frozen
dragonettes, hiding her face.
After a moment, she said, in a muffled
fractured voice, I didn't steal him.
Prince Arctic, Winter said.
I didn't steal him.
Though Slayer lifted one wing so she
could meet Winter's eyes.
I fell in love with him.
An entire history of a tribe.
The story of a war, the foundation of an
ancient hatred.
It all shivered in winter's mind, like
stepping onto the thinnest layer of ice.
And he loved me too, Those Slayer said.
That's the truth.
Although no ice wing has ever listened
long enough to hear it before.
Everything, was splintering apart.
We didn't mean to ruin everything. she
said, or start a terrible war, or make 2
tribes hate each other for all eternity.
We just wanted to be together.
He believed her.
He wouldn't have a month ago.
But now he believed her, because he knew
exactly how that felt.
Because he could imagine throwing
everything away too, for the chance to be
with Moon.
If they dared to start something.
Could he and Moon end as badly as Foe
Slayer and Arctic?
Would he risk it?
Even after seeing where it might lead?
It's different, he told himself.
Queen Diamond cared very much what
happened to Prince Arctic.
No one cares at all what happens to me.
So now you know.
Beauslayer said, rolling the spear over
to him.
Ready to kill me?
He shook his head.
I'm getting you out of here.
The Nightwing's eyes gleamed, dark and
glittering in the light from his moon
globe.
That's impossible, I'm afraid, she said.
Every time I've tried to cross the chasm
some kind of invisible wool drives me
back.
I assume the enchantment was crafted to
keep me here forever.
Maybe, winter said.
But ice wings are careful planners
especially when it comes to animus
gifts.
I'm sure Diamond left away to free you, in
case they needed you to negotiate with
the Nightwings.
He stepped back, studying her from wings
to tail.
It must be your shackles.
That's what's been animus touched, right?
She lifted one back foot and then the
other.
Well, they're impervious to fire, she
said.
And nothing happens when I smash them
against the walls, except it makes my
angles really hurt, so I'm guessing
they're enchanted, yes.
Whatever will break them, Winter said.
I bet can only be done by a member of the
Royal Family.
If I know ice wings anyway.
But you're in luck, because that's what I
am.
He tried not to think about his name on
the rankings wall.
His name glittering at the top, and then
tundras claws scratching through it
marking him as dead.
He picked up one of the spears and
pointed it at the shackles.
Hold still.
Oh, dear, Boslayer said, closing her
eyes.
With a swift jabbing motion, Winter
struck the closest shackle with a tip of
the spear.
It bounced off, reverberating in his
claws.
The shackle looked untouched.
Winter set the spear down again, and
crouched to examine the shackles.
There was a small diamond shape indented
on the side of each one.
Carefully, he poked the diamond with one
claw, but that didn't do anything
either.
One more possibility, something only an
ice wing could do, which made it safe
because no ice wing would ever, ever free
a night wing.
He reached inside him for the lurking
snowstorm and then breathed out, covering
the diamond with frost breath.
The shackles sprang apart, clattered to
the floor, and shattered into tiny
pieces.
Foslayer sat up, staring at the other
shackle with hope and disbelief warring
in her eyes.
Wait, Winter said.
He touched the other shackle.
I should.
I have to make sure one thing.
If I free you.
You have to promise you won't go hurt any
ice wings.
I don't want a whole new cycle of
vengeance and war to start.
Do you understand?
It ends here.
I never want to see an ice wing ever
again in my whole life.
Those Slayer said fervently.
Set me free, and I'll go straight home to
the night kingdom, and you'll never see
me again.
The Night Kingdom.
The lost city of night.
Boslayer knew exactly where it was.
She could help them stop the prophecy.
Actually, Winter said, I want to come
with you.
This was his future now, not prints among
ice wings, not Queen Glacier's nephew, not
a warrior struggling his way up their
rankings, under the disapproving gaze of
his parents.
He was a dragon, who had friends from
other tribes, and he was going to save
Jade Mountain with them.
He leaned forward to breathe frost breath
on the last shackle.
Moon, Kibli, Kingajoo.
I'm coming.
Wait for me.
I'll be there soon.
Epilogue.
Alone and buried in rock.
Dark Stalker waited, and listened. 26
dragonettes remained of the 35 who had
started at Jade Mountain Academy, and
their minds were full of secrets.
In the art cave, a Nightwing wondered
where Moon Watcher and the rest of the
jade winglet had gone.
He dipped his brush and paint and worried
about the secret letter he had just
received from old friends.
Is it true?
Have they escaped Thorn's prison?
Are they really coming back soon with an
army?
And does mother know?
And will she join them?
Which side of the coup would she be on?
And would I want her to?
Or all things may be better the way they
are, even with a rain wing for our
queen.
He didn't know.
He'd have to make a choice.
Probably sooner than he wanted to.
And he had no idea what the right
decision would be.
Dark Stalker knew.
He knew which option would lead this
dragonette to a long, safe life, and
which would end in death within the
year.
He also knew which choice would be better
for his own plans.
But which path a dragonette would take.
That was still uncertain.
Outside, on the sandy bank of a mountain
stream, the mind shrouded sandwing took
off her necklace, hit it carefully under
a rock, and waded into the frigid water.
Dark Stalker narrowed in on her, knowing
this was a rare few minutes of exposure.
Cold, cold, cold.
She was cursing as she splashed.
Stupid, stupid, stupid, 3 moons.
Why is it so cold?
I've got to get back to the desert.
Abruptly out loud, she said, are you
listening?
You'd better be.
For a moment, Dark Stalker was startled
into thinking she meant him, but then she
went on.
This plan is inane.
I haven't learned anything new here, and
I can barely get near the daughter
especially after all the aggravation, with
caves exploding and other inconvenient
nuisances.
I thought I had an idea, but then he up
and vanished from the school.
You have no idea how frustrating it is.
It's like 400 other stories are going on
around me, and nobody has noticed that
I'm the one who's going to shape the
future of Pyria.
She brooded for a moment, thinking
jumbled thoughts about castles and crowns
and power.
Finally she said, There's one more
possible option.
If I stay a bit longer.
A dragonette, as loyal to that thorn
character as anyone.
And I think she's connected to one of
Thorn's generals.
She might be my inn.
I'll give it a try.
But if it gets too annoying, I'm coming
back to the Scorpion Den.
Onyx climbed out of the stream and shook
her wings furiously.
Send me a message the usual way.
She snapped.
I will be queen within the month.
Whether that old dragon helps me, or
whether I have to kill him and do it
myself.
She dropped the necklace over her head
and all dark stalker could hear was
fuzz.
Interesting.
Who was she talking to?
And how?
He wished he could tell Moon Watcher.
He wished he could tell anyone.
But with her gone, he had no one left who
could hear him.
Come back soon, little moon watcher.
Bring me my talisman, and come back
soon.
Deep in the underground lake.
Another dragonette was swimming, although
the temperature of the water didn't
bother her.
Fathoms, great, great, great, great, great
great, great, great, great, great, great
great, great, dove to the bottom, and
then shot up out of the lake, soaring to
the ceiling and spiraling back down with
a splash.
Very impressive, princess, called the sea
wing named Pike, paddling in a small
circle nearby.
Such speed and grace.
The sea wing with a skyfire bracelet
snorted from the top of a rock.
Anybody can do that, he said.
Not when you're tied to your mother, his
sister said, squirting water at him with
her talons.
I've never flown as fast as I wanted, or
soared as high as I could go.
Now I can do anything, anything I want.
Stop being such a mope, turtle.
So what if your entire winglet is gone?
You've still got us.
She thwacked her tail into the water
sending a wave over the other 3 sea wings
in the lake with her.
Unless mother comes and tries to take me
home, but I won't let her.
I won't.
I might be the most powerful dragon in
the world, and if she didn't learn that
from what I did to Whirlpool, I can teach
her some other way.
The spell on Aucklett's harness should
keep her away from me, though.
If it doesn't, I'll come up with
something stronger.
Tag, you're it.
Barracuda called, tapping anemone's tail
and racing away.
The rest of the sea wing princess
thoughts scattered into laughter and the
game.
Dark Stalker studied her possible futures
thoughtfully, then tucked them away and
moved on.
There.
Now this was the most interesting mind in
the school.
This poor dragon, pacing in an empty cave
afraid of her own scales.
Her mind was a blazing mess of flames, hot
and fierce, and self destructive.
Her dreams were haunted by hissing queen
with a melted face.
Her heart was given entirely and forever
to the only dragon she couldn't hurt.
Was she the talons of power and fire?
Dark Stalker wasn't sure.
The paths ahead of her were all confusion
like trying to follow a map into a forest
fire.
But on the other side, something
flickered through the smoke, something
like hope, something shaped, like a
scroll.
He didn't have to see exactly what would
happen.
He was already sure of one thing.
This dragon could change everything.
A letter from Smolder of the Sandwings, to
Vermilion of the Sky Wings.
On the challenges and joys of scavenger
pet ownership.
Dear Vermilion.
Greetings from the kingdom of sand to the
Sky Kingdom.
My sister tells me that you might get a
pet scavenger like mine.
It's a splendid idea.
They are highly entertaining, but I must
warn you, scavengers are not easy pets to
keep.
Mine is probably the only one to have
survived longer than 5 years.
So might I offer some advice?
Rule number one.
Protect your scavenger.
Someone will definitely try to eat her
whether by accident or not.
I recommend you clearly label your pet
with some kind of collar or bell.
If you make the color sparkly, the
scavenger will probably love it, they
adore shiny things.
Keep in mind that scavengers have no
natural weapons.
No claws, no wings, no scales, no fire
and absolutely useless teeth.
Also, they are shockingly squishy.
So do not squeeze them, even lovingly, or
shake them, even if they are very wicked
or poke them too hard.
They also love making things with their
little paws.
So rule number 2 is protect your
belongings.
If you have anything made of cloth, say, a
favorite blanket or new curtains, for
instance, keep it far out of your
scavenger's reach.
Otherwise, it will end up with holes in
it, and those scraps of cloth will be
transformed into mysterious scavenger
coverings.
They must get rather cold, as all the
scavengers I've ever seen come wrapped in
fabric at all times.
As for the care and feeding of your
scavenger, they eat a lot more than you'd
expect, for their tiny size, and they
prefer meat only after it's been set on
fire.
I offered flour a live desert mouse once
and later discovered, she'd kept it as a
pet.
They also require a daily supply fresh
water, and get very floppy, or very loud
if you forget to provide it.
Remember, scavengers are endangered, and
can be hard to acquire, as the few that
are left are increasingly skilled at
hiding from dragons.
I've heard that some are impossible to
tame too.
And of course, there are those stories
about pet scavengers trying to stab their
owners in the middle of the night.
But flower has always been a loyal
amusing pet, and I'm terribly fond of
her.
So I say don't worry about all the
rumors.
Worst case scenario.
If your scavenger is wildly annoying, you
can always eat him.
Best of luck, and do send me a picture of
your scavenger whenever you get it.
My scavenger drew this picture of us
herself.
Isn't she clever?
I like the fierce look on her little face
here.
Rather a good likeness of me too, I must
say.
Wishing you bride sun and strong winds.
Smolder.
A guide to the dragons of Pyria.
Updated and edited by Starflight of the
Night Wings.
Welcome to the Jade Mountain Academy.
At this school, you will be learning side
by side with dragons from all the other
tribes.
So we wanted to give you some basic
information that may be useful as you get
to know one another.
You have been assigned to a winglet with
6 other dragons.
The winglet groups are listed on the
following page.
Thank you for being a part of this
school.
You are the hope of Pyre's future.
You are the dragons who can bring lasting
peace to this world.
We wish you all the power of wings of
fire.
Jade Winglet.
Ice wing, winter.
Mudwing, umber, Nightwing, Moon Watcher
Rainwing, Kinkajoo, Sandwing, Kibli
Seawing, Carnelian.
Gold winglet.
Ice wing, icicle.
Mudwing, Sora, Nightwing, Big Tail, Rain
Wing, Tamarind, Sand Wing, Onyx, Sea Wing
Pike, Sky Wing, Flame.
Silver Winglet, Ice Wing, Cheng Bai, Mud
Wing, Sepia, Night Wing, Fearless, Rain
Wing, Photo, Sand Wing, Ostrich, Sea Wing
Anemone, Sky Wing, Thrush, Copper Winglet
Ice Wing, Marsh, Night Wing, Mind Reader
Rain Wing, Coconut Sandwing, prong horn
seawing, snail, skywing, peregrine, quartz
winglet, ice wing, ermine, mud wing, newt
night wing, mighty claws, rain wing
ciamang, sandwing, arid, seawing
barracuda, skywing, garnet.
Sand wings.
Description.
Pale gold or white scales, the color of
desert sand, poisonous barbed tail, forked
black tongues, abilities, can survive a
long time without water, poison enemies
with the tips of their tails like
scorpions, bury themselves for camouflage
in the desert sand.
Breathe fire.
Queen.
Since the end of the war of Sandwing
Succession, Queen Thorn.
Students at Jade Mountain, arid, onyx
ostrich, pronghorn, Kibley.
Mudwings.
Description.
Thick armored brown scales.
Sometimes with amber and gold underscales
large flat heads, with nostrils on top of
the snout.
Abilities can breathe fire if warm enough
hold their breath for up to an hour.
Blend into large mud puddles, usually
very strong.
Queen, Queen Morhen.
Students at Jade Mountain, Marsh, Newt
Sepia, Sora, Umber.
Skywings, description.
Red, gold, or orange scales, enormous
wings, abilities, powerful fighters, and
flyers, can breathe fire.
Queen, Queen Ruby.
Although some dragons still support Queen
Scarlet, who may be alive and in hiding.
Students at Jade Mountain, carnelian
flame, garnet, peregrine, thrush, sea
wings, description.
Blue or green or aquamarine scales, webs
between their claws, gills on their necks
glow in the dark stripes on their tails
snouts, underbellies.
Abilities, can breathe underwater.
See in the dark.
Create huge waves with one splash of
their powerful tails.
Excellent swimmers.
Queen, Queen Coral.
Students at Jade Mountain, Anemone
Barracuda, Pike, Snail, Turtle.
Ice wings.
Description.
Silvery scales like the moon, or pale
blue like ice, ridged claws to grip the
ice, forked blue tongs, tails narrow to a
whip thin end, abilities, can withstand
subzero temperatures and bright light
exhale a deadly frost breath, Queen, Queen
Glacier, Students of Jade Mountain, Alba
Cheng Bai, Ermine, Icicle, Winter.
Rain wings.
Description.
Scales constantly shift colors, usually
bright like birds of paradise, prehensile
tails, abilities can camouflage their
scales to blend into their surroundings
shoot a deadly venom from their fangs.
Queen, Queen Glory.
Students at Jade Mountain, Bodo, Coconut
Kinkaju, CMA, Tamarin.
Night Wings.
Description.
Purlish black scales and scattered silver
scales on the underside of their wings
like a night sky full of stars, forked
black tongues.
Abilities can breathe fire, disappear
into dark shadows.
Once known for reading minds and
foretelling the future, but no longer.
Queen, Queen Glory.
See recent scrolls on the Nightwing
Exodus and the Rainwing Royal Challenge.
Students at Jade Mountain, Big Tail
Fearless, Mighty Claus, Mind Reader, Moon
Watcher.
This is Shannon McManus.
We hope that you have enjoyed this
production of Wings of Fire, Book 7
Winter Turning, by 2ET Sutherland.
This audiobook was produced by Dion Audio
and directed by Sebastian Zetton.
Executive producer Paul R.
Gagney.
Print edition published by Scholastic
Press, an imprint of scholastic Inc.
Text copyright 2015 by 2ET Sutherland.
Production copyright 2017 by Scholastic
Inc.
All rights reserved.